THE ASSEMBLY IS
NOW IN SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM. SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL
BACKGROUND CURRY. ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BRIAN BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DAILY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
pMAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN. SUSHI
THIS AREA IN HOLD ON A
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
WORKS. RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE READ
ROBERT RE RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
TEEN VELADERO THIS VEHICLE TO A
VOEPEL WALDRON WARS WEBER.
WICKS WOULD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
ACORN IS FOR ANY. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY. TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER. WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM
YASIR KHAN YOUR MOM YES. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. WE HUNGER
FOR FREEDOM. FREEDOM FROM WAR
POVERTY AND WANT. FREEDOM FROM
LONELINESS AND DESPAIR. FREEDOM
FROM PRESSURES THAT DIVIDE AND
ALIENATE US. ALL THIS WE ASK
FOR. AS WELL AS THE COURAGE TO
FREELY ACCEPT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND BURDENS
WHICH MUST BE OURS SO THAT
OTHERS MAY BE FREE. I MEAN.
THANK YOU MA'AM YES SIR WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AS SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
IS PITCHING HOURS. NUMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE SALUTE OUR
FLAG I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND SALAS FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
FOR ALL. THANK YOU MAY SEATED.
MEDIA THE PREVIOUS DAY'S.
ASSEMBLY TRIMMER SACRAMENTO
WINS APRIL TO EIGHTH TWO TWENTY
ONE IS IN THE AT SEVEN THE ON
DAVID CHIU WAS IN THE MEMBERS
OF JUST CHIEF LOOKS PARTNER
WITH PRINCIPLE CLERK WILL C. TO
READING THE FOLLOWING REPLACE
MY THE MORNING ROLL CALL
SEVENTY FIVE IS. MOVES MISSED
SECONDS. THE READING OF THE
DAY'S JOURNAL BECAUSE- WITH
PRESENT. HAVE BEEN. THERE ARE
AND REFERENCE BILLS BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ. AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED. MESSAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. WILLING TO MOTIONS
AND- ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
PER BUSINESS ASSEMBLY BIGELOW.
MAY RARE S. U. RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR FIRST MOTION. THANK YOU
SPEAKER EVERY YOU NOT CONSENT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE TO HAVE HER
DAUGHTER SEATED AT HER DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THE REQUEST
IS GRANTED. WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING. CORKERY
ASSEMBLY GIRL LIVING SEVENTY
ONE. ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
RIGHT. ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM THREE FOUR FIVE. PASS
AND WE. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER. SIX AB. NINE
SEVENTEEN BY MR BELOW THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AN ACT RELATING TO
VEHICLES MISTER BLOOM YOU MAY
OPEN GOOD MORNING THIS YOUR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB NINE
SEVENTEEN WILL ALLOW TRANSIT
AGENCIES TO CAPTURE IMAGES OF
VEHICLES VIOLATING TRANSIT ONLY
LANES AND BLOCKING BUS STOPS
DESPITE CLEAR MARKINGS AND
SIGNAGE TRANSIT ONLY LANES ARE
FREQUENTLY IGNORED. BUS ONLY
LANE VIOLATIONS AND PARKED
VEHICLES FORCE TRANSIT
OPERATORS TO MANEUVER AROUND
CONGESTED LANES AND MAKE DROP
OFFS FURTHER FROM THE CURVE AND
THEY POSE SAFETY HAZARDS TO
WRITERS AS WELL. EXISTING
CAMERON FORSMAN PROGRAMS IN SAN
FRANCISCO ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY HAVE SHOWN GREAT
SUCCESS IN REDUCING VIOLATIONS
AND INCREASING ON TIME TRANSIT
PERFORMANCE. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTEEN WILL PROVIDE RIDERS
WITH SAFE ACCESS. TO AND RAPID
BUS SERVICE AND ENSURE PUBLIC
TRANSIT REMAINS COMPETITIVE IN
ATTRACTING MORE RIDERS THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTESAND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BOOK. THANK YOU MISTER
BLOW SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CARCLUB RURAL MEMBERS
THAT. IS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
YOUR PARKWAY CLOSER ALL TIED UP
ICE FIFTY FOUR. NO. ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THE FACT.
PASTORATE. FILE ITEMS EIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEN ON ITEM
NUMBER NINE. WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A FOR ITEM THE TEN A FIFTY
FIFTY. BY MYSTERY OF US CLERK.
ASSEMBLY RULE FOR FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOOSE AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO HIGHER WE
RELATIONS. THIS THANK YOU
MISTER AND MEMBERS I RISE
PRESENT AB FOR FIFTY EIGHT
FIFTEEN FOR PER FACULTY RIGHTS
BY ALLOWING FACULTY WHO ARE
CURRENTLY IN A BARGAINING UNIT
TO REMAIN ELIGIBLE FOR UNION
REPRESENTATION EVEN IF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA MOVES
THOSE FACULTY POSITIONS IN THE
ACADEMIC SENATE THREE YEARS AGO
THE OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT
REQUESTED THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGENTS
MOVE SIX PART TIME FACULTY JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS FOR LECTURES.
ACTIVELY COVERED BY A
COLLECTIVE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT INTO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE RECENT
AMENDMENTS HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWED THE BILL TO
EXCLUSIVELY FOCUS ON ALLOWING
FACULTY TO RETAIN UNION
REPRESENTATION IF THEIR JOB
CLASSIFICATION IS MOVED TO THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS REAVIS SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON THE
BILL. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE MEMBERS. WE DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS ADEBAYO. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT
AS FORTY SIX MINUTES FOURTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING
TO PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
ELEVEN THROUGH EIGHTEEN. PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NINETEEN PASS RETAIN ON TWENTY
AND TWENTY ONE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWENTY TWO AB THREE THIRTY
NINE BY MISTER LEE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC MEETINGS MR LEE EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER%
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB
THREE THREE NINE A BILL TO
EXPAND TO PRESERVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE WITH THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH
INTERNET. OR CALL IN OPTIONS
FOR FAR TOO LONG MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HAVE BEEN PRECLUDED FROM
PARTICIPATING GOVERNMENT DUE TO
REQUIREMENTS TO ATTEND IN
PERSON THERE ARE MANY REASONS
WHY SOMEONE WOULD BE UNABLE TO
ATTEND A TUESDAY HEARING AT
SEVEN PM AND SIT THERE FOR
SEVERAL HOURS IN ORDER TO MAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT SO THEIR VOICE
IS HEARD. THIS BILL IS
ESPECIALLY TIMELY GIVEN LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE ALREADY HAD TO
IMPLEMENT WAYS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO ENGAGE REMOTELY
AND WE WANT TO SEIZE
OPPORTUNITIES CONTINUED AFTER
THE PANDEMIC IN ORDER FOR US TO
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO HEAR THE VOICES OF ALL OUR
CONSTITUENTS. THIS BILL HAS A
SUNSET ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONLY
APPLIES TO CITY COUNCIL AND
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
MEETINGS AND JURISDICTION THE
POPULATION TO UNDER FIFTY
THOUSAND. AB THREE THREE NINE
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR
ARGUMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER LEE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION- DEBATE ON
THIS SIDE. CLERK WILL I'M SORRY.
THIS GARCIA CHRISTINE GARCIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MEMBER SERVICES FOR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE 4% THIS
THE PANDEMIC HAS BEEN HARD FOR
A LOT OF BUT IT ALSO HAS UP
PRESS TO SEE TECHNOLOGY COME
INTO THE FOLD AND FIND ANOTHER
WAY TO BETTER ENGAGE OUR
CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE AND SO I
AM HAPPY TO SEE THIS MEASURE
BEFORE AS A THROUGH HOLE BASS.
AS THE YEARS MOVE ON FIND MORE
WAYS TO INCORPORATE THIS AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT. I THINK
WE HAVE A SPONSORED TO ENSURE
THAT I CAN. ARE EMPOWER. TO
PARTS IN THAT WE'RE MEETING
THEM WHERE THEY AT ON AND SO
THAT THERE'S LOTS VARIOUS THERE
TAKING- CAN OVERCOME SOME OF
THE VERY OR ARE WILLING THAT WE
GET EXHAUSTED WITH SOON- I
THINK ALL THOUGHT THEY WERE THE
POWER BE. TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE
SO I A PRE. THAT WE ARE THIS
THE FORWARD I THINK IT'S A GOOD
FIRST US WE MOVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
THANK YOU MISTER C. MISTER COLE.
YOUR RECOGNIZE. CALL ARE VERY
PLEASED RISE AND OF BILL. OF
THE ISSUE OF TECH AND SOME OF
OUR HAS A VERY STRONG INTRA OF
MINE. COURSE WERE IN THIS
PROCESS OF MOVING SHORT TO A
BUILDING WHICH HAVE UP TO TEXT.
EVENTUALLY COMING BACK INTO A
BUILDING THAT'LL HAVE. YET
AGAIN UPDATED TECHNOLOGY SURE
VERY MUCH IN A TIME WHERE
COVERT HIS FORCES TO TRY OUT
NEW IDEAS WE HAVE USED THEM TO
IN WITH VARYING DEGREES OF
SUCCESS BUT I THINK THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT TIME IN OUR
DEMOCRACY. TO BE TAKING STOCK
OF THE TOOLS WHICH EMPOWER
CONNECTION AND UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT IS BEING DELIBERATED UPON
THE FUTURE. OF A GIVEN YOUR
FIVE THIS IS A VERY BILL I
THINK SCALE THE TO REALLY HELP
START UNDER IT IN A REAL WORLD
GOV. CONTACT AND I'D THE
LEARNING THAT WILL- IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND REMARKABLY TIMELY.
BECAUSE OF THE- REENGINEER OF
ART. THE COLD IS ENGENDERED.
SERGEANT VOTE. THANK YOU COOLEY
SAYING NO. OTHER SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER LIAM I CLOSE
IF YOU WISH. THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I THINK THE MEMBERS OF
ARISING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IT IS A CLEAR-
ADAPTATION WE MUST MAKE SINCE
THE IS A CRYSTAL MINING THAT
THE FED THEM BECAUSE LED US. TO
ADAPT OUR DEMOCRACY TO CHANGING
TIMES AND WILLIAM BROUGH CITY
KNOWLEDGE YOU CAN HOPEFULLY
HEAR FROM MORE VOICES I DID
ALSO WANT TO CLARIFY SAID IN MY
TALKING POINTS THE SUNSET DATE
IS TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY ONE OF HAS
OBVIOUSLY THIS YEAR BUT THE
SUNSET IS DECEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. I WOULD
DESPERATELY ASK. THREE ITEMS.
WITH ACTOR CALL THEIR OWN. THE
DESIGN OF A ON MEMBERS I OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIGN OF A.
CLICK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I FORTY FOUR KNOWS EIGHT. THE
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM. TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR. CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
GROUNDWATER THIS YEAR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS LOOK AT THIS ONE SHORT
EASY THIS HELPED US OUT WITH
OUR GROUNDWATER PLANS I ASK YOU
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
RESIDENTS SEEING NO DISCUSSION.
ON THE ADAM. CABALLERO. DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
RESERVE A.
CALL. MISTER MATHIS
WAS A CALL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR AB THIRTEEN NINETY
EIGHT BLOOM KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOWBACK
RELATING TO HOUSING MISTER
BLOOM EMAIL BUT THANK YOU SIR
MEMBERS CURRENTLY IF A
JURISDICTION DOES NOT ADOPTED
HOUSING ELEMENT BY THE
STATUTORY DEADLINE IT MUST
ADOPT A REVISED HOUSING ELEMENT
EVERY FOUR YEARS RATHER THAN
EVERY EIGHT. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
PENALTY HAS PROVEN INEFFECTIVE
AND LEAD TO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SUCH AS CITIES
ADOPTING FAULTY HOUSING
ELEMENTS JUST TO MEET THE
DEADLINE AND AVOID THE PENALTY
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS THE
ADOPTED ELEMENT WAS NOT REVISED
TO CORRECT THE LEGAL
DEFICIENCIES FOR MORE THAN
TWELVE MONTHS AFTER THE
DEADLINE IN SOME CASES NOT FOR
YEARS. AB THIRTEEN NINETY EIGHT
WOULD ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS BY
ELIMINATING THE FOR YOUR
PENALTY AND REQUIRING CITIES TO
MISS THE DEADLINE. TO CONDUCT
RESOUNDS WITHIN ONE YEAR. AND
CLARIFY THAT AN ADOPTED HOUSING
ELEMENT MUST BE APPROVED BY A
CD BY THE DEADLINE TO AVOID THE
PENALTY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DERIVE A- THANK AS WELL SEEING
THEIR DISCUSSION. OUR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CLARK WELL OVER THE
ROLE. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. IS THAT A VOTE- ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIGN OF A.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
THAT ICE FORTY ONE NO SIXTEEN
THE MEASURE PASSES.
BEVERAGE
ONE WAY BACK IN THE FILE THE
NUMBER FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN. HELLO MISTER COOPER
TO TAKE UP ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN
FORTY EIGHT. CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. THIS
COULD BE A MALE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TEN FORTY
EIGHT IS A DISTRICT BILL
ORIGINALLY AUTHORED BY NOW
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA CURRENT
LAW PREVENTS SAN LEANDRO
HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES FROM JOINING
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT ASSOCIATION.
RETIREMENT PLAN THAT EVERY
OTHER ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEM
EMPLOYEE HAS ACCESS TO THIS
KIND OF COURAGE EMPLOYEES
WITHIN THE HEALTH SYSTEM TO SEE
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES AT SAN
LEANDRO HOSPITAL BECAUSE THEY
WOULD LOSE THEIR ONGOING
BENEFITS INCLUDED IN THE
RETIREMENT SYSTEM. THIS IS AN
EQUITY ISSUE THAT AB TEN FORTY
EIGHT WILL SOLVE BY ALLOWING
THESE PARTICULAR EMPLOYEES TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
ASSOCIATION THIS IS A THREE
FOUR BILL THE SUBJECT TO THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
AND DOES NOT FORCE. ANY PARTY
INVOLVED TO AGREE TO AN
ADDITIONAL BENEFITS WAGES OR
WORKING CONDITIONS OUR SPECS WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANKS
COOPER. SENIOR DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM CORPORAL. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. OUR MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I. TWO
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. WE
ARE GOING TO PASS TEN. ON FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE A. B. THE
FOURTEENTH. PASS EVER. ON I.
TWENTY WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN. AND. TWENTY NINE.
LET'S TAKE A FILE ITEM THIRTY.
AB TWO FIFTY TWO BY MYSTERY OF
US CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO LAND USE MYSTERY OF
US YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS LEGISLATION
SEEKS TO HELP MINIMIZE THE
IMPACTS OF SIGMA BY CREATING A
GRANT PROGRAM TO HELP FARMERS
REPURPOSE FORMALLY IRRIGATED
LAND THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION RESPECT LAST WHEN I
VOTE THANK U. S. B. THANK YOU
MYSTERY. SENIOR DISCUSSION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. THE SENATE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLE TYLER I SIX
SIXTY THREE. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES PAST RETAIN A
FILE AND THIRTY ONE. FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO. MISTER PATTERSON.
QUACKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO HUMAN TRAFFICKING
MR PATTERSON EMAIL BUT- THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT AB TWO SIX TO A
BILL THAT WILL. MAKE IT EASIER
FOR SURVIVORS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING- TRAFFICKING TO
CLEAR THEIR RECORDS VIA VACATE
YOUR RELIEF. CURRENT LAW
CREATES A CATCH TWENTY TWO THAT
MAKES IT ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR
SURVIVORS TO CLEAR THEIR
CRIMINAL RECORDS. SURVIVORS
OFTEN HAVE TO PAY ALL FINES
MEET ALL PROBATION REQUIREMENTS
BEFORE THEY CAN EVEN ASK A
COURT TO CLEAR THEIR CRIMINAL
RECORD OF NON VIOLENT OFFENSES.
WITHOUT A CLEAR RECORD
EMPLOYMENT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
WITHOUT EMPLOYMENT PAYING A FEE
TO THE COURT AS A BARRIER. THAT
PREVENTS MANY SURVIVORS FROM
EVEN TRYING TO CLEAR THEIR
RECORDS. THIS BILL WOULD
PREVENT A COURT FROM REFUSING
TO HEAR A HUMAN TRAFFICKING
SURVIVORS PETITION. FOR RAP
RECORD CLEARANCE DUE TO UNPAID
FINES OR FEES. IT ALSO WOULD
GIVE SURVIVORS THE ABILITY TO
PITCH IT TO PETITION
PROVOCATEUR RELIEF AT ANYTIME
AFTER THEY ARE REMOVED. FROM
TRAFFICKING. AT THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED AS ZERO NO VOTES IT
WILL MAKE A WORLD OF DIFFERENCE
TO SURVIVORS AND HUMAN.
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS. THAT WERE
TRYING. TO PIECE THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER THIS BILL HELPS
INTO. A DRAMATIC WEIGHT STARTS
THE THEM ON THE PATH WITH
CLEARING THEIR RECORDS. AND
GETTING ON WITH THEIR NEW LIFE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK MY ABOUT.
DAVID PATTERSON SEEING NO
DISCUSSION ON ITEM. CABALLERO.
IS THAT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A. CLARK WELL. CULTURAL
TIE THAT I SIXTEEN OH ZERO THAT
MEASURE THIS IS FILE I THIRTY
THREE AB THREE SO FOUR.
ACCORDING TO SOME PEOPLE FREE
SIXTY FOR BY SOME MEMBER ON
THREE AND I INTO FOR LABOR. MR
RODRIGUEZ HE MAILED. MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY ALL RIGHT TO
PRESENT A B. THREE FOUR. THIS
BILL ONE ALL OVER PER TWO
HUNDRED. TEMPORARY BE HOLDERS
TO COME TO A CAL RISK.
COMPREHENSIVE AT THE POINT
RECRUITMENT. PROTECTION FROM
WHAT DOCUMENT. OF THEIR PARTY
LINE RECRUITER FOR EXPORT
VULNERABLE WORK SEEKING TO
LAWFULLY IN THE UNITED STATES
AMONG ALL TYPES OF RESEARCH THE
H. TWO A. PRO. IF THE TEMPER BE
SAYS LINKED WITH LARGER NUMBER
A FEW TRAFFICKING CASE IN THE
STATES. OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
FEDERAL AND IN THE STATE DO NOT
ADEQUATELY PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
LAW ABIDING EMPLOYERS- PORTABLE
TEMPORARY MIGRANT WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE SERVICES
OF FOREIGN LABOR RECRUITERS ARE
STRICTLY HOUSE FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MR IVORY. SENIOR DISK.
ON THE ITEM. CABALLERO. IS THAT
A VOTE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE EYES FORTY THREE
KNOWS FIFTEEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
FOUR AB. THREE EIGHTY EIGHT.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AND OTHERS AND I
RELATING TO SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
MR MEDINA YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH IS A MEASURE
THAT WILL ENSURE NOT
ADMINISTRATIVE EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES. SERVING IN POSITIONS
REQUIRING CERTIFICATION WILL
BECOME PERMANENT EMPLOYEES
FOLLOWING A PROBATIONARY PERIOD.
TODAY EXPERIENCED EDUCATORS AND
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
BEING DISMISSED AND TERMINATED
FOR ARBITRARY REASONS WITHOUT
WARNING. UNDER CURRENT LAW ONLY
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES IN
TEACHING POSITIONS AT COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION WITH THE
AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE OF
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
PUPILS CAN ACHIEVE PERMANENT
STATUS AFTER PROBATIONARY
PERIOD. THIS MEANS THAT
CERTIFICATED CERTIFICATED
EMPLOYEES IN NON TEACHING
POSITIONS DO NOT HAVE A RIGHT
TO ATTAIN PERMANENT STATUS.
THIS POLICY AFFECTS GROUPS OF
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES SUCH AS
SCHOOL NURSES ENGLISH LANGUAGE
EDUCATOR FOSTER YOUTH
COUNSELORS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS WORKING WITH
SEVERELY DISABLED STUDENTS
AMONG OTHERS. IN THE CASE OF A
DISMISSAL A PERMANENT EMPLOYEE
STATUS WOULD ALLOW EMPLOYEES TO
REQUEST A HEARING BEFORE
COMMISSION ON PROFESSIONAL
COMPETENCE TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
THEIR DISMISSAL WAS APPROPRIATE.
FURTHER A PERMANENT EMPLOYEE
HAS A RIGHT TO REQUEST A
HEARING DURING A REDUCTION IN
FORCE. UNFORTUNATELY SEVERAL
CLASSES OF EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
INAPPROPRIATELY DENIED
PERMANENT STATUS BASED ON THE
NEEDS TO CREATE FISCAL SOLVENCY
OR INTENT ANTICIPATION THAT THE
NEEDS FOR SERVICES IN THE
FUTURE ARE IN SECURE. THE LACK
OF PERMANENT STATUS IS LEAD TO
DISCRIMINATION RETALIATION AND
FAVORITISM WITHIN OUR SMALLER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THIS BILL WILL
REMEDY THIS SITUATION TREATING
ALL CERTIFICATED EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES WITH DIGNITY RESPECT
AND THE PROFESSIONALISM THEY
DESERVE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
REGINA. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. TOOK OVER
THE ROLE. DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF. DESERVE A.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
MR
MEDINA MOVED TO CALL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE AB THREE
NINETY SEVEN MAYES OPERATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE NINETY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES
AND OTHER PERSONALITY TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. MR MAYS
EMAIL. I THINK THIS IS SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB THREE NINETY SEVEN. EVERY
MEMBER OF THIS BODY HAS BEEN
INUNDATED WITH EDT ISSUES THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN RESOLVED BY
THE AGENCY. UNDER CURRENT LAW
AN APPLICANT CAN HAVE THEIR
BENEFITS TERMINATED IF THEY
SUBMIT AN INACCURATE STATEMENT
HOWEVER MANY STATEMENTS EDIE
FLAGS ARE NOT INTENTIONALLY
INACCURATE BUT INSTEAD
MISSTATEMENTS DUE TO CONFUSING
FORMS THE OUTCOME FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS IS BEING LOCKED
OUT OF BENEFITS FOR FIVE AS
MUCH AS TWENTY THREE WEEKS.
THIS IS AN UNACCEPTABLE OUTCOME
AND SO MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
RELYING ON THIS IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC LIFELINE AB THREE
NINETY SEVEN REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTIN CLEAR NOTICE
THE CLAIMANTS IF EDIE HAS
IDENTIFIED THIS ISSUE WITH OUR
APPLICATION AND ALLOW OUR RIGHT
TO CURE. THIS LEGISLATION DOES
NOT CHANGE THE AGENCY'S ABILITY
TO INVESTIGATE AND PROSECUTE
FRAUD INSTEAD WE ARE FOCUSED ON
CLARIFYING AND SIMPLIFYING THE
MAZE OF FORMS INDIVIDUALS MUST
NAVIGATE TO KEEP BENEFITS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES MISSED
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
ISE IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
NINE SEVEN. I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL WHICH IS
EXTREMELY NECESSARY. AS WE ALL
KNOW EDT HAS BEEN AN ABSOLUTE
NIGHTMARE AND THE PROBLEM THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS IS A
LARGE REASON WHY. MY DISTRICT
OFFICE LIKE MANY OF YOURS HAVE
RECEIVED THOUSANDS OF
DISTRESSED BECAUSE CONSTITUENTS.
HAVE OF WHO'VE CONTACTED US.
WHO ARE JUST LOOKING FOR AN
ANSWER ON THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS IN MANY OF THESE CASES
THE EDIE DIDN'T EVEN GIVEN THE
COURTESY OF A STATUS UPDATE ON
THE BENEFITS AND THEY ARE LEFT
WONDERING WHAT TO DO MOVING
FORWARD HOW TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES DURING THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES. TOO OFTEN PEOPLE ARE
JUST TRYING TO NAVIGATE COMPLEX
STATE AGENCY JUST AS JUST SUCH
AS ADD. WILL BE CONFUSE IN THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AND MAKE
TECHNICAL ERRORS OR NOT SUBMIT
EVERY SINGLE PIECE OF
APPROPRIATE DOCUMENTATION. THE
EDG WITH THIS CALL THE
APPLICANT THE APPLICATION BUT
NEVER INFORMED OF A
DISQUALIFICATION OR GIVEN OR
GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO CORRECT
THE MISTAKE. THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTELY AND NECESSARY AND
UNACCEPTABLE AND I'M HAPPY TO
SEE THE CHANGES THIS BILL WOULD
MAKE TO THE PROCESS FOR
FAMILIES WHO NEED THIS THE
MOST. AND I ASK FOR YOUR SEATS
I SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISSED ONE SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAM MISMANAGEMENT
CLOTHES IF YOU WISH GREAT I WAS
VERY FAST AND I HOPE. CLICK
LIBERAL. IS THAT A VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ABOUT. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES IS FILE ITEM THIRTY AB
FOUR SIX. BY MISTER MAY
CORPORATE SOME BILL FOUR FOUR
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANAK
RELATING TO WILL. MISTER MAY HE
MAKE OPEN. I THANK YOU SPEAKER
MEMBERS- I APPRECIATE DEBRA PE
AB FOUR FOUR SIX. AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT ONLY SEVEN NEW
POLITICAL PARTIES OF QUALIFIED
TO PARTICIPATE IN CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS WITH SIX PARTIES
QUALIFYING THROUGH VOTER
REGISTRATION. AND ONLY ONE
QUALIFYING TO PETITION PROCESS
BUT THEY FAILED THE STATE
QUALIFIED FOR SUBSEQUENT
ELECTIONS WHEN THEY FAILED TO
REGISTER ENOUGH VOTERS THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
SIGNATURES NEEDED ON A PETITION
TO FORM A NEW POLITICAL PARTY.
FROM 10% 23% PUTTING
CALIFORNIAN LINE WITH THE VAST
MAJORITY OF OTHER STATES DURING
COMMITTEE RESEARCHING THIS
ISSUE FOUND THAT MOST STATES
ARE BETWEEN TWO AND FIVE
PERCENT. THIS BILL ALSO SEEKS
TO FREE UP NAMES OF PRIOR
UNSUCCESSFUL POLITICAL
MOVEMENTS BY ALLOWING A NEW
POLITICAL BODY TO REGISTER WITH
THE NAME THAT HAS BEEN
ABANDONED LASTLY THIS BILL
FORMALIZES THE SECRETARY OF
STATE APPEALS PROCESS. WHEN
APPLYING FOR A PARTY NAME I
THINK THE ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE FOR WORKING CLOSELY WITH
ME ON THIS BILL INCLUDING NEW
MINUTES TAKEN JUST LAST WEEK.
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS REYES MISTER.
YOU ARE. A QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION DO
YOU THINK THAT THIS BILLS GOAL
OF PROVIDING MORE OPTIONS TO
VOTERS- MIGHT BE BETTER SERVED
OR PAIRED WITH THE REPEAL OF
THE TOP TWO PRIMARY SYSTEM.
THIS MADE HIM ADDRESS AT AN
HOUR IN YOUR CLOTHES I'LL JUST
MY CLOTHES. I'M IN THIS KELLY
YEAH I SUPPORT BILL SUPPORT
IT'S A- OF A OF A LOT IF YOU.
TO YOU. BUT THAT DOES REALLY
MUCH IF THERE PARTIES ARE
AFFECTED BANNING FROM THE
BALLOT THROUGH WHICH THE OFFICE
HOLDER AS CHOSEN SO NEXT YEAR
IT'S GOING TO HAVE BEEN TEN
YEARS OF THIS EXPERIMENT WITH
THE TOP TWO PRIMARY. WHICH IS
PRODUCED SOME DECIDEDLY MIXED
RESULTS IN AN ON LEAST SOME
RATHER STRANGE FORCES- INTO OUR
ELECTION SYSTEM AND I BELIEVE
THAT WE SHOULD GIVE AYE ARE
VOTERS A CHANCE. TO WEIGH IN
AFTER A DECADE OF EXPERIENCE AS
TO WHETHER WE WANT. TO CONTINUE
WITH THE SYSTEM MOVING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS KELLY SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE BILL MR
MAYES YOU MAY CLOSE. I THANK
YOU SO MUCH JUST TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTION- FROM MY COLLEAGUE-
YOU KNOW IF IT WAS UP TO ME
THERE WOULDN'T BE POLITICAL
PARTIES- IN FACT IN FACT- IF I
HAD A MAGIC WAND I WOULD. DO
AWAY WITH THAT I DON'T HAVE A
MAGIC WAND I'M IN REGARDS TO
THE OPEN PRIMARY THAT IS THE
SYSTEM- THAT- CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. OUT WANTED- THAT IS THE
SYSTEM THAT WERE THE WITH THAT
WERE- THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE
THE BILL BEFORE YOU AT TODAY
MAKE SOME VERY MINOR AND
CLARIFYING- CHANGES TO THE
CODE. AND THAT I THINK WE CAN
ALL AGREE WITH- AND AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK THE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE AND ALSO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE WITH WORK
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS THIS
BILL- MISTER- MISTER. BY THE
MEMBERS AND I MISTER SPEAKER I.
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. AND I
THINK I MISSED MASON THAT CLERK
WILL THE ROLE. THE ABOUT ALL MY
VOTED OUT OF A- THE. USED TO
HAVE MY. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT
OF A CLERK WILL. BECAUSE ROLL
TIDE OF A ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASSWORD OF
OUR THIRTY. FILE I'M THIRTY
EIGHT IS AB FOR SEVENTY FOUR
CORE CORE. ASSEMBLY FOR SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY CHAO AN
ACCOLADE IN THE PUBLIC. MISTER
EMAIL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB FOUR SEVENTY
FOR READ ROUSE WE ALL FOR OF
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC ACT THERE'S
OPPOSITION I ASKED YOUR RIVAL.
HEY MICHELLE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ADAM CLERK WILL THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS TO VOTE. ALL VOTE IT IS
OUT OF A. CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE
TIED UP AS FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASS. WHERE THE
PAST HAVE ON FOR ITEM FOR NINE
PASS. AND RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS
FOR AND FORTY ONE. WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB FOR
EIGHTIES. I MISS GABER.
KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SO
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL IN
OTHERS ARE THAT RELATING TO
MEDIA. MR GAVE YOU MAIL THANK
YOU MISTER. THIS BILL TO DO
WITH THE S. OF HOW SOCIAL COM
Mà R. PA THIS. AND FOR MANY
PARTICULARLY FOLLOWING THE
ASSAULT ON OUR DEMOCRACY THE
CAPITAL EARLY THIS YEAR THESE
CONCERNS HAVE CENTERED AROUND
THE ROLE THAT SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS PLAY IN PROMOTING
HATE SPEECH DISINFORMATION
CONSPIRACY THEORIES VIOLENT
EXTREMISM AND SEVERE POLITICAL
POLARIZATION. THERE'S ALSO
CONCERNS ACROSS THE SPECTRUM
ABOUT WHICH VOICES ARE BEING
AMPLIFIED ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
WHICH OTHERS ARE BEING SILENCED
THIS BILL TAKES A VERY MODEST
APPROACH TO THAT ISSUE BY
REQUIRING TRANSPARENCY FROM
MAJOR SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
ABOUT WHAT THEIR CONTENT
MODERATION POLICIES ARE ASKING
THEM TO BE TRANSPARENT WITH
THEIR CONSUMERS AND WITH THE
PUBLIC ABOUT HOW THEY ARE
MODERATING OUR POLITICAL
DISCOURSE. THIS IS A NARROW
APPROACH THAT RESPECTS THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND FEDERAL
PREEMPTION AND PROVIDES
MEANINGFUL TRANSPARENCY AND
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY. WE ARE A
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION CONTINUE TO BE A
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM BUT
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
ON ADDRESSING THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. THAT IS
CENTRAL TO OUR DEMOCRACY AND
WITHOUT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
RISK A REAL MISTER CUNNINGHAM
YOUR- THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE AS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE. AND IF YOU'RE ON THE
FENCE ON THIS BILL I ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING.
INFORMATION WHEN YOU MAKE YOUR
DECISION. FIRST OF ALL A
HANDFUL OF COMPANIES THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO NAME THEM. EXERTS
AN INCREDIBLE UNDENIABLE
INFLENCE OVER OUR SOCIETY. ALL
ASPECTS OF SOCIETY OUR
ELECTIONS THE NEWS FEED PEOPLE
READ. GO ON DOWN THE LIST AND
THIS IS WELL DOCUMENTED AND
IT'S UNDENIABLE. AND THEY
EXERCISE IT'S NOT CENSORSHIP
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT THE
GOVERNMENT. BUT ITS CONTENTS
SUPPRESSION FOR LACK OF BETTER
TERM. IN A TOTAL BLACK BOX THEY
OPERATE WITH TOTAL IMPUNITY ON
WHAT THEY CHOOSE TO TAKE DOWN
OUT OF THE FEED WHAT THEY
CHOOSE TO ALLOW WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING WE DON'T
KNOW THE STANDARD THEY'RE
APPLYING WE DON'T KNOW WHETHER
THAT'S BEING FAIRLY APPLIED TO
ALL DIFFERENT TYPES OF YOU
POINTS. IT GETS APPEALED TO AN
INDEPENDENT BOARD IN A CERTAIN
WITH A CERTAIN PARTICULAR
COMPANY AGAIN I DON'T NEED TO
NAME THAT INDEPENDENT BOARD WE
DON'T KNOW WHO'S ON IT. WE KNOW
VIRTUALLY NOTHING ABOUT THIS
AND IT IMPACTS AGAIN EVERY
SINGLE FACET OF OUR SOCIETY IN
THE MODERN WORLD. WHERE ELSE
ARE WE ALLOWING THAT TO GO ON.
IF THE COMPANY'S POISONING
WATER. WE HOLD THEM TO ACCOUNT
WE MAKE THEM DISCLOSE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING TO KEEP THE WATER
PIER. OKAY SO ALL THIS BILL IS
ASKING YOU TO DO IS TO CONSIDER.
IMPLEMENTING A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IT DOESN'T TELL THE
COMPANIES WHAT TO DO OR NOT DO
IT DOESN'T RESTRICT THEIR
FREEDOM TO OPERATE. IT DOESN'T
CONTROL WHO THEY ALLOW ON THEIR
PLATFORM IT JUST SAYS HEY. ONCE
A QUARTER SO YOU GOTTA TELL US
WHAT CONTENT YOU'RE SUPPRESSING
WHAT STANDARD YOU'RE APPLYING
TO DO IT AND ARE YOU DOING IT
FAIRLY AND THEN WE CAN ALL
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO ABOUT
THAT. I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP. I DON'T THINK IT'LL
BE THE LAST STEP BUT I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP I
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR HE IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
INDUSTRY TO WORK OUT ISSUES.
AND I THINK WE WOULD BE DOING
OUR SOCIETY IN PARTICULAR ARE
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS ARE
KIDS WHOSE BRAINS ARE BEING
SHAPED BY THE INFLUENCE OF THE
CONTENT ON THESE PLATFORMS.
WITHOUT YOUR KNOWLEDGE. TRY TO
CONTROL YOUR TEENS ARE LOOKING
AT ON THEIR PHONES GOOD LUCK TO
YOU I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO IT
FOR FOUR YEARS FAILING
MISERABLY. WE NEED TO STEP IN
WE NEED TRANSPARENCY WE NEED A
LITTLE MORE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
WE NEED THIS BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL.
THANK CUNNINGHAM GALLAGHER
YOUR RECOMMENDS. THEY YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS- I TO
WRITE IN THE- OF AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN- AND AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN LUIS OBISPO SAID. I THINK
THIS IS A GOOD FIRST STEP WE
NEED TRANSPARENCY. WE NEED TO
BEGIN WITH SOME TRANSPARENCY ON
HOW THESE DECISIONS ARE GETTING
MADE. ABOUT WHAT CONTENT IS
BEING MODERATED WHAT WHAT-
VIEWS ARE BEING CENSORED. AND I
WILL BRING UP TO EXAMPLES THAT
I THINK. REALLY BRING HOME THE
POINT OF WHY THIS IS IMPORTANT.
WE FOUND OUT HERE RECENTLY.
WE'RE TOLD ALL THE TIME THIS IS
A PRIVATE COMPANY THEY CAN MAKE
THEIR OWN DECISIONS FIRST
AMENDMENT DOES NOT APPLY TO
PRIVATE COMPANIES BUT WE FOUND
OUT HERE RECENTLY THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WAS
CONTACTING TWITTER AND FACEBOOK
AND TELLING THEM HEY TAKE THESE
POSTS DOWN SO WE NOW HAVE A
STATE ACTOR. TELLING THESE
PRIVATE COMPANIES HEY WE THINK
THIS IS MISINFORMATION TAKE IT
OFF TAKE IT DOWN. AND WE STILL
HAVEN'T GOTTEN FULL
TRANSPARENCY ON WHAT THOSE
POSTS WERE. BUT WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE STATE
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER WERE
CENSORING SPEECH ON ON
FACEBOOK. SO THERE YOU GO ARE
WE GONNA GO DOWN THIS ROAD
WHERE STATE ACTORS ARE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO INFLUENCE AND
DETERMINE WHAT WHAT SHOWS UP.
ON THESE PLATFORMS. SECONDLY.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS A YEAR
AGO THERE WAS THERE WAS TALK
THAT. THE ORIGINS OF THIS VIRUS
THAT HAS PLAGUED OUR ENTIRE
PLANET. MAY HAVE COME FROM A
LEAK OUT OF A- LAB IN WUHAN
CHANT IN WUHAN CHINA. FACEBOOK
AND THE PEOPLE THE TRUTH
EXPERTS. AT FACEBOOKU NOBODY
REALLY KNOWS THERE IS NO REAL
TRANSPARENCY ABOUT WHO THESE
PEOPLE ARE THAT MAKE THESE
DECISIONS DECIDED NO THAT'S
FAKE NEWS THAT'S MISINFORMATION.
AND SUPPRESSED EVEN THE MENTION
OF SAYING THAT THAT COULD BE
THE CASE AS MISINFORMATION WELL
WE ALL KNOW. IN THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS THAT ACTUALLY THERE IS
THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE TO VERY
MUCH SOME STRONG EVIDENCE TO
SUPPORT THAT IN THEIR HOT THERE
IS INVESTIGATIONS INTO THAT
VERY ISSUE. WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN. TASKING. HIS SECURITY
FORCES TO LOOK INTO THIS ISSUE
AND TO PRESS THAT ISSUE WITH
COMMUNIST CHINA. BUT DON'T
WORRY BECAUSE FACEBOOK AND
TWITTER DECIDED LONG BEFORE
THERE WAS EVER ANY
INVESTIGATION BEFORE ANYBODY
COULD ACTUALLY GET TO WHAT THE
FACTS WERE THAT THIS WAS
MISINFORMATION. DO WE REALLY
WANT TO ALLOW THAT TO REMAIN
THE STATUS QUO. THIS SELECT
GROUP OF PEOPLE GET TO
DETERMINE WHAT'S TRUE AND
WHAT'S NOT WHAT'S
MISINFORMATION AND WHAT'S NOT.
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP AND I
WON'T. HAVE BEEN VERY.
OUTSPOKEN ABOUT WHERE I WANT TO
GO WITH THIS ULTIMATELY I THINK
THE FIRST AMENDMENT SHOULD
APPLY. TO THESE COMPANIES
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE NEW PUBLIC
FORM. AND HE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS THESE THE
STRONGEST SPEECH PROTECTIONS IN
ITS CONSTITUTION IN THE NATION.
IT SAYS YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
FREELY SPEAK PUBLISH. IN OUR
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION HAS
ALREADY BEEN INTERPRETED AS
BEING APPLYING TO PRIVATE
PROPERTY A SHOPPING MALL. IN
THE BRUGNON CASE AND THE REASON
BEHIND THAT WAS THAT SHOPPING
MALLS. YOUR THROUGH THE
EIGHTIES AND AS OF THE GROWTH
OF THESE SHOPPING MALLS HAVE
BECOME THE NEW PUBLIC SQUARE
THERE WAS NO LONGER THE TOWN
SQUARE THE TRADITIONAL TOWNS
WHERE WOULD PEOPLE WOULD COME
IN PRESENT THEIR IDEAS AND
DEBATE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED NOW BY THE SHOPPING
MALL WELL NOW THE SHOPPING MALL
WE KNOW. BY HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
CLOSED DOWN. THESE LAST DECADES
HAS BEEN DISPLACED BY THE
DIGITAL AGE AND SOCIAL MEDIA
AND WE ALL KNOW IT. THE NEW
PUBLIC SQUARE. IS FACEBOOK AND
TWITTER ANY SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS WHERE MUCH OF OUR
PUBLIC DISCOURSE OUR POLITICAL
DISCOURSE ARGUABLY ELECTIONS
HINGE ON THE INFORMATION. THAT
COMES THROUGH THESE IN THAT
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS CAN WE
TRULY SAY. WE CONTINUE WITH THE
STATUS QUO THAT KNOW THEIR
PRIVATE ACTORS THEY CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT. AND THEY
CAN DETERMINE WHAT SPEECH IS
TRUE AND WHAT IS FALSE THIRTY
SECONDS WITHOUT ANY
TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT ANY INPUT.
FROM DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES I DON'T THINK
THAT CAN ANY LONGER BE THE CASE
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP. TO
MAKING THAT CHANGE MEMBERS AND
ASK YOU TO JOIN US. THANK YOU
MISS GALLAGHER. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION. OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM MR GABRIEL
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ST LOUIS BASED
ON YOUR BY CITY FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTARY HERE WE
JUST OFFER IT'S CLEAR OBVIOUSLY
THAT THERE ARE FOLKS ON THE
POLITICAL RIGHT WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT CENSORSHIP ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THERE A LOT OF
FOLKS ON THE LEFT WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE APPLICATION
OF CERTAIN VOICES A BROAD
COALITION OF CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL. BECAUSE THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THE ROLE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES AND
POTENTIALLY AMPLIFYING HATE
SPEECH AND DISINFORMATION AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND THAT
THE PREDICTABLE RESULTS ABOUT
ARE THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
RECENTLY THAT HAVE SHOCKED MANY
OF US AND ABOUT THE SEVERE
POLITICAL POLARIZATION SO THERE
ARE BROAD CONCERNS ABOUT ALL
THIS AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID
THIS IS A FIRST STEP TO HAVE
SOME MODEST TRANSPARENCY SO
THAT WE AS THE PUBLIC CAN
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY HOW THESE
COMPANIES ARE MODERATING SPEECH
AS HAS BEEN DISCUSSED. THERE
ARE A HANDFUL OF CALL A SMALL
COMPANIES THAT HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATE POWER TO
FUNDAMENTALLY IMPACT OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE THIS BILL SEEKS IN A
LITTLE BIT A PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY AND WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THING IS GABRIEL AT THAT
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR ALL. WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE SERVER. CLARK WELL
CLOSER ALL TIED UP I FIFTY. NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS
IS FILE ITEM FORTY THREE B. SIX
HUNDRED SEPARATE SOME PEOPLE
SIX HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AN ACT RELATING TO
HATE CRIMES DR ARABIA THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB SIX HUNDRED
WHICH PROTECTS CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTIONAL CIVIL RIGHTS BY
REITERATING CALIFORNIA'S
POSITION TO PROHIBIT CRIMES
AGAINST A PERSON COMMITTED
AGAINST THEIR PERCEIVED OR
ACTUAL IMMIGRATION STATUS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DEKARANGER SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN. DESERVE IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE SAID ABOUT.
CLICK WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIED IC FIFTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES WHERE PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM FORTY
FOUR. PASS RETAIN OF FILE I'M
FORTY FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX EIGHTY SIX NINETY
FIVE MY DOCTORATE TO CORRECT
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
ACCORDING TO ELDER INDEPENDENT
ADULTS. THAT'S ARAMBULA YOU
MAKE IT OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB SIX NINETY
FIVE WHICH EXPANDS AND ENHANCES
THE ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
FOR OLDER INDEPENDENT ADULTS IN
CALIFORNIA. BY FIRST INCREASING
COUNTIES CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
CASE MANAGEMENT AND SERVICES
SECOND LOWERING THE AGE OF
ELIGIBILITY AND FINALLY BY
BUILDING UPON THE SUCCESSFUL
HOME SAFE PROGRAM TO ASSIST THE
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICE
CLIENTS WHO NEED HELP WITH
HOUSING ISSUES. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SEEING THEIR DISCUSS
DEBATE. CARCLUB RURAL. IT IS
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A. ALL MY RESEARCH. THE
SERVER. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THEM PASSES PASS IN RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY AND
FILE ITEM. FORTY EIGHT. PASS
AND RETAIN A FELON FORTY NINE.
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
FIFTY. ASCERTAIN ON FIFTY ONE
FIFTY TWO AND FIFTY THREE.
THERE IS WE'RE FIVE OUT OF
FIFTY FOUR EIGHTY NINE NINETY
THREE. BY MISTER PATTERSON
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON ACCORDING TO
THE PARENT AND CHILD
RELATIONSHIP. MR PATTERSON
EMAIL. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
AB NINE THREE IS OUR AND ADOPT
BILL SPONSORED BY THE ACADEMY
OF CALIFORNIA ADOPTION LAWYERS.
THIS YEAR'S BILL MAKES MULTIPLE
CHANGES TO ADOPTION AND FAMILY
LAW INCLUDING EXPANDING THE USE
OF POST ADOPTION CONTACT
AGREEMENTS AND EXPANDING VENUE
OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES TO
COMPLETE THEIR WE ADOPTIONS OF
CHILDREN ADOPTED. IN OTHER
COUNTRIES. THE GOAL OF THIS
BILL IS TO PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
CONSISTENCY AND CERTAINTY TO
FAMILY FORMATIONS AND
ULTIMATELY TO HELP THEM AVOID
UNNECESSARY FURTHER LITIGATION.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK RESTORATION SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLICK OVER THERE ALL. THE
IT IS OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CARDWELL CLOTHES ALL TYLER I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES PASSER RETAIN ON
FILE OUT OF FIFTY FIVE THIS IS
FILE ITEM. FIFTY SIX. AB TEN
SEVENTY ONE CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN
ACT RELATING TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND DECLARING THE
YEARS EITHER UPTICK FACT
MEDIALLY. MR RODRIGUEZ YOU MAY.
THANK YOU MAY SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARRIVED PRESENT A TENSE ONE.
BUT THE COVERT NOW PAN AND
STATE TO YOUR WHILE FARSI. WE
ARE READY FOR TO RISK TO ME
MULTIPLE MADE TASK SOME.
HOWEVER CAL MYSELF BE PREPARE
TO FACE OTHER NOT TO DOES SUCH
AS EARTH PLAY AND SOME. WE
CANNOT BECAUSE GUARD IF IN OF
THESE THREATS OCCUR THE SAME.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
TAKING THE NEXT STEPS TO MANY
AGAINST THESE KNOWN DISASTERS
THIS BILL REQUIRE POWELL YES TO
CONDUCT BI ANNUAL TABLETOP
EXERCISES OF CALIFORNIA
CATASTROPHIC DISASTER RESPONSE
PLANS AND INCLUDE RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS. DUE TO THE
ONGOING AND NATURAL DISASTER
THREATS A. B. TEN THIRTY. IS AN
URGENT URGENCY STATUTE THAT
WILL ENABLE US TO BETTER
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS
ARE FACTORY PRIVATE. THANK MR
IVORY. THE C. DISCUSSION OF A
ON THE. CLARK CALL THE ROLL. IT
IS TO VOTE ON MEMBER VOTERS TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THIRD DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ZERO
TIED TO IT I SICK TWO NO HERE
ON THE URGENCY I SEE TWO KNOWS
HERE ON THE- THAT BILL PASSED.
THIS IS FOR ITEM FIFTY SO AB
TEN NINETY FOUR CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY FOUR
BY SOME OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA AND OTHERS NOT REALLY
KNOW HOW THAT A- THAT ARAMBULA
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB TEN NINETY
FOUR WHICH WILL ESTABLISH A
PILOT PROGRAM IN SELECTED
GEOGRAPHICALLY AND
DEMOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES TO TRAIN
CORONERS AND MEDICAL EXAMINERS
ON THE COLLECTION AND REPORTING
OF SEXUAL IDENTITY AND EXCUSE
ME GENDER IDENTITY AND SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. WE HAVE NOTICED
THAT THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH IT
THE INFORMATION IN CASES OF
VIOLENT DEATHS SUCH AS SUICIDE
AND HOMICIDE. THIS DATA WILL
ALLOW OUR RESEARCHERS AND
POLICYMAKERS POLICYMAKERS TO
BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND HOW
ORIENTATIONS AND IDENTITIES ARE
UNIQUELY IMPACTED. IN THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS HOW TO
ALLOCATE RESOURCES THAT WILL
REDUCE. THE NUMBER OF
PREVENTABLE DEATHS WE MUST HAVE
BETTER DATA TO UNDERSTAND THE
SCOPE OF WHAT'S APPENING IN
THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY
AMONG YOUTH WHEN IT COMES TO
VIOLENT DEATHS INCLUDING
HOMICIDE AND SUICIDE. AB TEN
NINETY FOUR IS BOTH AN
IMPORTANT AND HUMANE STEP AND
ULTIMATELY PREVENTING THESE
DEATHS THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A- THANK YOU DE CURRICULA.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM- CABALLERO. DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS LETTERS OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED UP I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT
AB ELEVEN TEN. BY MISTER RIVAS.
SEPARATE SAMEGRELO BIAS MEMBER
REED AND SNACKS IN THE CLASS
CAL'S PROJECTS. TO CREATE A NEW
PROGRAM TO HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BRIDGES ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES MORE COST
EFFECTIVELY IT'S BILLS RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION RESPECT LAST NIGHT
ABOUT MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU.
THANKS RIVAS. C. NOTIFICATION
ABATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS. IT IS
OUT OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF THE.
IS THAT OF A. CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLLTIDE AYE AYES FIFTY SIX NOW
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. PASS
RETAIN A. FIVE FIFTY NINE. FILE
ITEM SIXTY. AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE CORKERY SOME AGO A LEVIN
THIRTY NINE BY LORENA GONZALEZ
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
ENERGY. MR THE YOU MAILED ME.
THANK YOU MISTER. I'LL BE
HONEST HI THIS IS PROBABLY THE
TOUGHEST BILL I'VE HAD TO
NAVIGATE AND IN THAT SAME
SOMETHING COMPARED TO SOME OF
THE BILLS THAT I'VE HAD TO
NAVIGATE BECAUSE THE LEVEL OF
MISINFORMATION THAT HAS BEEN
OUT THERE IS ASTONISHING. WHEN
I FIRST SAW ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
I SAID WHAT WHY WHY. AM I GONNA
GET IN THE MIDDLE OF SOMETHING.
THAT THE P. YOU SEE SHOULD BE
DOING. BUT I'D ALREADY KNOWN
FROM PREVIOUS BILLS THAT THE
CPUC DOESN'T ALWAYS DO WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE DOING. AS
QUICKLY AS THEY SHOULD BE DOING
THAT. AND IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THAT ONE OF THE FIRST BILLS I
EVER VOTED ON IN THIS ASSEMBLY
WAS TO TELL THE C. P. U. C. TO
STOP THE CAUTION. THAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. UNDER OUR
NET METERING. AND YET HERE WE
ARE EIGHT YEARS LATER ST WE
STILL NEED TO STOP THIS
COLLECTION. DESPITE WHAT SOME
FOLKS SAY THERE IS A COST SHIFT
EVERY SINGLE REPORT THAT HAS
BEEN MADE ABOUT HOW WE DO NET
ENERGY METERING. SAYS IT THE
CPUC SAYS THAT SMUD SAYS IT UC
BERKELEY SAYS IT THERE IS A
COST SHIFT OF THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND THAT MEANS THE
PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO HAVE ROOFTOP
SOLAR ARE BEING SUBSIDIZED BY
MY WORKING CLASS NEIGHBORS. WHO
WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO AFFORD.
SOLAR IN SAN DIEGO. THAT THAT
THAT IS TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DOLLARS A YEAR. THAT IS BEING
PAID BY FOLKS WHO SOME DON'T
WANT SOLAR SHARE SOME WHO ARE
RENTERS WHO HAVE NO CONTROL
OVER WHETHER THE HOPS UP SOLAR
SOME WHO HAVE BAD ROOFS AND
CAN'T GET SOLAR. IN SOME WHO
JUST MIGHT HAVE A HOUSE THAT
FACES WRONG WAY INSULAR
WOULDN'T WORK FOR THEM. IN A
COURSE THOSE WHO WILL NEVER BE
ABLE TO AFFORD IT. SO INSTEAD
WE SAY EVERY TIME SOMEBODY GOES
AND GET OLDER UNDER THEIR
HOUSE. IT PUTS ADDITIONAL COST
ON THOSE FOLKS WHO DON'T HAVE
SOLAR. THIS STARTED IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND IT WAS
WRONG AND SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
STAND UP AND SAY THE WAY WE
DECIDED TO FUND IN INCENTIVIZE
SOLAR WHEN WE DESPERATELY
NEEDED MORE WAS WRONG. AND SO
IT'S BEEN SO POPULAR AND SO
SUCCESSFUL THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP
REVISITING AND SAYING HEY C. P.
U. C. WE CAN'T CONTINUE TO DO
THIS. SHOULD WE- INCENTIVIZE
ROOFTOP SOLAR PROBABLY YES I
WOULD SAY YES AND WE SHOULD DO
IT. THROUGH THE STATE BUDGET IN
A FAIR WAY WE SHOULD NOT DO IT
ON THE BACKS OF RATE PAYERS. I
WOULD LOVE FOR THE P. YOU SEE
TO ACT OR TO FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
GOING TO ACT AS THEY KEEP
TELLING US THEY WILL. BUT WE
KEEP WAITING AND IF WE LOOK AT
PAST HISTORY OF THE C. P. U. C.
WE'LL SEE THEY TEND TO DO THIS.
IF ANYBODY REMEMBERS LIFELINE.
HOW MANY YEARS DID WE WAIT FOR
THE CPUC. ACT ON LIFELINE. AND
YET EVERY SINGLE DAY. MORE
PEOPLE GET SOLAR. IT'S
INCENTIVIZE RATE PAYERS. IT'S
SUBSIDIZED BY PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
HAVE SOLAR. AND THOSE ENERGY
RATES CONTINUE TO RISE. IT'S
NOT EASY TO TAKE ON MY FRIENDS
AND ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY WHO
SUGGESTS THAT SOMEHOW I WANT TO
KILL ROOFTOP SOLAR. SURE I'M A
ROOFTOP SOLAR ADVOCATE I HAVE
IT ON MY OWN HOUSE. BUT
SOMETIMES TO BE A LEADER IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TO BE
HONEST WITH TO BE HONEST WITH
OUR FRIENDS. AND WE HAVE TO BE
ON OUR WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS.
I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THOSE
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
TODAY AREN'T BEING. COMPLETELY
HONEST BUT MOST YOU HAD PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS WITH ME AND
UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS
NECESSARY. IT'S HARD TO LEAD ON
AN ISSUE LIKE THIS WHEN THERE'S
SO MUCH MISINFORMATION. BUT
REST ASSURED THAT
MISINFORMATION ISN'T JUST
HAPPENING BECAUSE PEOPLE IN THE
FIRE MENTAL COMMUNITY LIKE
SOLAR. IT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE
OUR BIG SOLAR CORPORATIONS ON
THE OTHER SIDE WHO ARE ACTUALLY
PROFITING OFF THE SUBSIDY
PROFITING OFF THE SUBSIDY THAT
MY NEIGHBORS WHO CAN'T AFFORD
IT OUR PAIN. AND SO THIS
OPPOSITION HAS BUT NOT ORGANIC
IT'S BEEN GENERATED AND MOST
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE ISSUE IS. WE'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE WHO HAVE
ALREADY INVESTED ROOFTOP SOLAR
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THE INVESTMENT ON IT AND PAY IT
OFF. I UNDERSTAND THERE'S APROBLEM WITH PEOPLE WHO LEASE
SOLAR. I HAVE COMMITTED TO NRDC
INTO TURN BOTH OF WHOM ARE
SUPPORT IF AMENDED TO FIX THAT
IN THE SENATE. IF YOU HAVE BEEN
UNFORTUNATELY DUPED INTO A
CONTRACT BY A SOLAR COMPANY AND
NOW WE'RE STUCK IN A CONTRACT
WITH IT IS NOT FAIR. TO FORCE
YOU TO PAY OFF THAT CONTRACT
WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO REAP THE
BENEFITS OF THE SUBSIDY THIRTY
SECONDS BUT FOR US IN THE
FUTURE TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON
RENEWABLE ENERGY WHICH WE'RE
STILL GOING TO GET TO ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT. I WILL REMIND
I WAS THE LEAD CO AUTHOR. R. B.
SB ONE HUNDRED TO GET TO A 100%
RENEWABLE. IT'S GOING TO BE
DONE IN A WAY IT HAS TO BE DONE
IN A WAY THAT'S FAIR TO ALL
CONSUMERS. AND IT CAN BE DONE
AND IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ARKANSAS TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHO CAN'T AFFORD INCREASING
ENERGY RATES TO DO IT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU CONSULT. MISTER
COOPER. FIRST MIKE UP. YOUR
RECOGNIZED. THANK MISTER
SPEAKER CALLING I RISE A PROUD
COAL OF AB LET THIRTY NINE JUST.
THE UC BURKE IN INSTITUTE AT
HAAS WROTE A BLOG THE NET
ENERGY METERING THEY'RE SAYING
CALIFORNIA'S DISTRIBUTED SOLAR
POLICY HURTS THE POOR IT REALLY
IS THAT SIMPLE THEY'RE NOT
WRONG FOR CENTRAL VALLEY IN
INLAND REGION RESIDENTS THE
PUSH TOWARDS RENEWABLE ENERGY
ADDING TO THEIR STRUGGLE THE
CURRENT STRUCTURE ALLOWS
CUSTOMERS TO AVOID PAYING FOR
FIXED COSTS IN THE MAINTAIN THE
GRID MY COLLEAGUES AT FROM LA
IN THE BAY AREA. YOU KNOW HOW
HOT AND COLD IS UP HERE IN THE
WINTER AND SUMMER SO OBVIOUSLY
IF IN CENTRAL VALLEY USUALLY
BILLS ARE A LOT HIGHER. FOR
EXAMPLE. THE EXTRA. MONEY THAT
RESIDENTS PAY TO SUBSIDIZE
SOLAR POWER AMOUNTS TO
REGRESSIVE TAX MAINLY PAID BY
WORKING FAMILIES. WHO CAN
AFFORD TO HAVE SOLAR
THEMSELVES. THE ORIGINAL GOAL
OF THE NAME PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED TEN THOUSAND SOLAR
SYSTEMS. THERE ARE NOW OVER ONE
MILLION HOMES WITH SOLAR.
MISTER BUSH BE MORE EQUITABLE
PROTOCOLS FOR CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. IN AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE THE MOTION
IS STEP THAT. WHY SHOULD A
SINGLE MOTHER. OR WORKING
FAMILIES FOR SO AWESOME ELSE'S
HOUSE. THAT'S A QUESTION THEY
CAN AFFORD IT. THINK ABOUT THE
NO HE EXAMPLE. FOR THE ARM EV'S
THE REBATE PROJECT TEN YEARS OF
DATA. FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES. WE
KNOW THAT PERSON ABOUT THE
VEHICLES THE DEMOGRAPHICS ARE
MALES THAT MAKE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. IN HALF OF
THOSE MAILS MAKE OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO WHY
SOMEONE BARELY STRUGGLING TO
GET BY HELPING SUBSIDIZE THINGS
LIKE THIS. THIS IS REASONS
BILLS IMPORTANT. I WANNA THANK
MY CLIMB FROM SAN DIEGO
FROTHING THIS BILL. AND HAVE
THE COURAGE IT'S IMPORTANT TO
JUST BUILD THE RIGHT BILL THAT
YOUR AYE VOTE. FAMOUS
GOVERNMENTS CALDERON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE WHILE OUR PUSH TOWARDS
100% RENEWABLE ENERGY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE IS IMPORTANT WE
SHOULD NOT BE ASKING. ARE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES TO DO
THE HEAVY LIFTING. THE COST
SHIFTING DUE TO NET ENERGY
METERING IS BACKWARDS. MIDDLE
AND LOW INCOME FAMILIES ARE
SUBSIDIZING THOSE ABLE TO
INVEST IN AFFORD ROOFTOP SOLAR.
INITIALLY SUBSIDIES FOR SOLAR
PROVIDED IN THE NINETIES TO
HELP JUMPSTART THE INDUSTRY.
SOLAR IS NO LONGER IN ITS
INFANCY HOWEVER AND IT'S
CONTINUED GROW SINCE THE LAST
NAME AUGMENTATION OCCURRED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. I'M ALSO
PLEASED THAT THIS BILL MAKES A
NEW SOLAR PROJECTS SUBJECT TO
PREVAILING WAGES. THIS IS THE
NECESSARY BILL TO PROVIDE
EQUITY FOR THE MAJORITY OF
ENERGY CUSTOMERS I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND THE AUTHORED FOR
ADDRESSING THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISS CALDERON MR
HOLDEN. YOUR ADDRESS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
OUT THERE ON THIS BILL VERY
LITTLE OF WHICH IS ACCURATE LET
ME HIGHLIGHT. FIRST THIS BILL
IS ABOUT RATES THIS BILL DOES
NOT PREVENT ANY CUSTOMER FROM
CHOOSING TO PUT SOLAR ON THEIR
ROOFTOPS. SECOND THIS BILL IS
ABOUT FAIR RATES FOR ALL
REPAIRS REPAIRS ARE CURRENTLY
PAYING TWO TO THREE TIMES MORE
FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR THAT IS VALUE
TO THE GRID OR TO THE
RATEPAYERS. AND THE QUESTION IS
WHY IS THAT. BECAUSE CURRENT
LAW MANDATES THE CPUC TO ENSURE.
THAT THE SOLAR INDUSTRY SO GROW
SUSTAINABLY. THIS IS A THE
HISTORIC MISSION OF THE CPUC.
ITS MISSION IS TO ENSURE THAT
THE COSTS RATEPAYERS PAY ARE
JUST. AND REASONABLE NOT THAT
PRIVATE CORPORATIONS MAKE MONEY.
THIS BILL REMOVES THAT MANDATE
FROM CURRENT LAW. SECOND THIS
BILL ADDRESSES A GROWING
PROBLEM OF COST SHIFTING. WE'RE
GOING GREEN IN THE STATE THAT
IS MANDATED BY LAW AND
INDISPUTABLE THE QUESTION IS
SHOULD WE PAY TWO TO THREE
TIMES MORE TO GET THERE. AND I
DON'T THINK SO AND I ASK FOR
YOUR EYE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL THANK. THANKS HOLDEN MR
MURATSUCHI YARD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I'D LIKE TO START OFF BY
FIRST ACKNOWLEDGING. THE AUTHOR
OFFER NOT ONLY CHAMPIONING. V.
THE ECONOMIC INTERESTS
ESPECIALLY OF OUR LOW INCOME
AND WORKING CLASS COMMUNITIES I
ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AUTHOR. FOR HER CHAMPIONING
MANY ENVIRONMENTAL CAUSES OVER
THE YEARS AND THAT. I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY QUESTION AS
TO THE AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO
FIGHTING AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE
AND FIGHTING FOR CLEAN ENERGY.
BUT I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE AND
THE REASON WHY I'M OPPOSING
THIS BILL. IS BECAUSE AT THIS
TIME WE'RE NOT SCIENTISTS ARE
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE- HOW
PERHAPS ALREADY PAST THE
TIPPING POINT IN TERMS OF OUR
FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT WE SHOULD BE INCENTIVIZING
CLEAN ENERGY NOT ELIMINATING
WHAT IS PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS TO
INCENTIVIZE ROOFTOP SOLAR TO
INCENTIVIZE CLEAN ENERGY. FOR
MANY HOUSE WERE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOUSEHOLDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE AUTHOR
RIGHTFULLY FOCUSES ON THE COST
SHIFT ISSUE AND AS A MEMBER OF
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE. WE HAD A ROBUST
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE COST
SHIFT ISSUE AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THE COST SHIFT ISSUE
IS A REAL ISSUE. AND THAT.
WE'RE GETTING RUNNING OUT OF
PATIENCE MANY OF US HAVE RUN
OUT OF PATIENCE WITH. THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
FIX THIS PROBLEM OF THE
CONCEPT. BUT LET'S REMEMBER.
THAT THE CONCEPT. ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THE COST COMING FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE IN TERMS. OF THE
WILDFIRE MITIGATION EFFORTS ALL
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE SPENDING ON WATER
MITIGATION. ON IMPROVING ON
HARDENING THE GRID THOSE COSTS
FAR OUTWEIGH ANY ROOFTOP SOLAR
CREDITS THAT THE THAT FAMILIES
ARE RECEIVING. UNDER THE NET
ENERGY METERING PROGRAM. THIS
IS A PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
FIXED BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THROUGH A THOUGHTFUL.
STAKEHOLDER STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN
PROCESS FOR ALL STAKEHOLDERS
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE. THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
WE NEED TO FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE
WE SHOULD NOT BE ELIMINATING
ONE OF THE MOSTSUCCESSFUL
INCENTIVES TO TOWARD CLEAN
ENERGY AT THIS CRITICAL TIME.
THANK YOU MYSTERIES HE DR QUIRK
IN THE REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BICKERING MEMBERS. THIS PROGRAM
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE I'M A CO
AUTHOR. I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANYBODY IN HERE WHO KNOWS THESE
PROGRAMS BETTER THAN I DO.
RIGHT NOW THE ROOFTOP SOLAR
PROGRAM IS HURTING US IN
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
THE REASON IT'S HURTING US IS
THE COST OF ELECTRICITY IS
BEING DRIVEN UP THIS IN FACT IS
SEVERAL TIMES HIGHER THAN THE
PROGRAMS THAT WE JUST
MENTIONED. BY THE MEMBER FROM
TORRANCE IT IS HIGHER BY
SEVERAL TIMES. THE ACTUAL OF
FORTY COST WHICH IS WHAT IS IN
THE BILL NOW WILL BE ALLOWED TO
THESE PEOPLE THAT INCLUDES THE
SOCIAL COSTS. OF REDUCING
POLLUTION ETCETERA BUT IF THESE
PRICES CONTINUE TO GO UP AND
LET ME TELL YOU HOW EXTREME
THIS YEAR'S THE CUSTOMERS IN
SAN DIEGO THE PEOPLE WITHTHE
LOWEST INCOMES PAY A HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR MORE FOR THEIR
ELECTRICITY BECAUSE OF THIS
PROGRAM IT IS MUCH BIGGER THAN
ANY OTHER PROGRAM WE HAVE IT IS
TIME FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR TO
COMPETE. ON ITS OWN. IF IT'S A
GOOD TECHNOLOGY IF IT GETS THE
THINGS DONE IF WE GIVE IT THE
CREDIT IT SHOULD GAP. FINE I
ALSO AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR WHEN
SHE SHOWS WE CAN'T TRUST THE P.
YOU SEE THE ACT BECAUSE FRANKLY
THEY WORRY MORE ABOUT THE
POLITICS THEN WE DO. THEY ARE
NOT RELIABLE NOW SHE IS GIVING
THEM I THINK IT'S NEXT SUMMER.
TO GET IT DONE SUMMER OF NEXT
YEAR. OF AND IF THEY GET IT
DONE AND THEY DO A GOOD JOB
THAT'S ALL WELL AND GOOD. BUT
RIGHT NOW THIS IS HURTING US IT
IS HURTING OUR CLIMATE GOALS IF
WE DON'T REDUCE THE COST OF
ELECTRICITY THEN PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE GETTING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
BE GETTING ELECTRIC HEATING FOR
THEIR HOMES. THEY WILL BALK AT
THIS BECAUSE OF THE PRICES WE
HAVE TO THINK IN EFFECT FOR THE
CHAIR OF UTILITIES. THE MEMBER
FROM PASADENA. THERE IS A
WHOLE. FRAME THIS YEAR ON WE
ARE NOT GOING TO INCREASE THE
PRICE OF ELECTRICITY AGAIN. IT
IS ALREADY TWO TO THREE TIMES
MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE. AND
WE HAVE TO MAKE SOME CHANGES
THIS IS THE MOST IMPORTANT WHAT
I CAN THINK OF BECAUSE IT IS
THE LARGEST IMBALANCE. PLEASE
VOTE YES ON. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR. MR
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ME
DESK. THANK YOU THE SPEAKER.
MEMBERS THE IN. CAL HAS MADE
AND ROOFTOPS HAS BEEN OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT CLIMATE
BENEFITS. OF MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE DONE AND THAT
INVESTMENT THE INCENTIVES PUT
IN PLACE TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO. PUT ROOFTOP SOLAR ON THEIR
HOMES HAS SIGNIFICANTLY DRIVEN
DOWN THE COST OF THE
INSTALLATION THE COST OF THE
SOLAR PANELS. THAT PEACE HAS
REALLY WORK. WHAT WE NEED TO DO
NOW IS TAKE APPROPRIATE STEPS
INTO THE NEXT STEPS IN THE
SOLAR ROOF BY ATTACHING STORAGE
TO IT. BY ENSURING THAT WE CAN
DEVELOP MICRO GRIDS BY REALLY
ENFORCING THIS DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION MODEL THAT WE NEED
TO DO. SO ROOFTOP SOLAR IS THAT
IMPORTANT TO CALIFORNIA AND TO
KEEP THOSE INVESTMENTS GOING.
BUT THE NET ENERGY METERING
THAT WAS PUT IN PLACE WAS
REALLY KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD AND WE ARE NOW PAYING FOR
THAT CAN. AND IT DID SO BECAUSE
IT WAS AN UNWILLINGNESS TO
INVEST IN- GRAMS IN THE WAY WE
NORMALLY WOULD AND PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR
MAYBE ADD AN EQUITABLE. PIECE
OF OUR ELECTRICITY BILL TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE
INCENTIVES TO KEEP A ROOF TOP
pTO DO WAS JUST BUILD IT INTO
THE RATES AND STERN THAT GREAT
THAT INCENTIVE TO MOVE IT
FORWARD. THAT INCENTIVE NOW
WORKS AGAINST ALL OF THE OTHER
CLIMATE GOALS THAT WE HAVE THAT
INCENTIVE NOW BECAUSE OF THE
SUCCESS OF ROOFTOP SOLAR HAS
ENDED UP WITH A THREE BILLION
DOLLAR COST SHIFT. SO IT HAS TO
BE ADDRESSED AND IT HAS TO BE
ADDRESSED. NOW ENDED THE DRILL
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE POLICY IS
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY IS AS
APPROPRIATE LOOKING AT WHAT WE
SHOULD BE DOING TO PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT. VERMEILLE
JUSTICE POLICY ALSO ASKED THE
QUESTION WHO'S PAYING. AND
WHO'S BEING LEFT BEHIND. AND
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THIS COST
SHIFT WE ARE LEAVING.
COMMUNITIES BEHIND AND PUTTING
ADDITIONAL COSTS ON COMMUNITIES
WHO WERE NOT SET UP TO BEAR
THIS CAR. SO IN THIS BILL
COUPLE OF THIGS THAT THAT ARE
NOT ADDRESS IS HOW WE DEVELOP
THAT NEXT INCENTIVE PROGRAM. IT
WAS ACTUALLY IN THE BILL TO
BEGIN WITH. AND IT WAS TAKEN
OUT. AND UNFORTUNATELY
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE PUT INTO
THE BILL ALONG THE WAY WERE
VERY REFLECTED WHAT THE
INDUSTRY WAS ASKING FOR BECAUSE
WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO WAS PAY
FOR SOLAR ROOFTOP GENERATED
INDUSTRY. L. GENERATION AT THE
LOWEST POSSIBLE RATE WELL
THAT'S NOT FAIR. THEY ALSO
WANTED TO ATTACH AN ARBITRARY
FEE FOR THE PLEASURE OF
CONNECTING TO THE SYSTEM. WELL
THAT'S NOT FAIR EITHER THOSE
PIECES HAVE BEEN TAKEN OUT
FORTUNATELY. SO FOR ME MOVING
AHEAD WITH BREAKING DOWN THE
INEQUITIES IN THE NET ENERGY
METERING RATE STRUCTURE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND WE
NEED TO SEND A SIGNAL WHICH
THIS BILL DOES TO THE PC TO GET
IT DONE TO GET IT DONE NOW BUT
NOT EXCEED TO WHAT THE INDUSTRY
WANTS TO DO WHICH IS THE REAL
THREAT TO ROOFTOP SOLAR. IS
CHARGED ALL THESE ADDITIONAL
FEES AND SUCH THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS CANNOT AND DO NOT
PAY OFF OVER TIME SO NOT ONLY
DOES THIS BILL PROTECT LEGACY
INSTALLED SYSTEM. BUT IF THE
RATE STRUCTURE IS CORRECT THEN
IT WILL STILL ALLOW FOR.
SOMEONE WHO PUTS ROOFTOP SOLAR
ON TO RECOUP THAT INVESTMENT IN
THE APPROPRIATE WAY BUT WE HAVE
TO DO MORE. WE NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE STORAGE AS A PART
OF ROOFTOP SOLAR. AND WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE THAT
WE ARE WE ARE. PUTTING TOGETHER
THAT THOSE INCENTIVES. TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
DISTRIBUTED GENERATION AND THE
ABILITY TO DEVELOP MICRO GRIDS
AND BREAK OUR DEPENDENCE ON
THESE LONG TRANSMISSION LINES
THAT OR REALLY HOW THESE THESE.
COMPANIES MAKE MOST OF THEIR
MONEY OVER TIME AND PUT A CAP
ON. THE JUST ASTRONOMICAL
SPIRALING GROWTH OF ELECTRICITY
RATES. IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
THAT UNDERMINES OUR ABILITY TO
MOVE TO ELECTRIC HOMES IT
UNDERMINES OUR ABILITY TO PUSH
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE PROGRAM TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO DO ALL OF OUR CLIMATE GOALS
FOR ONE OF OUR CLIMATE GOALS IS
REALLY WHAT THE QUESTION IS WE
NEED TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON AB.
ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER STONE MISS CARILLO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I ACTUALLY
SIT ON UTILITIES AND ENERGY
WITH OUR CHAIR FROM MY- MY
NEIGHBOR IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PASADENA AND THEN SOMETIME
AROUND TWENTY NINETEEN WE HAD A
HEARING RELATED TO THE NET
ENERGY METERING AND WE ASK THE
SAME QUESTION WHEN IS THE P.
YOU SEE GOING TO ACT AND THE
RESPONSE WAS FUMBLED IN THAT
THEY HADN'T GOTTEN AROUND TO
IT- IT HADN'T BEEN A PRIORITY
THERE WAS CHANGES IN
LEADERSHIP. A NEW PRESIDENT
COMING ON BOARD LOTS OF EXCUSES
AS TO WHY THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION HOW NOT
NOT ACTED UP PERMISSION TO READ
A LETTER THAT I WROTE TO THE P.
YOU SEE ON JULY TWENTY TWENTY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THANK YOU
AND I'LL JUST- A SHORT A BIT.
IN MY LETTER ON JULY OF LAST
YEAR I WROTE NOW MORE THAN EVER
POLICY MAKERS AND REGULATORS
ALIKE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE PURSUING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION GOALS
AND TRANSITIONING 21100% CLEAN
ENERGY IN A MANNER THAT
ACHIEVES THE MAXIMUM BENEFIT AT
THE LEAST POSSIBLE COSTS FOR
CONSUMERS THE CURRENT STRUCTURE
OF NAM FAILED TO ACHIEVE THAT
OBJECTIVE BECAUSE IT MANDATES
THAT UTILITIES PURCHASE EXCESS
POWER GENERATED. FROM ROOFTOP
SYSTEMS AT A RATE ROUGHLY TEN
FIVE TIMES HIGHER THAN A
CONVERGENCE FROM OTHER SOURCES
IN ADDITION IT HAS CREATED A
SIGNIFICANT COST SHIFT RAPIDLY
APPROACHING TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THIS MEANS THAT
CUSTOMERS WHO FOR WHATEVER
REASON DO NOT HAVE THE CHOICE
OR DESIRE TO INSTALL SOLAR
PANELS ARE COLLECTIVELY PAIN
TWO BILLION MORE IN THEIR
ELECTRIC BILLS TO SUBSIDIZE
THOSE WHO HAVE HOME BASED SOLAR
SYSTEMS. I'D LIKE TO READ THE
RESPONSE FROM THE P. YOU SEE
THAT OBJECTION THIS IS FROM
COMMISSIONER MARK DOUGLASS MON
A- JULY THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LETTER I SHARE YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE NEED TO MODERNIZE.
THE NEED FOR MODERNIZATION
EXCUSE ME OF THE NON PROGRAM
AND APPRECIATE YOUR LEGISLATIVE
EFFORTS TO ENACT THESE REFORMS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW THE COMMISSION
IS PREPARING TO INITIATE RULE
MAKING THAT WILL CONTEMPLATE
THAT VERY SAME ISSUE YOU'RE
RAISING YOUR LETTER. WE EXPECT
TO ISSUE AN ORDER INSTITUTING
RULE MAKING TO BEGIN THE
PROCEEDINGS IN LATE SUMMER
TWENTY TWENTY I ASSURE YOU THAT
THE PRINCIPLES YOU LAID OUT
ENSURING EQUITY. AVOIDING
REGRESSION AND EXCESSIVE
STRUCTURE THAN THEM AND
BALANCING CONSIDERATIONS OF
CUSTOMERS WHO LACK CHOICE WILL
FULLY BE CONSIDERED WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF NEW PROCEEDINGS. MY
FELLOW COMMISSIONERS AND I
SHARE YOUR GOAL OF ENSURING THE
EQUITABLE EQUITABLE
MODERNIZATION OF THE ELECTRIC
GRID WILL MEETING OUR CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS. WE HAVE OFTEN
TALKED IN THIS BODY HOW BECAUSE
OF THE SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME THE
PREVIOUS LEGISLATORS WERE HERE
AT A SIX YEAR MAXIMUM.
OVERSIGHT OF DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN LACKING WELL
WE ARE HERE LONGER. AND WE ARE
TELLING THESE AGENCIES IN THESE
DEPARTMENTS THAT THEY NEED TO
ACT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HAS HAD. YEARS TO
FIGURE OUT NUMBER FORM AND THEY
HAVE FAILED TO DO SO AT THE
COST. OF WORKING FAMILIES
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND TO THAT THAT IS
NOT FAIR. IT IS NOT JUST AND
THEY ARE SIMPLY NOT DOING THEIR
JOB. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE WOULD
NOT EVEN BE NECESSARY. IF THE
P. YOU SEE ACTED. AND DID THEIR
JOB WHICH THEY HAVE NOT DONE
SO. SO PUTTING PRESSURE AND
ENSURING THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD IS THE APPROPRIATE
RESPONSE AND I AM SO GRATEFUL
TO ALL THE AUTHORS THAT ARE.
SPEAKING ALL THE MEMBERS THAT
ARE SPEAKING TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. THIS
BILL DOES NOT KILL SOLAR. IT
DOES NOT. IMPACT OUR GOALS OF
1100% RENEWABLE ENERGY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. IT'S SIMPLY
ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT EQUITY
AND ENERGY WHICH IS A
CONVERSATION THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE. ADDITIONALLY I COME
REFUTE. THAT YOU CAN ONLY BE AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST OR CAN ONLY BE
IN SUPPORT OF LABOR THOSE TWO
ARE NOT MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE. IF
YOU TRULY BELIEVE IN THE GREEN
NEW DEAL THE PILLARS OF THE
GREEN NEW DEAL INCLUDE. PEOPLE
FIRST WHICH MEANS PREVAILING
WAGE JOBS UNION JOBS. DIGNITY
AND THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND
ENSURING THAT A JUST TRANSITION
IF WE ARE TO MOVE FORWARD AND
AWAY FROM OUR RELIANCE ON
FOSSIL FUELS THAT YOU TAKE THAT
JOB. WITH THE UNION WITH A
PENSION WITH BENEFITS STARTING
OUT AT APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IN
TRANSITION. TO CLEAN ENERGY AT
THE SAME BENEFITS AN EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR A YEAR JOB DOES
NOT EQUATE. TO A MINIMUM WAGE
TWELVE DOLLAR FIFTEEN DOLLAR AN
HOUR JOB THOSE ARE NOT THE SAME
THING THAT IS NOT A JUST
TRANSITION THIRTY SECONDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
NINE. AND AGAIN I WILL SAY TO
YOU ALL THIS BILL WILL NOT EVEN
BE NEEDED HAD THE P. YOU SEE
DONE ITS JOB AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS CARRILLO. MISTER BRYANT
FROM A DESK YOUR RECOGNIZE.
WELL THIS IS THE BILL WE'VE ALL
BEEN WAITING FOR RIGHT. IS THE
ONE I'VE BEEN GETTING THE MOST
CHATTER ABOUT THE DAY I WAS
SWORN IN LAST FRIDAY. I GOT A
LETTER FROM A CONSTITUENT.
BECAUSE THIS CONVERSATION IS
PITTED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
AGAINST ECONOMIC GROWTH WORKING
FAMILIES VERSUS SAVING OUR
PLANET THIS IDEA THAT ONLY THE
WEALTHY CAN AFFORD SOLAR PANELS.
AND IS BEING SUBSIDIZED BY
WORKING FAMILIES AND UTILITY
COSTS. THE SOME TRUTH TO THAT.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO FOLKS WHO TOOK
FROM THEIR RETIREMENT. TO PAY
FOR THE SOLAR PANELS UNDER THE
PROMISE THAT IT WOULD PAY FOR
ITSELF IN EIGHT YEARS. THAT'S
ALSO TRUE. IT WAS A MISTAKE
I'VE STRUGGLED ALL MORNING WITH
OUR VOTING YES OR STAYING OFF
OF THIS. I'M VOTING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. AND I'M VOTING IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE WE CAN'T
SUBSIDIZE OUR GREEN FUTURE-
PUBLIC UTILITY COSTS ON WORKING
FAMILIES. AND WE HAVE TO
INCENTIVIZE SOLAR INVESTMENTS
AND GREEN INVESTMENTS IN A
SERIOUS WAY WE MAY PROMISES TO
FOLKS WITH NET METERING AND WE
CAN MAKE THAT RIGHT WITH THE
BUDGET WE CAN MAKE THAT RIGHT
WITH OTHER LEGISLATION I JUST
GOT HERE LAST WEEK BUT I'M
WILLING TO WORK WITH ANYBODY TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN. BUT THIS IDEA
THAT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND
ECONOMIC JUSTICE HAVE TO COME
HEAD TO HEAD MEANS THAT WE'VE
ALREADY FAILED. AND WE CAN DO
BETTER. THIS BILL TAKES US BACK
TO THE DRAWING BOARD. THIS BILL
START BY LIFTING UP THOSE AT
THE BOTTOM I'M GOING TO BE
VOTING YES. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO BROUGHT THIS TO
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU MISTER
PRIME MINISTER GALLAGHER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS. MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT IT THIS BILL. IS
BY THE UTILITIES AND FOR THE
UTILITIES AND THAT'S ABOUT IT.
LET ME START BY JUST JUST ASK
YOURSELF. IF THIS BILL PASSES
DO YOU THINK THAT THE UTILITIES
ARE GONNA LOWER YOUR RATES.
I'VE NEVER SEEN IT. ALL I'VE
SEEN AS RATES CONTINUE TO GO UP
IN THE STATE. IT HAS BEEN SAID
WE PAY 80% MORE AS A
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMER IN
CALIFORNIA THAN PEOPLE ANYWHERE
ELSE. IN THE UNITED STATES. ONE
OF THESE UTILITIES IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR BURNING DOWN AN
ENTIRE TOWN. IN MY DISTRICT.
THE VERY NEXT YEAR THEY RAISED
OUR RATES. LET'S TALK ABOUT
RATES AND WHY THEY'RE SO HIGH
IT'S LAUGHABLE. TO HEAR PEOPLE
SAY THAT IS THE NAME PROGRAM
THAT IS CAUSING OUR RATES TO
BE SO HIGH THAT SHOWS THE
COMPLETE IGNORANCE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH RATES AND WHY
THEY'RE SO HIGH LET'S START
WITH R. P. S. YEAH WE ALL LIKE
IT BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
RENEWABLE INVESTMENTS. BUT GO
BACK IN HISTORY. TO GET ALL
THIS STARTED. MULTI MILLION
DOLLAR COMPANIES BUILT UTILITY
SCALE SOLAR. THAT WE ENTERED
INTO CONTRACTS WITH LONG TERM
CONTRACTS WITH THAT VERY HIGH
PRICES WE'RE STILL PAYING ON
THOSE CONTRACTS NOT AT MARKET
RATES TODAY. LOW SOLAR BUT AT
THOSE RATES THOSE RATES IN
THOSE CONTRACT RATES MULTI
MILLION DOLLAR COMPANIES. THAT
ARE MAKING MONEY RIGHT NOW
TODAY AND THAT IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST REASONS WHY YOUR RATES
ARE SO HIGH. BUT IT DID HAVE A
POSITIVE EFFECT IN SOME PEOPLE
OF ALLUDED TO IT BY MAKING
THOSE INVESTMENTS. AND BY THE
MILLION SOLAR ROOFTOP
INITIATIVE IT BROUGHT THE COST
OF SOLAR DOWN SO THAT MIDDLE
CLASS AND LOW INCOME PEOPLE
COULD FINALLY AFFORD IT.
BECAUSE BACK THEN THEY COULDN'T
THE RATE THAT THE COST WAS SO
HIGH. THOSE INVESTMENTS MADE IT
SO THAT THEY COULD FINALLY
AFFORD IT. AND NOW MANY OF DONE
SO. YOU KNOW LIKE THE AUTHOR
I'M I'M- I'M A FAMILY WHOSE
ADOPTED SOLAR MAYBE I WAS A
LITTLE LATE AND COME INTO THE
GAME. BUT A COUPLE YEARS AGO I
DECIDED TO DO IT. LET ME TELL
YOU WHAT THE ANNUAL TRUE UP
COSTS. FROM THE UTILITIES IN
THE FINANCING COSTS BECAUSE I
LIKE MANY CALIFORNIANS CANNOT
JUST AFFORD TO DROP. CASH ON
THE SOLAR SYSTEM I HAD TO
FINANCE IT AND I'M STILL PAYING
THAT FINANCING STORE A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE GOING TO BE AFFECTED BY
THIS VERY BILL BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT ONLY AFFECTS PPA
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMERS IT
DOESN'T AFFECT THE BIG GUYS. IT
AFFECTS THE LOW INCOME PPA
CONSUMERS PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD TO. DROP MONEY ON THE
SOLAR THEY'RE DOING IT BY
FINANCING OR THEY'RE DOING IT
BY LEASING. THAT'S TO THIS
AFTER THE AMENDMENTS THAT TO
THIS BILL AFFECTS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT BREAKING THE
CONTRACT WITH THE BIG GUYS. WHO
ARE PAID WHO YOU'RE PAYING ON A
CURRENT LONG TERM CONTRACT. WAY
HIGHER THAN MARKET RATES FOR
SOLAR RIGHT NOW ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT BREAKING THEIR CONTRACTS
AND CHANGING THE RULES OF THEIR
GAME. NO. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
TAKING IT OUT ON THE
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMER. TAKE IT
OUT ON THEIR BACKS AND THEY'RE
GONNA END UP PAYING MORE
THEY'RE NOT GONNA GET THE
CREDITS THAT THEY WERE PROMISED
WHEN THEY DID IT. IS A PART OF
THE REASON THEY DECIDED TO MAKE
THAT DECISION. AS A GENTLEMAN
FROM SANTA CRUZ POINTED OUT.
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT WE
SUBSIDIZE MANY THINGS WITH OUR
RATES MANY THINGS. AND IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THAT SHOULD BE SOMETHING
COMING OUT OF RATES OR SHOULD
BE COMING OUT OF OUR GENERAL
FUND. THAT'S A GOOD DISCUSSION
TO HAVE. IF YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT VOLUMETRIC RATES ARE
FIXED RATES AND- WHAT'S A
BETTER WAY TO DO THAT MORE
EQUAL WAY TO DO THAT LET'S HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION. BUT DON'T
PICK ON ONE PROGRAM. THE BY THE
WAY HAS BEEN THE MOS
RESPONSIBLE FOR GETTING ACCESS.
TO LOW INCOME TO MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES. GETTING SOLAR IN THE
STATE. IT'S NOT HELPING THE
RICH AND NOW BY VIRTUE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL IS REALLY
FOCUSED. ON THE LEAST OF THESE
THAT CAN AFFORD. THEY GOT IN
UNDER THAT PROGRAM THIRTY
SECONDS. LAST YEAR THE UTILITY
PLAYER CHARGED PLED TO
MANSLAUGHTER. EIGHTY FOUR
COUNTS PEOPLE WHO DIED IN MY
DISTRICT. THEY PLAYED THE
EIGHTY FOUR COUNTS OF
MANSLAUGHTER IF THIS BILL
PASSES TWO THOUSAND KANNST
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMERS AND BUTTE
COUNTY ARE GOING TO SEE THEIR
RATES GO UP. ARE GOING TO SEE
THEIR CREDIT TAKEN AWAY.
MEANWHILE THEY STILL GOT TO PAY
THE ILL THEY STILL GOT TO PAY
THE FINANCING AND THEY STILL
GOT TO PAY THE UTILITY THAT
RAISE THE RATES AGAIN. THIS
BILL IS FOR THE UTILITIES BY
THE UTILITIES. MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT. YEAH I MEAN I
GALLAGHER MEMBERS. DON'T GO
DOWN THIS ROAD LET'S HAVE A
LET'S HAVE A TRUE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE WHOLE PICTURE ABOUT
ALL THE THINGS WE SUBSIDIZE.
AND WHAT WE TO DO ABOUT RATES
BECAUSE YOU'RE I AGREE WITH YOU
THEY ARE WAY TOO HIGH. BUT
LET'S DO SO THE REAL LET'S DO
SOME REAL REFORMS NOT PICK ON
ONE PROGRAM. AND HURT LOW
INCOME AND MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES THAT HAVE ADOPTED
SOLAR IN THE STATE I URGE A NO
VOTE. THANK RICH GALLAGHER.
MISTER RAYOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANT
TO BEGIN BY SAYING THAT THE
TRAGEDY IN PARADISE IS ONE THAT
WE WILL REMEMBER FOREVER IT WAS
A TRAGEDY AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE MUST LOOK TO REMEDY IN
SOME WAY BUT I WANT TO GET BACK
TO THIS BILL. THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE IS A
BILL THAT I SUPPORT. AND I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CHAMPIONING THIS IMPORTANT
EQUITY ISSUE IN FOR WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. TO HELP MEET
THEIR CONCERNS. INCLUDING
GRANDFATHERING THOSE WHO GOT
SOLAR BEFORE THE IMPLEMENTATION
WILL EXTEND TWENTY YEARS FOR
THOSE. WHO HAD ALREADY
INSTALLED THEIR SOLAR. ROOFTOP
SOLAR IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLY SUCCESSFUL DUE IN
PART TO THE MANY EARLY ADOPTERS
WHO COMMITTED TO CLEAN AND
RENEWABLE ENERGY. HOWEVER AS
HAS BEEN STATED BY SO MANY.
THEIR SERIOUS INEQUITY THERE IS
THERE IS A SERIOUS INEQUITY
WHEN IT COMES TO NOW TO ENERGY
METERING AND THE STRUCTURE AND
THAT MUST BE RESOLVED. THE COST
BURDEN CANNOT CONTINUE TO FALL
AND LOW INCOME AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. OF
THE STATE CONTINUES TO MOVE
TOWARD CLEAN RENEWABLE ENERGY.
IT MUST DO SO IN AN EQUITABLE
MANNER. AB ELEVEN THIRTY NINE
WILL STRIKE A BALANCE OF
REFORMING THE NOT TO ENERGY
METERING STRUCTURE. IF THE P.
YOU SEE FAILS TO ACT AND UP TO
NOW THEY HAVE FAILED TO ACT BUT
IT STILL ALLOWS THAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE CPUC CARE
ACT. WELL WILL STILL REASSURE.
EARLY SOLAR ADOPTERS THAT THEIR
COMMITMENT TO INSTALLING SOLAR
WAS NOT IN VAIN. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THE FUTURE
PROJECTS CONNECTED TO THEM. PAY
THEIR WORKERS A PREVAILING WAGE
IT IS FOR ALL THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS REYES.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU I JUST WANNA- BE CLEAR
ABOUT A COUPLE THINGS THAT WERE.
MISGUIDED I WOULD SUGGEST- AND
UNDERSTANDABLY SO I THINK IF
YOU ARE. IT LIVED IN AN AREA
WITH A FIRE AND DO BLAME THE
UTILITIES AND I CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT I IT- NUMBER ONE HAVE
NEVER EVEN TALKED TO THE
UTILITIES ABOUT THIS BILL. AT
THE SUGGESTION THAT I. CARRY
THE WATER OF A CORPORATION FOR
ANYONE WHO KNOWS ME IT'S ALMOST
LAUGHABLE. I DID TALK TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE ABOUT THIS BILL. AND
LEARNED A LOT ABOUT MY OWN
PERSONAL DECISION TO GET
ROOFTOP SOLAR IN WHO THAT COSTS.
AND I'M EMBARRASSED QUITE
FRANKLY I'M EMBARRASSED THAT I
CONTINUE. TO BURDEN MY
NEIGHBORS. BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS
THOSE LARGE SCALE SOLAR. PLANTS
FARMS THEY ACTUALLY PRODUCE A
LOT CHEAPER THAN MY ROOF CAN
PRODUCE AT. IT BRINGS DOWN THE
COST OF RENEWABLE ENERGY. BUT
EVERYTHING IS IMPORTANT WE NEED
ALL OF THESE TO MEET OUR GOALS
AND WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING IN ANY
WAY THAT ROOFTOP SOLAR ISN'T
PART OF THAT. FOR THOSE FOLKS
WHO SIGN A PPA. YOUR RATES ARE
LOCKED IN YOU DON'T GET THE
NAME CREDIT YOU'RE GIVING THEM
CREDIT TO A LARGE CORPORATION.
RUN BY THE RICHEST MAN IN THE
WORLD. THAT'S WHO MY NEIGHBORS
ARE SUBSIDIZING. AND I KNOW IT
MIGHT BE EASIER FOR ME TO TAKE
THIS ON BECAUSE THE REALITY IS
LESS THAN 1% OF MY CONSTITUENTS
CAN AFFORD ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
HAVE IT LESS THAN ONE PERCENT.
I KNOW THAT'S NOT THE CASE FOR
EVERYBODY ON THE FLOOR SOME OF
YOU HAVE 15% BUT THE PEOPLE IN
MY COMMUNITY SHOULDN'T BE
PAYING FOR THAT. THIS IS THE
BIGGEST COST THOSE WILDFIRE
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALSO PUT ON
REPAIRS. NOT SOLAR USERS. EVERY
TIME WE ADD COST IT'S SHIFTING
THE BURDEN. I AM COMPLETELY
COMMITTED TO OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS BUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO HAVE THESE HARD
CONVERSATIONS WE CANNOT BE
TALKING ABOUT SWITCHING TO A
100% ELECTRIC VEHICLES. WHEN
ELECTRICITY RATES CONTINUE TO
BE SHIFTED ON TO THE POOREST
FOLKS WHO NUMBER ONE CAN'T
AFFORD TO LET TRICITY NUMBER
TWO. CAN'T ELECTRIC VEHICLE
NUMBER THREE DON'T HAVE A
CHARGING STATION I'LL NEVER
HAVE SOLAR ON THE ROOFTOPS.
WHAT ARE WE DOING. WHEN ARE WE
GOING TO ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT
HOW WE REACH THOSE GOALS IN A
REALISTIC WAY THAT DOESN'T PUT
ALL OF THE BIRD IN A WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES. THOSE ARE MY
CONSTITUENTS AND I WOULD GUESS
EVEN FOR THOSE OF YOU IN
WEALTHIER COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU'RE STILL. JUST BECAUSE THEY
THEY DIDN'T GET A LETTER FROM A
SOLAR COMPANY TELLING THEM TO
CONTACT YOU. KNOW WHAT NOBODY
IS ORGANIZING THEM THAT'S OUR
JOB. TO PROTECT THEM. PEOPLE
WHO BOUGHT PURCHASED SOLAR
UNDER A PROMISE ARE STILL GOING
TO BE ABLE TO RECOUP ALL OF
THEIR COSTS PLUS. AND QUITE
FRANKLY THIS BILL GOES AWAY IF
THE P. YOU SEE JUST DOES THEIR
JOB. OR WE CAN WAIT. LIKE WE
DID FOR. THE SMART PHONES IN
THE DEAF AND DISABLED TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROGRAM TO
TRIPS NINE YEARS NINE YEARS.
THAT'S THAT'S THE KIND OF
RESPONSE WE GET FROM THE PUCT
I'M SORRY WE HAVE TO PUSH THEM
ALONG I'M SORRY IT'S A HEARD
BILL I'M SORRY WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT REAL EQUITY CONCERNS IN
ABOUT THE REAL WORKING POOR
CARE CUSTOMERS. ANOTHER THING
WE SUBSIDIZE THEIR RATES IN ONE
OF THE REASONS ARE RATES ARE
HIGH BUT CARE CUSTOMERS ARE
THEN TURNING AROUND AND SPENT
IN HAVING TO PAY FOR SOLAR BUT
DOES THIS DOES OF THIS MAKE
SENSE ARE WE SPIRALING DOWN. IN
OUR EFFORTSTO FEEL GOOD ABOUT
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES INTO
AN UNSUSTAINABLE PERMANENT
UNDER CLASS. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
LOOKING OUT FOR EVERYBODY. I
SPENT MANY YEARS AT ORGANIZED
LABOR TELLING OUR OWN FOLKS YES
WE CAN HAVE IT ALL WE CAN HAVE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS AND
GOOD JOBS. TOOK A LOT OF CRAP
FOR THAT. BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO DON'T BELIEVE THAT I
STILL DO ON THIS FLOOR WHEN I
VOTE FOR MANY OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL THINGS THAT COME
UP. I'M ASKING YOU AS
ENVIRONMENTALISTS ON THIS
FLOOR. TO STAND UP AS WELL IT
TELL THE TRUTH YES WE CAN HAVE
BOTH BUT IT'S NOT HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. UNDER OUR NAME
RIGHTS AND WE NEED TO REFORM IT.
THIRTY SECONDS THIS BILL DID
GET BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
COMMITTEE. THE FARM BUREAU IS
NOW NEUTRAL WE'RE WORKING WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO COME
OUT WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE
SOLUTION I ASK THAT YOU REACH
INSIDE AND STAND UP. FOR
WORKING CLASS ENERGY USERS WHO
CANNOT CONTINUE TO AFFORD THIS
RATE. EFFORT YOU VOTE YES ON A.
B. ELEVEN THIRTY NINE. THANK
YOU RESIDENTS ALSO FOR POPULAR
ALL. NUMBER VOTE. THE DESERT OF.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OF A.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
MEMBERS ROADSIDE OF A.
MS
GONZALEZ YOUR PLEASURE. THIS IS
ALSO THE CALL. MEMBERS I'D
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL.
MISTER MEDINA'S ITEMS THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY FOUR EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT. THE CLERK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
WHICH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
WOULD WISH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
WOULD WISH TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY SEVEN NO SIXTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. BACK IN FILE
ORDER. THIS IS FILE ITEM. SIXTY
ONE. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY
MISERABLES CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AND
ACCORDING TO DESERT
CONSERVATION MYSTERON US HE MAY
OPEN THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
THREE A BILL THAT WOULD CREATE
A PROGRAM WITHIN THE ALREADY
ESTABLISHED WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN FORTY
SEVEN. THIS WILL PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
PROTECT ENHANCE OR RESTORE
DESERT HABITAT AND SACRED
ANCESTRAL LANDS OF THE LOCAL
NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE. IT ALSO
PROVIDES PUBLIC ACCESS FOR
RECREATIONAL AMENDMENT
AMENITIES OR REDUCE THE THREATS
OF WILDFIRE DROUGHT FLOOD AND
OTHER CATASTROPHE EVENTS THAT
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS PROGRAM WOULD
BENEFIT THE MANY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE DESERT
REGION THESE ARE COMMUNITIES
WHO HAVE SUFFERED
DISPROPORTIONATELY FROM ONGOING
ENVIRONMENTAL CRISIS AND
ONGOING CLOVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. THE CALIFORNIA
DESERT'S MERIT INCREASE PUBLIC
ATTENTION AND INVESTMENT THE
DESERT REGION IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST STILL INTACT ECO SYSTEM
IN THE LOWER FORTY EIGHT STATES
THESE LANDS PERFORM CRITICAL
ENVIRONMENTAL ROLES INCLUDING
CAPTURING AND STORING CARBON TO
HELP US FIGHT THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISIS THAT WE SEE TODAY.
THE DESERT REGION IS ALSO THE
HOMELAND OF NUMEROUS TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES SINCE TIME
IMMEMORIAL WHO CAN BENEFIT FROM
THE DESERT CONSERVATION
PROGRAM. WELL I WAS COUNTY
SUPERVISOR FOR SEMINOLE COUNTY
WE WORKED TO PRESERVE AN AREA
KNOWN AS PRIORITY HOLE THAT HAD
THOUSANDS OF PETROGLYPHS OF
INDIAN ART DRAWINGS ON THESE
ROCKS THAT WERE BEING- DESSA.
BY THE VISITORS THAT WERE THERE
THAT TYPE OF PROTECTION IS WHAT
WE NEED IN THE DESERT
COMMUNITIES. UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA FUNDING INITIATIVES
INCLUDING PASSED BONDS HAVE
INVESTED FAR LESS CONSERVATION
FUNDING INTO THE DESERT THAN
OTHER AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY THOSE REGIONS IN
EXISTING STATE. STATE AREAS AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY THREE PROVIDES A
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM BY
CREATING A PROGRAM WITH THE WCB
FOCUSED ON FUNDING IMPORTANT
PROJECTS WITHIN THIS REGION.
ALSO NGOS TRIBES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND
OTHERS WOULD NOW HAVE A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM FOR THE MANY
IMPORTANT CONSERVATION
RECREATION PUBLIC EDUCATION AND
RESTORATION PROJECTS WITHIN THE
DESERT. WE CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MYSTERONS SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLICK OVER THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WITH THAT VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS. DESIRABLE. WELL
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
THIRTY ONE THOSE NINE THAT
PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
THROUGH SIXTY SEVEN PASS AND
RETAIN. IN FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM. SIXTY EIGHT. AB
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT BY MR TANG.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. SIXTY EIGHT
AB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT OF
MISTER CHANG IS READY TO TAKE
IT UP. CLERK WILL READ. SOME OF
BILL TWELVE THIRTY BY SOMEONE
TEAM OTHERS IN ACTIVATING
PROTEST. MISTER CHANG WITH YOU
LIKE PASS TEMPORARILY MR TANG.
WE'RE GONNA PASS TEMPORARILY.
WE'RE GONNA PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE I'M SIXTY EIGHT. GOING TO
PASS AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM
SIXTY NINE THROUGH SEVENTY ONE
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS A RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
SEVENTY THREE. WE WILL GO BACK
AND TAKE AYE MR TANG'S IS LET'S
SEE THIS IS FILE I'M SIXTY
EIGHT AB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT.
CLERK WILL GENERATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEEING AND
OTHERS AMERICA TO THE DE MISTER
K. MAY OPEN THANK SPEAKER A
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT MAKES OUR
VEHICLE FRIENDLIER THIBODEAU.
CURRENTLY PER. WHO FOR WATER
THE STREET IN THE MIDDLE THE
ROAD. COULD FACE FIVE UP TWO
HUNDRED DOLLAR. BUT EVEN IF
THEY ARE CARS ARE. THE FIVE ARE
ON FOR JUST. LET IN COMMUTER
COLOR WE FOUND. IN THE CENTER A
LONG BEACH WHAT AMERICANS WERE
TO FOUR TIMES MORE LIKELY. TO
GET WALKING TICKETS THAN
ANYBODY ELSE WELL WITH THE B.
TWELVE TH TO PROHIBITS FIVE FOR
CROSSING THE STREETS WERE NO
CARS PRESENT. ALLOWS
PEDESTRIANS TO USE ACROSS ON A
YELLOW LIGHT IN REPEAT EXIST
LAWS WHAT'S OF THE STREET
PEDESTRIAN. MUST WALK. THE BILL
ENJOY BY PARTY SUPPORT IN FOR
AS WELL THE PROBES RESPECT FOR
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
LACKING HERE RECOGNIZE. WHILE
MEMBERS. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
SAYNG THIS IS SO FOR FORCE TO
TAKE A AT UNDER. WHEN YOU LOSE
TRACK WITH YOUR THIS IS THE
KIND OF MEASURE THAT GETS
BROUGHT FOR. BECAUSE WHAT IS
FELT HERE IS THERE'S BEEN IN.
AND FOR. OF PEDESTRIAN LOS.
BECAUSE I'M TANYA IF YOU REALLY
UNDERSTOOD THE DANGERS
ASSOCIATED WITH PEDESTRIANS AND
VEHICLES YOU WOULD NOT CONSIDER
THIS AS A VIABLE OPTION. SOME
OF THE MOST TRAGIC AND
HORRENDOUS INCIDENTS THROUGHOUT
MY CAREER HAD TO DO WITH
WORKING. ADESTRA VERSUS VEHICLE
INCIDENTS AND I'M TELLING YOU
YOU MAY NOT THINK THIS IS LIKE
SAYING LET'S PASS A LAW THE
SAYS IT'S OKAY RUN A RED LIGHT
IF YOU DON'T SEE. THIS IS BAD
POLICY. I UNDERSTAND THAT I
UNDERSTAND WHERE IT'S COMING
FROM ESPECIALLY THOSE OF YOU
WHO LIVE IN THE THEIR- WHERE
TRAFFIC IS SLOW AND THERE'S-
CIRCUMSTANCES TO WHERE YOU
THINK YOU COULD JUST ACROSS
THERE WITHOUT ANY PROBLEM. WELL
I'M TELLING YOU YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE CHAOS. IS WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE YOU HAVE BACKED
UP TRAFFIC YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
PEOPLE PEDESTRIANS. FREE
ROAMING THE ROADWAYS AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE BEEN PASSED
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE. REALLY
UNMANAGEABLE CIRCUMSTANCES SO I
UNDERSTAND. THE THOUGHT BEHIND
US AND IT'S- IT'S MISTRUST AND
I HOPE LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL.
PAY ATTENTION I KNOW THAT THE-
BE FAIR AND FORCING. LOST THANK
YOU. DAVIS LACKING SAY NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM MR TANG YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MUCH I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LANCASTER
PALMDALE THINK THEY'RE VERY
WHERE. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE ALL PROBABLY DONE IN OUR
LIVES BUT I WOULD PROBABLY LOOK
AROUND THIS BODY IN WONDER IF
ANYBODY IN THIS BODIES EVER
BEEN CITED. I KNOW REGARDING
THE VEHICULAR QUOTE IT'S A VERY
DIFFEREN SITUATION WHERE.
PEOPLE DRIVE AT A CERTAIN SPEED
LIMIT AND WE PROBABLY ALL BEEN
CITED FOR SO THAT SEEMS TO BE
pMECHANISM THIS ONE HOWEVER
SEEMS TO BE VERY INDISCRIMINATE
SEEMS TO UNFORTUNATELY BE
DISPROPORTIONATELY HOPPING IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES SO
CERTAINLY STARTS BEING ENFORCED
OF THE POOR OTHER COMMUTERS
NOT. I THINK WHAT WE DO HAT
WE'RE DOING IS TRYING TO
SIMPLIFY THIS MAKE IT SO THAT
IT IS SIMPLER TO IMPLEMENT THAN
TO BE ENFORCED ACROSS THE BOARD
MORE EQUALLY IN MORE EVENLY.
WITHIN FOR COMMONSENSE MEASURE
AND LIKE WE MENTIONED IN
PARTICULAR THE STATE FIGHTS THE
CITATIONS THAT I CITED WERE
REALLY AROUND WITH ANGELES IN
LONG BEACH IN PARTICULAR
BECAUSE WE DID HAVE STUDIES AND
DID HAVE DATA SO AGAIN WE THINK
THIS IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH
IT DOESN'T TAKE THE ABILITY OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO. NOT ENFORCE.
ADESTRA IN IRVINE. OR A VEHICLE
VIOLATIONS I THINK WHAT IT DOES
IS IT SAYS. THAT PEDESTRIANS
HAVE THE ABILITY TO CROSS THE
STREET WITHOUT FEAR OF GETTING
CITED. I TOTALLY AGREE WE DO
NEED TO DO MORE AROUND THE
VEHICLE ENFORCEMENT IN VEHICLE
SPEED ARE COMPLETE SUPPORT THAT
WE HAVE. IN OUR CITY BEEN
FORCING FOR A PILOT TO REDUCE
THE- SPEED LIMIT TO REALLY
REDUCE- AND REDUCE TRAFFIC AS
WELL AS TO ARRIVE NOT VERY MUCH
MITIGATE TRAFFIC. I THINK TO
BLAME- PEDESTRIANS FOR GETTING
HIT BY CARS IS- YOU KNOW I
DON'T WANT NOTHING THAT'S WHAT
YOU SAID BUT I THINK THAT IS
NOT THE RIGHT APPROACH EITHER
SO AGAIN. WE ARE THIS IS WHAT A
POINT WERE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
WALK. THE LAST THING THAT WE
SHOULD DO IS TO PENALIZE PEOPLE
FOR CROSSING THE STREET. WITH
THE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT FUNDS
WITHOUTA RESPECTFULLY ASK WILL
ONLY BE TWELVE THIRTY. THANK MR
TAN WITH CLERK WILL THE ROLE.
IS THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK
WELL CLOSER ALL TODD ABOUT ICE
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS TWELVE. THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING BACK IN THE FILE TO PICK
UP FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE. A. B.
FOUR NINETY FIVE MISTER GIBSON
CARBURY ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETY BY ASSEMBLY RIVER GIPSON
AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY POLICIES
THAT SHOULD GIVE SAID EMAIL
PRINT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL. A. B.
FOUR NINETY ANGELOS LAW WHICH
SEEKS TO BAN LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM USING RESTRAINTS THAT
CALLS POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA OR
ASPHYXIATION POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA IS A DEADLY CONDITION
THAT CAN OCCUR WHEN A PERSON
BEING RESTRAINED. CAN NOT BRIEF.
WHILE LAW ENFORCEMENT INTENDS
TO INCAPACITATE OR RENDER A
SUSPECT UNCONSCIOUS WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT ARMBAR CHILL COOLS
AND CAROTID RESTRAINTS ARE
DANGEROUS AND OFTEN LETHAL.
LAST YEAR MEMBERS AFTER HIGH
PROFILE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT IN
MINNEAPOLIS. SOCIAL UNREST TOOK
PLACE ALL OVER THE NATION AND
INTERNATIONALLY. RESPONDING TO
THE COMMUNITY WITHOUT WASTING
ANYTIME I AUTHORED LANDMARK
LEGISLATION. AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX I MEAN IF YOU'RE ON THE
FLOOR THE MAJORITY OF YOU ON
THIS FLOOR SUPPORTED THAT BILL
IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED THAT
BILL INTO LAW TO BAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING SHOKO.
WE NOW NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL METHODS OF RESTRAINING
SOMEONE DO NOT TURN.
UNNECESSARILY DEADLY. AS WE ALL
KNOW THAT OFFICER. WHO KNEELED
ON GEORGE FLORES NECK DID SO
FOR MORE THAN. NINE MINUTES AND
TWENTY EIGHT SECONDS UNTIL HE
LAID LIFELESS. IN DECEMBER ON
DECEMBER THE TWENTY SIX TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY SEVEN MONTHS
AGO. ANGELO TITO MEMBERS YOU
MAY NOT KNOW THAT INDIVIDUAL
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT ANGELO
KETO A THIRTY YEARS OLD NAVY
VETERAN FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHO WAS TRAGICALLY KILLED BY
ANY ARMED POLICE. ANGELO I HAD
BEEN SUFFERING FROM A MENTAL
HEALTH EPISODE WHEN HIS FAMILY
HIS FAMILY CALLED POLICE TO
HELP. DE ESCALATE THE SITUATION
BUT IN FACT THEY ESCALATED THE
SITUATION POLICE RESPONDED AND
AGILE LAID FACE DOWN BLOODY.
HANDS CUFFED A RESPONDING
OFFICER NEIL DON'T ANGELO KING
SNACK FOR NEARLY FIVE MINUTES.
NEARLY FIVE MINUTES MEMBERS.
AND THEN WHEN HE GOT TIRED
ANOTHER OFFICER. NERONE ANGELOS
NECK AND TOOK OVER ANGELO LOST
AND NEVER REGAINED
CONSCIOUSNESS HE DIED AT THE
HOSPITAL THREE DAYS LATER. HIS
FAMILY WITNESSED THIS HORRIFIC
TRAGEDY NO FAMILY MEMBERS EVER
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE SUCH AN
ORDEAL LIKE THE KETO FAMILY HAD
TO EXPERIENCE THIS CIRCUMSTANCE
OF ANGELO KEY DOES DEATH. OUR
IS A STARK RESTORED PARALLEL OF
GEORGE FLOWING. WHICH BOTH
EXPOSE LOOPHOLES IN THE USE OF
FORCE POLICIES GEORGE FLORES
ARCHERD BREEZE. HE SAID THAT
TWENTY TIMES ANGELO PINTO SAID
PLEASE DON'T KILL ME. PLEASE
DON'T KILL ME. IT'S NOT ABOUT
LIGHTS. IT'S NOT ABOUT SOCIAL
MEDIA POSTS. THIS IS ABOUT
LIVES. THAT THE LOAN HERE. BUT
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN AWAY FROM US EVERYONE
SHOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY AND
THE RIGHT TO BREATHE. THIS IS A
QUESTION WE SHOULD BE ASKING
OURSELVES. EHRMANN OUR
BROTHER'S KEEPER AM I MY
SISTER'S KEEPER ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOUR NINETY CREATE A UNIFORM
STATEWIDE POLICY ON RESTRAINTS
THAT CALLS POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA
TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
RESTRAINTS ARE NO LONGER USE IN
THIS STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MISTER SPEAKER PERMISSION TO
USE THE PROPER. PERMISSION IN
THIRTY SECONDS MISTER GIBSON.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS I CAN'T
BREATHE. EVERYONE DESERVES THE
RIGHT TO A BREEZE. WE'RE
COUNTERING POLICE OFFICER.
THANK YOU. THANK GOODNESS
GIPSON MR LEE YOUR RECKLESS I
LIKE TO THINK MY COLLEAGUES LOS
ANGELES FOR BRING FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILLING SHEDDING MORE
SPOTLIGHT ON THE MURDER VENTURE
LOOKING SO JUST LIKE- THE OTHER
IS ALREADY VERY ELOQUENTLY PUT
THEY ARE VERY STARK PARALLELS
THESE CASES JUST AS EVERY AS
JUST AS EVERY ISSUE WE'RE
CONFRONTING RIGHT NOW WITH THE
ISSUE OF POLICE BRUTALITY OF
MAKING SURE THE PROPERTY WERE
RESPONDING TO MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES ALL THOSE CASES THAT
WERE LUMPED INTO ONE RIGHT
HERE. ONLY LOOK NO MORE THAN AN
HOUR AWAY FROM SOCCER AND WE
ARE RIGHT IN THE BAY AREA AND
TO SEE THAT SOMEONE A NAVY
VETERAN A FILIPINO AND THAT WAS
CALLING OUT FOR HELP WAS
MURDERED ON HAN CAMERON FROM
HIS FAMILY RIGHT HERE IN OUR
STATE SHOWS THAT POLICE
BRUTALITY AND THE FORCES THAT
WE HAVE STILL YET TO REFORM
FIX. OUR OUR- TO BE EFFECTIVE
ON ANYONE NO MATTER WHAT THEIR
SKIN COLORS ESPECIALLY ASIAN
AMERICANS JUST AS MUCH ARE ARE
VULNERABLE THESE THINGS. AND
THAT'S WHAT'S ON BOARD TO DO
COMMONSENSE THINGS LIKE THIS TO
BAN. THE VAN POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA. TO NOT MAKE IT SO
THAT SOMEONE HAS TO BE ASHAMED
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT LONGER
BREED. AND THOSE ARE THE COMMON
SENSE THINGS THAT THIS BILL IS
DOING TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE. NOT SUCCEEDED I'M NOT
CERTAINLY KILLED WHEN THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE ESPECIALLY RAIN
FURTHER FAMILY WHEN THEY'D BE
NEED HELP THE MOST BECAUSE-
WHEN PEOPLE CALL FOR NINE ONE
ONE TO CALL FOR HELP. THEY'RE
CALLING FOR HELP THEY ARE NOT
HOPING THAT THAT WILL RESULT IN
THEIR OWN TIME UNTIMELY DEMISE
AND CERTAINLY THAT'S WHY I'M
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IS A
PROUD. CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
AND WHEN TO TAKE THE AUTHOR
AGAIN FIRST HARD WORK ON THIS
AND I SAID- DR. THANK YOU
MISTER LEE MR LACKEY. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS LET ME BEGIN BY
SAYING NO ONE SUPPORTS POLICE
MISCONDUCT NO ONE SUPPORTS
TRAGEDY. AND I WILL TELL YOU
HERE'S HERE'S ONE UNIQUE THING
ABOUT POSITIONAL ASPHYXIA. IT'S
A VERY COMPLICATED- SORT OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. THAT THE IS IT
THEMSELVES OF CERTAIN RESISTIVE
CIRCUMSTANCES WHEN YOU HAVE. A
SUSPECT. WHO- BECOMES EXTREMELY
COMBATIVE AND IT IT DOESN'T
ROUTINE BUT IT IT HAPPENS
FAIRLY ON. REGULAR BASIS THAT
YOU GET EXTREMELY VIOLENT AND
RESISTIVE SUSPECTS. AND THAT
REQUIRES INTERVENTION BY THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN CALLED TO
PRESERVE THE PEACE AND RESTORE
ORDER. AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS
WHEN I'M TRYING TO TELL YOU
FOLKS IS. MANY OF YOU CAN
IMAGINE THE DEGREE TO WHICH
SOME PEOPLE RESIST. TO THE
POINT TO WHERE THEY KICK OUT
WINDOWS IN THE PATROL CAR. THEY
CONTINUALLY SCREAM AND YELL
EVEN NO MATTER WHAT FORM OF
INTERVENTION YOU TRY. SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS YOU HAVE TO PUT ON
LEG RESTRAINTS. UNLIKE
RESTRAINTS COUPLED WITH HAND
RESTRAINTS. REQUIRE A SUSPECT
TO REMAIN. STEADY AS THEY ARE
INSTRUCTED IN THE BACK OF THE
PATROL CAR BECAUSE IF THEY MOVE
A CERTAIN DIRECTION THEY WILL
SELF INFLICT THIS POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA THAT WE'RE REFERRING
TO. THIS HAPPENS WAY MORE OFTEN
THAN IT SHOULD. BUT IT'S NOT
THE PEACE OFFICERS FAULT. IT'S
THE PERSON WHO HAS CHOSEN TO
RESIST AND FIGHT AND NOT LISTEN
TO INSTRUCTION THEY PUT
THEMSELVES IN A VERY VERY GRAVE
SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES AND THEY
ARE TOLD THAT BUT YOU THINK
THEY'RE LISTENING. IT'S NOT
LIKELY. AND SO. TO BLAME
OFFICERS IN ALL INSTANCES OF
POLICE. NATIONALS PICTURE IS AN
UNFAIR MANDATE. EVERYBODY
UNDERSTANDS THE TRAGEDY OF
GEORGE FLOYD I HAVE NOT HEARD
ANY ADVOCATES SAYING THAT THAT
WAS NOT AN EXTREME TRAGEDY.
MANY OF THESE TRAGEDIES THAT
HAPPENED IN THE CUSTODY OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE REGRETTABLE AND
SHOULD BE AVOIDED AT ALL COSTS.
BUT TO SAY THE POSITIONAL
ASPHYXIA IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
THE FAULT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ALSO EXTREMELY UNFAIR. UNWISE
AND UNJUST SO I'D ASK YOU TO
VOTE NO ON THIS MEASURE. MR LOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES LIKE TO COMMEND OUR
ASSEMBLY COLLEAGUE FROM CARSON
FOR BRING THIS MEASURE FORD.
WHEN I SAW THE OUR COLLEAGUE
EARLY ON THE FLOOR TODAY HE
SEEMED A BIT PENSIVE AND HE HAD
A GREAT SENSE OF PURPOSE AN
OBLIGATION ESPECIALLY WITH THIS
MEASURE I ASKED HIM WHY HE
SEEMED PENSIVE. EIGHT EIGHT OH
HE WAS STRUCK BY THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE CAN TO
FAMILY A SPECIFICALLY ON THE
OBLIGATION THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
US ON THIS MEASURE. AND I RICH
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS AS THIS IS
A SENSIBLE AND SURGICAL
APPROACH TO MAKING SURE THAT WE
CORRECT THE MISTAKES OF THE
PAST A LOSS OF RECOGNIZING THAT
WE HAVE A AN OBLIGATION. TO
HELPING ENSURE THAT WE PROTECT
MEMBERS OF OUR PUBLIC. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MR LOW AND MISTER JONES
SAWYER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINETY. TO
PROHIBIT LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS FROM USING HARMFUL
TECHNIQUES THAT PUT INDIVIDUALS
AT RISK OF A FIXATION. I
PROBABLY WANTED A FEW HERE.
THAT NO FORTY YEARS AGO. THERE
WAS THIS CHIEF OF POLICE NAME
DEROGATE. AND WHEN IT CAME TO
THE CHOKEHOLD AT THAT TIME.
CHIEF GAVE THOUGHT IT WAS
SHOWING COMPASSION AND
SENSITIVITY. WHEN HE ASKED HIS
AIDES TO CONFIRM HIS HUNT.
MERCED HUNCH. THAT BLACKS MIGHT
NOT RECOVER AS QUICKLY AS
WHITES FROM CAROTID CHUCKLES.
WE MAY BE FINDING THAT IN SOME
BLACKS WHEN IT THE CHOKEHOLD IS
APPLIED THE VEINS AND ARTERIES
DO NOT OPEN AS FAST AS THEY DO
IN NORMAL PEOPLE. THAT WAS
FORTY YEARS AGO. NINETEEN
EIGHTY TWO. AND YOU HAD THE
CHIEF OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY THAT BELIEVES. THAT
PROBABLY DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT
AFRICAN AMERICANS WERE NORMAL
PEOPLE AND THAT'S WHY THEY DIED
DURING THAT TIME. NOT BLAMING
THE OFFICER PROBABLY NINE
BLAMING HIMSELF. AND I THINK
WHAT EVERYBODY IS TRYING TO DO
IS COME UP WITH THE METHODOLOGY.
THAT WILL NOT. ULTIMATELY HURT
AND KILL ANYONE THAT'S INVOLVED
IN A POLICE ALTERCATION I
NOTICED TRUE FROM A VICE CHAIR
OF PUBLIC SAFETY. WHAT WE DO
HAVE TO DO IS MAYBE COME
TOGETHER. AND TALK WITH EXPERTS
ON AN ALTERNATIVE WAY. OF USING
WHATEVER METHODOLOGY TO IT TO
MAKE SURE THAT NO ONE
ULTIMATELY DICE. BECAUSE AS
CHIEF CASE WAS TRYING TO
EXPLAIN. HE WAS TRYING TO BLAME
IT ON THE PERSON. NOT THE
TECHNIQUE AND NOT LOOKING
TOGETHER. LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CARSON MCCAULEY FROM
PALMDALE I BELIEVE IT'S TWO OF
THEM GOT TOGETHER AND TALKED
ABOUT WHAT IS THE NEXT
GENERATION OF READ THE BILL
POLICE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
BEING ABLE TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE THAT THE ARRESTING
THIRTY WE MOVE FORWARD-
CHOKEHOLDS. DEVELOPED OVER TIME
OF THE METHODOLOGY THAT MY VICE
CHAIR TALK ABOUT DIDN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT IT DEVELOP OVER TIME
AND THAT WAS THE BEST WAY OF
DOING THINGS NOW WE'RE SAYING
THAT MAYBE WE NEED TO TAKE IT
TO THE NEXT GENERATION HAS
ARRIVED I BELIEVE WHAT WHAT THE
AUTHORS TRYING TO DO. IS GET US
TO THAT- AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK EVERYONE TO VOTE FOR THIS
SO THAT NOT ONLY THAT WE MOVE
IT FORWARD. BUT BET POLICING
STARTS TO MOVE FORWARD INTO THE
NEXT GENERATION TO TWENTIETH
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THIS BILL.
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR- YOUR YOUR
REMARKS AND APPRECIATE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU I WANT TO TAKE
LIBERTIES AS THE THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALM DEL
LANCASTER I HONOR HIS YEARS OF
SERVICE TO THIS STATE- AS A
HIGH PATROLMAN I HONOR HIS
WISDOM AND ALSO HIS EXPERIENCE.
I ALSO FOUGHT WITH SIMPLY SAY-
BECAUSE THE REDDICK WHAT HAS
BEEN- THAT WE'RE TAKING A TOOL
OUT OF THE TOOL BOX ALONG
PORTSMOUTH THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY TALKS ABOUT- A
PERSON'S ABILITY TO BREED-
ANGELO CANTIL WHATEVER
SITUATION HE WAS GOING TO WHICH
IS A MENTAL ILLNESS HIS FAMILY
CAUGHT NOT ONLY TO HAVE THE
PLEASE COME IN RESPONSE TO DE
ESCALATE THE SITUATION AS A
MATTER OF FACT IT ESCALATE THE
SITUATION- GEORGE FLOYD DIDN'T
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO WANT
TO EVEN GO TO BE BOOKED TO EVEN
GO AND STAND BEFORE JURY OF HIS
PEERS WHATEVER HE MAY HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED UP HE WAS NOT GIVEN
THAT OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE HIS
BREATHING WAS RESTRICTED SO
MUCH NINE MINUTES AND TWENTY
EIGHT SECONDS AND HE DIED
ANGELO KATO THIRTY YEARS OLD.
WAS A NAVY VETERAN TO THIS
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA- A
TECHNIQUE THAT WAS USED IN
PROPERLY THAT BECAUSE THIS
YOUNG MAN TO LOSE HIS LIFE I'M
SIMPLY SAID TO AB FOR NINETY
IT'S ABOUT GIVING UP
INDIVIDUALS THE ABILITY TO
BRIEF JUST LIKE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BREATHE NO FAMILY
SHOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH WITH
THE KEEP THE FAMILY HAS BEEN
THROUGH- MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR A STRONG AYE VOTE. ON
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY. THEY
GIVE US GIVE SENT AWAY FACT
WILL- OPEN THE ROLE. WE
DESIGNED VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL. CLOSE ROLE. TELEVOTE EYES
FORTY NINE KNOWS FIVE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS IN FILE
ORDER WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP.
THIS PARA QUE HANS ITEMS WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS. FIRST ITEM
FIRMAS PARA QUE HAN FILE ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR. AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
SIX CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF OUR QUE HAN AND
OTHERS AMERICA LIVING THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THIS PARA QUE HAN.
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX THIS IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT UPDATES ARE LAWS TO
ADDRESS THE THREATS THE
PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS AT A
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CLINIC
SPACE. ROE VERSUS WADE IS THE
LAW OF THE LAND PEOPLE HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SEEK
SERVICES FOR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CLINICS. WITHOUT THEIR
FREE WILL BEING VIOLATED. THERE
IS NO QUESTION THAT WHEN
SOMEONE GOES TO SEEK HEALTH
CARE THEY'RE ENTITLED TO. THEY
SHOULD DO SO FREELY AND WITHOUT
INTIMIDATION OR FEAR OF
VIOLENCE. HOWEVER THE LAWS
PROTECTING THIS RATE HAVEN'T
BEEN UPDATED SINCE THE TWO
THOUSANDS SENSE THEN PROTESTERS
A CLINICS HAVE BECOME
DRASTICALLY MORE EXTREME IN
THEIR TACTICS AND POWERED BY
ADVANCES IN TECHNOLOGY.
EXTREMIST PROTESTERS. RETURNED
DAY AFTER DAY HARASSING IN
FILMING PATIENTS AND PROVIDERS
THEY POST THESE IMAGES ON
WEBSITES WITH PROVIDERS
PERSONAL INFORMATION SEARCHABLE
FOR MILLIONS TO SEE. EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF US IS PROTECTED IN
THE PRIVACY OF WHAT HEALTH CARE
WE RECEIVE HER HEAD BACK. IT
SHOULD BE NO DIFFERENT FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH PATIENTS.
CURRENT LAW IN THE FACE ACTED
NOT REFLECT THE SEVERITY OF
THIS THREAT. WHEN A PATIENT
FACES ON MANY GREATER CRESSMAN
INTERVAL MOM VULNERABLE MOMENT
THEY ARE BEING DENIED THAT
RIGHT TO HEALTH CARE. OUR LAWS
AND WE ARE FAILING TO PROTECT
THEM. THIS BILL MERELY UPDATES
ARE LAWS TO INCREASE FINES FOR
ONLINE HARASSMENT AND
INTENTIONAL TEARS ATION OF
PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS. AND
INCREASES PENALTIES FOR REPEAT
VIOLENT OFFENSES. IT ALSO
IMPROVES NEEDED TRAINING FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO PROPERLY
RESPOND AND ACTUALLY PROSECUTE
THESE CRIMES THAT ARE HAPPENING
IN OUR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND-
SOMEHOW WE HAVE ACCEPTED THE
STATUS QUO. OVER PENALIZES
MARIJUANA POSSESSION BELIEVES
YOUNG WOMEN VICTIMS OF DEATH
THREATS SIMPLY FOR SEEKING
HEALTHCARE UNPROTECTED. THIS
MEMBERS IS UNACCEPTABLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
IN PROTECTING PATIENTS IN
SEEKING THE HEALTHCARE THAT
THEY NEED. THANK YOU IS BETTER
CARE. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A- CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
OF ICE FORTY NINERS ELEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE OH
THREE. A. B. NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
ALSO BY MISS AMERICA HAND FILE
ITEM ONE OF THREE AB. NINE
EIGHT EIGHT CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE NINE EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OUR QUE
HAN AND OTHERS AND ACCLIMATE TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES. THIS PARA
QUE AN EMAIL. THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB NINE EIGHT EIGHT. WE
JUST LISTEN TO OUR COLLEAGUE.
FROM LOS ANGELES SPEAK IN
PASSION AND- ABOUT ANGELO CAN
TELL IN HIS LIFE BEING TAKEN.
ANGELO CAN SHOW IS IN THE MIDST
OF A SCHIZOPHRENIC EPISODE WHEN
HIS SISTER AND HIS MOTHER WERE
AFRAID BECAUSE HE WAS HUGGING
THEM A LITTLE TOO TIGHTLY. THEY
NEEDED HELP. WHEN PEOPLE NEED
HELP WHO THEY CALL. THEY CALL
NINE ONE ONE. AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOWED UP. AND THAT
EVENING AND LOOK INTO DIED.
MILES HALL TODAY ONE TODAY'S
THE ANNIVERSARY OF MILES HALL'S
DEATH. MILES HALL IS AN
INCREDIBLE YOUNG MAN WHO LIVED
IN MY DISTRICT. HE WAS ALSO
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS.
HIS INCREDIBLE MOTHER HAD DONE
EVERYTHING SHE COULD TO GET THE
RESOURCES SHE NEEDED TO GET
MILES THE HELP HE NEEDED WHEN
HE WAS IN CRISIS. SHOULD CALL
THEIR LOCAL POLICE DEPARTMENT
TO MAKE SURE THEY KNEW. WHO
MILES WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN HE WAS IN AN EPISODE THEY
WOULD TREAT HIM THE WAY HE
DESERVES TO BE TREATED. BUT ON
THE DAY THAT MILES WAS KILLED
SHE NEEDED HELP. SO SHE CALLED
NINE ONE ONE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARRIVED. AND HE WAS
KILLED SHORTLY THEREAFTER. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT SAYS THAT
THOSE SUFFERING FROM MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS DESERVE A HEALTH
CARE IN A MENTAL HEALTH CARE
RESPONSE. AND THAT MY FRIENDS
IS NOT TOO MUCH FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO EXPECT THEY
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A SYSTEM
BY WHICH WHEN THEY ARE
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL ILLNESS.
THEY DON'T TURN TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE TRAINED TO
DEAL WITH MENTAL ILLNESS THEY
TURNED TO TRAINED PROFESSIONALS
WHO CAN DEAL WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CARE NEEDS. SO THIS BILL. WHICH
NOW JUSTICE ALLERGIES OR INTENT
TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON WHAT
CONGRESS UNANIMOUSLY MY FRIENDS
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IN
WASHINGTON. GOT TOGETHER
UNANIMOUSLY. PRESIDENT TRUMP
SIGNED ENABLING LEGISLATION
INTO LAW SAYING THAT WE AS A
STATE HAVE THE POWER TO SET UP
THE NINETY EIGHT SYSTEM TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS INTO A REAL AND
MEANINGFUL MENTAL HEALTH CARE
CRISIS RESPONSE SYSTEM. SO THIS
BILL WILL PUT US ON THE PATH
FORWARD TO SETTING UP THAT
STRUCTURE. AND I ASK FOR YOU TO
BE MY PARTNERS IN THIS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE THIS
RESPONSE THE 25% OF THOSE. WHO
WERE SHOT BY OFFICERS WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS RESPONSE CRISIS DESERVE
THIS THE 30% OF THE HOMELESS
PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS WHO ARE
SUFFERING. FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
DESERVE THIS AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE IT TO THEM
FOR AB NINETY DAYS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER OUT OF IT.
THANK IS BACKING HIM IS FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND- MEMBERS YOU'VE
HEARD ME FROM TIME TO TIME TALK
ABOUT CRISIS INTERVENTION. ON
THE ON SEVERAL LEVELS OF MENTAL
HEALTH. THIS IS A GOOD
COMMONSENSE APPROACH- I
GATHERED MY POLICE CHIEFS IN MY
SHERIFF IN SOLANO COUNTY. THE
BROWN TO HELP MENTAL HEALTH.
DIRECTORS IN OUR COUNTY TO
ADDRESS. THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
GOT THE COMMITMENT TO CREATE
THIS- TRAINING PROGRAM FOR
DISPATCHERS HOW TO DISCERN. ALL
WHO TO DISPATCH- OF THE ALSO.
THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS
RECOGNIZE. THAT THERE ARE
BETTER EQUIPPED PEOPLETO
ATTAIN BETTER RESULTS. I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS REALLY
GOING FORWARD ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT ACTUALLY HAVE OCCURRED
ALSO IS WITH. THE I. D. D.
POPULATION WITH THE PARENTS
HAVE BEHAVIORAL ISSUES WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. I URGE YOU TO
SEE A DANGEROUS SON A
DOCUMENTARY THAT SHARES THE
PLIGHT OF PARENTS WHO HAVE HAD
THESE- UNFORTUNATE OCCURRENCES
WERE A TRAINED PROFESSIONAL
NEEDS TO BECOME A COME OUT TO
ADDRESS THE SITUATION DE
ESCALATE AND GET THEM THE
APPROPRIATE. HELP THAT THEY
DESERVE. I URGE ABSOLUTE URGE
RIVAL. THANKS FRAZIER MISTER
LUCKY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
WASN'T GOING TO STAND. ON THIS
PARTICULAR MEASURE BUT I FEEL.
A STRONG COMMITMENT TO THIS
PARTICULAR PROBLEM. BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN. VERY VERY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES TRY TO BE MANAGED.
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT THEN YOU
GOTTA REMEMBER TRAINING. THIS
FOCUSED ON BEHAVIOR AND TO TRY
TO A- CONTROL BEHAVIOR NOT THE
CAUSE OF THE BEHAVIOR. AND IT'S
TIME THAT THIS SOCIETY. BOTH
POLITICALLY AND HUMANITY DRIVEN
CIRCUMSTANCES NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE TRAGEDY. OF
EXTREME MENTAL ILLNESS BUT
THERE'S ALSO BORDERLINE MENTAL
ILLNESS WE'RE NOT MANAGING THIS
VERY WELL. AND SO I'M THANKFUL
TO SEE THE PEOPLE ARE
RECOGNIZING THAT THE ONLY
INSTITUTION IT WAS BE RELIED
UPON TO MANAGE. MENTAL ILLNESS
ONCE LAW ENFORCEMENT WHAT A
TERRIBLE BURDEN TO BEAR. AND
I'M TELLING YOU THAT. SOME OF
THESE TRAGEDIES THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED. WE'RE NOT BECAUSE-
PEOPLE DIDN'T CARE THE WERE
WEARING THE BADGE. WE NEED
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
THE TRAINING. AND HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HELP AND I EMPHASIZE
THE WORD HELP. IT'S TIME LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THIS IS JUST ONE
STEP AND MANY STEPS THAT NEED
TO BE TAKEN I HOPE THAT WE WILL
TAKE MENTAL ILLNESS. FOR THE
SERIOUS. OXEN THAT IT HAS
BECOME IN OUR SOCIETY AND THESE
PEOPLE CAN BE HELPED AND THEY
DESERVE THAT HELP. NOT
PUNISHMENT. AND I ASKED YOU
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE. DAVID
SHELLAC HE SEE NO ADDITIONAL
YES MISTER GIBSON IN THE REAR
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO WASN'T
GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL BUT
I FEEL COMPELLED AND WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND CERTAINLY
STRONG ASKED OF MY COLLEAGUES
HERE ON THE FLOOR FOR A STRONG
AYE VOTE ON A. B. NINE EIGHT
EIGHT IF YOU'VE NEVER
ENCOUNTERED SOMEONE IN YOUR IN
YOUR PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. OF
WHO HAS MENTAL ILLNESS- YOU
DON'T HAVE TO LOOK VERY FAR WE
SEE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE INOUR
COMMUNITY WHO ABSOLUTELY NEED
HELP AND I BELIEVE THERE'S A
STATE TREMENDOUS PARADIGM SHIFT
TAKING PLACE NOT ONLY
CALIFORNIA BUT ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRYING OUT IN SPACES
IN WHICH THEY NEED HELP AND
CERTAINLY WE BELIEVE THAT WHEN
YOU WERE AT THE POINT OF BREAK
THROUGH OR OR BREAK DOWN IF I
SHOULD SAY THAT YOU NEED
SOMEONE YOU NEED AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CALL SOMEONE YOU NEED TO
HAVE. SOMEONE TO TALK YOU DOWN
AND SOMEONE WHO ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH AND BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
ALL BETTER WE ARE DEALING WITH
A NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN OUR
SOCIETY THAT IT IS HURTING AND
THIS PANDEMIC HAS REVEALED SO
MANY PEOPLE IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WE SERVE
ALL THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY HURTING
AND THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT IS
PANDEMIC HAPPENED WE'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
TRAUMA AS A RESULT OF THIS
PANDEMIC BUT ALSO HIDDEN TRAUMA
THAT IS NOW EMERGING AND
CERTAINLY I WOULD THINK THIS
THIS ARE OUR COLLEAGUES WANT TO
BRING THIS BILL FOR WE BELIEVE
IT'S GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND THANK YOU FOR
SAVING PEOPLE'S LIVES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
HURTING THE MOST. THANKS GIVE
SENT. SEEING THEIR- ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THIS PARA
QUE HAN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I JUST WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES- FOR
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BELL I THINK. WHAT HOPEFULLY
EVERYONE ON THIS FLOOR GREASE
WITH IS THAT THOSE SUFFERING
DESERVE. THE TREATMENT AND THE
CARE THAT IS GOING TO HELP THEM
GET BETTER THERE ARE VERY FEW
PEOPLE I'VE SPOKEN TO ABOUT
THIS BILL THEY DON'T HAVE A
STORY AND A MOMENT IN THEIR
LIVES FOR FRIENDS. FAMILY
MEMBER. THAT THIS WOULD HAVE
HELPED AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THIS CHANGE
TOGETHER MEMBERS. AND I ASK
THAT WE DO SO. TODAY AS I
MENTIONED IS WHAT INTO STUDIOS
AND IT'S CALLED THE ART SIDE OF
MILES HALL. HE DIED. ON THIS
DAY AND WE GET TO REMEMBER HIM
AND PASS A LAW. THAT COULD HAVE
CHANGED THE COURSE OF HIS LIFE
AND WILL CHANGE THE COURSE OF
OTHERS LIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ABBOTT. AND WITH THAT
CIRCLE OF THE ROLE. IS THAT A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A-
CLARK WELL. CLOTHES ARE ALL
TIDE OF ICT SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. THERE IS WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE
TO TAKE A FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY FIVE
MUSIC HERE CURRIES A. B.
FOURTEEN. CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS IN THAT
RELATING TO COMMUNICATIONS AND
CLEARLY YOU'LL SEE THERE ARE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY MISTER SPEAKER I
AM PLEASED TO THE LEVEL OF
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL FOR BROADBAND.
HOWEVER UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE
PASSES THE BUDGET AND WE GET
NEW ESTIMATES OF THE COST OF
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE
INCREASED INTERNET SPEEDS
CALLED FOR IN THE BUDGET AND
BILLS MOVING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. I INTEND TO CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR CONTINUING THE
EXISTING FEE TO THE FUND
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE FOR A.
B. FOURTEEN. THE ONGOING COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS MADE IT
GLARINGLY CLEAR HOW CRITICAL
CONNECTIVITY IS IN THE TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES. INCLUDING THE
MASSIVE TRANSITION OF STUDENTS
LEARNING FROM HOME AND DURING
THE STATE'S RECENT DEVASTATING
FIGHT WILDFIRES. THE DESPERATE
NEED FOR BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY
IN SMALL TOWNS AND RURAL AREAS
LIKE THOSE IN MY DISTRICT I
CONTINUED GIPSON IRMA
COMMUNITIES CANNOT BE IGNORED.
I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION. MORE DEBATE ON THE
ITEM OR CALL THE ROLL. ALL
MEMBERS OF. IS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON
THE URGENCY. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
EYES FIFTY FOUR NOTES HERE ON
THE URGENCY AS FIFTY FOUR NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE. THAT BILL
PASSES. MS RAYOS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. ON YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE
INACTIVE FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
EIGHT THIRTY TWO ITEM SEVENTY
AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE AND ITEM.
ONE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
ONE. THE CLERK WILL NOTE. AND
MISERY AS YOU HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL ANNOUNCEMENT YES I
JUST WANTED TO TELL THE MEMBERS
THAT WE HAVE. ONLY TAKEN UP
TWENTY THREE ITEMS- THIS
MORNING WE'VE HAD A FEW
DIFFICULT ONES AND ONE OF OUR
MANY OF YOU FELT COMPELLED TO
SHARE- I'M NOT TELLING YOU NOT
TO SHARE- BUT WE DO HAVE A
TOTAL UNIVERSE OF ABOUT JUST
UNDER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY.
YESTERDAY I'M VERY PROUD THAT
YOU ALL WERE ABLE TO- DISPENSED
WITH A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE.
ITEMS SO I'M NOT TELLING YOU TO
DO A HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE BUT-
IF WE- TAKE CARE OF BUSINESS WE
WILL BE OUT OF HERE SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER I DEFINITELY
DO NOT WANT YOU TO HAVE TO COME
BACK ON FRIDAY THAT'S STILL THE
GOAL. AND THE TOMORROW WE WILL
BE HERE. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE A
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN THIS IS. AB
ONE TWENTY FOUR PRESENTED BY
MISS GARCIA CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY FOUR
BY FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KAMLAGER AND OTHERS NOT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
MS GARCIA YOU MAY OPEN YES
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
AS THE CHAIR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS 2% AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR COM LONGER WITH
THIS ALSO WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL. AB ONE TWENTY
FOUR JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS WITH
SUPPORT SURVIVORS OF VIOLENCE
INCLUDING INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THROUGHOUT
THE SENTENCING IN EVERY SENSE
OF HE FACES OF THE POOR
PROCESS. BY REQUIRING COURTS TO
CONSIDER THE FULL PICTURE OF A
PERSON'S RELEVANT CIRCUMSTANCES
AND EXPERIENCES. SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING TRAFFICKING
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE WHO ARE
PREDOMINATELY BLACK BROWN AND
INDIGENOUS WOMEN QUEER AND
TRANS PEOPLE ARE NOT
SUFFICIENTLY RECOGNIZED OR
SUPPORTED AS VICTIMS BY THE
LEGAL SYSTEM. ACCORDING TO THE
ACLU NEARLY 60% OF FEMALE STATE
PRISONERS NATIONWIDE AND AS
MANY AS NINETY FOUR SO THE
FEMALE PRISON POPULATIONS.
EXPERIENCE PHYSICAL OR SEXUAL
ABUSE BEFORE BECOMING
INCARCERATED. BY ADDRESSING
MANY OF THE GAPS AND FAILURES
OF THE CURRENT LEGAL SYSTEM AB
ONE TWO FOUR CREATES JUST COMES
MOVING FORWARD TO. PROVIDE FULL
CONTEXT OF THE EXPERIENCES THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO SURVIVORS ACTIONS
OR IN ACTIONS. IN USE IS A MORE
HUMAN I SEE THE AND TRAUMA
INFORMANTS TO CRIMINAL
ADJUDICATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
GARCIA SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERA. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. MEMBERS VOTED
OUT OF THE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING ABOUT ICE
FIFTY NEWS TO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY AB FIVE FORTY THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL FIVE
FORTY BY SOME MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS INOCULATING TO
THE ELDERLY MISS PETER NORTH
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AS EIGHTY
FIVE FORTY ARTICLE THAT THIS
BILL IS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
PACE THE PROGRAM FOR ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY.
PACE ALLOWS ELIGIBLE SENIORS TO
RESIDE IN YOUR HOME AND
PROVIDES ALL INCLUSIVE MEDICARE
AND MEDI CAL COVERED BENEFITS
THROUGH ONE STOP SHOP HE
CENTERS PAYS IS A PROVEN
SUCCESS STORY FIVE WITH HIGH
LEVELS AS- ADD SUCCESS FOR
ENROLLED PATIENTS INCLUDING
FEWER HOSPITALIZATIONS AND
NURSING HOME ADMISSIONS BETTER
HEALTH AND QUALITY OF LIFE. AND
HIGH RATES AT PARTICIPATING
PARTICIPANT SATISFACTION WITH
OVERALL CARE IT'S ALSO A MONEY
SAVER FOR THE STATE FARM EVEN
THE PACE IS A MODEL OF CARE AND
THE BENEFITS ARE MANY ODD THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS IS
FRAGMENTED AND HAD KNOWLEDGE OF
THE PROGRAM IS LIMITED SO THIS
BILL WILL ATTEMPT TO. AT ENSURE
THAT LOW INCOME SENIORS ARE
INFORMED ABOUT PACE AS A CARE
OPTION WHEN ENROLLING IN
MEDICARE AND ENSURE THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS AVAILABLE TO MORE
ARE AT CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
PATIENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THE YOU MISTY
TRAINER AS C. AND HEARING
FURTHER DELAY ON THE MATTER
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS HOME MEMBERS VOTED
AMERICA. ON MEMBERS VOTED VERY
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY TWO
NOTED HERE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE NOW ON FILE ITEM SEVEN
WE'RE BACK IN FILE ORDER. SO WE
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
SIX AB FOURTEEN OH FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
FOURTEEN OH FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WICKS AND ACCORDING TO
CONSUMER DEBT. THIS WORKS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS WITH MANY CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLING WITH THE ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF COVER NINETEEN IT IS
IMPORTANT THERE ARE STRONG
PROTECTIONS. TO PREVENT
CONSUMERS FOR FROM FALLING IN
THE FIRST. FROM FALLING INTO
WORSE FINANCIAL SITUATIONS.
THERE'S CURRENTLY LITTLE TO NO
REGULATION OF DEBT SETTLEMENT
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT REFLECT
THE CHANGING PRACTICES OF THIS
INDUSTRY WHICH HAS MADE
ENFORCEMENT MORE DIFFICULT.
THIS LACK OF REGULATIONS LED TO
INCREASE PREDATORY BEHAVIOR BY
SOME BAD ACTORS WITHIN THE DEBT
SETTLEMENT INDUSTRY. MOREOVER
THE LACK OF REGULATIONS OF THIS
GROWING INDUSTRY HAS RESULTED
IN CONFUSED AND FRUSTRATED
CUSTOMERS SPENDING ADDITIONAL
TIME AND MONEY TRYING TO DEAL
WITH. UNANTICIPATED DEBT
COLLECTION LAWSUITS OF THEIR
OWN ROLE DEBTS. AB FOURTEEN OH
FIVE OH MODERNIZE CURRENT LAW
TO BETTER REFLECT THE
INDUSTRY'S PRACTICES AND
IMPROVE REGULATION DEBT
SETTLEMENT COMPANIES BY
ENSURING. THAT ALL THAT
SETTLEMENT COMPANIES OPERATING
CALIFORNIA ARE COVERED BY
CALIFORNIA LAW. PROHIBITING
THAT SOMEONE COMPANIES FROM
ENGAGING IN DECEPTIVE
PRACTICES. REQUIRING CLEAR
DISCLOSURES FOR CONSUMERS AND
PROVIDING REMEDIES FOR
CONSUMERS. I'VE HAD EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND I PLAN TO
CONTINUE THESE CONVERSATIONS TO
ADDRESS THEIR REMAINING
CONCERNS. HAVE ALSO TAKEN A
MOMENT FROM THE SENATE BANKING-
ASSEMBLY BANKING HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS. THIS
BILL PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR CONSUMERS TO MAKE INFORMED
CHOICE FROM A WIDE SELECTION OF
SAY FINANCIAL SERVICES. IN
ADDITION AB FORTINO FIVE LEVELS
THE PLAYING FIELD AMONG IN
STATE AND OUT OF STATE OUTSIDE
OF THE COMPANY'SBY REQUIRING
ALL THAT SOME COMPANIES TO
COMPLY. WITH THE SAME RULES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS WORK
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THERE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE
KNOWSTEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
WILL PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN THROUGH
SEVENTY NINE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHTY FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOR THE BURGLARY SOME
PEOPLE FORTY SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
OTHERS AND I RELATING TO
CRIMINAL PROCEDURE MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THE
MATTER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO PRESENT
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR A
BILL THAT WILL ADD MUCH NEEDED
LAYER OF GOOD GOVERNANCE AND
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY TO OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. BY
HAVING PROSECUTORS STATE THE
ESTIMATED COST OF A SENTENCE
FOR OPTIONAL JUDICIAL
CONSIDERATION DESPITE RECENT
REFORMS CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
LEAD THE NATION IN SPENDING ON
CORRECTIONS OVER THE PAST
DECADE DECADE CDCR SPENDING
INCREASED BY OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS OR APPROXIMATELY 30%
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY SPENDS
MORE ON CORRECTIONS THAN. TEXAS
IN YOUR COMBINED. THIS BLL
WILL BRING ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO THE SENTENCING PROCESS AND
HELP JUDGES TO CONSIDER THE
BROADER IMPACTS AS- OF THE
SENTENCES THAT THEY IMPOSE AND
RECOMMEND. AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
TAXPAYER RESOURCES ARE SPENT
WISELY IN A MANNER THAT TRULY
ADVANCES JUSTICE AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. THIS MESSAGE I SUPPORT
FROM NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS
VICTIMS RIGHTS GROUPS AND
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
MISSED OUR HANDS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR MEMBERS WE DO A LOT OF
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM WORK IN
THIS BODY ALL CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT WORK. AND THERE ARE
NUMEROUS REASONS FOR US TO
ENGAGE IN THIS WORK. TO HELP.
BETTER THE OUTCOMES OF THOSE
THAT ARE INCARCERATED TO
INCREASE REHABILITATION DURING
JUSTICE TO A SYSTEM THAT SO
DESPERATELY NEEDS IT AND LACKS
JUSTICE. AND ALSO DUE TO BE
FRANK BECAUSE WE'RE SPENDING
TOO MUCH MONEY ON OUR JAIL
SYSTEMS UNNECESSARILY. AND
DISCLOSURES AND TRANSPARENCY AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED. JUST
BRING SUNSHINE. AND LIGHT AND
THERE IS NO DOWNSIDE TO LETTING
FOLKS KNOW HOW MUCH WE'RE
SPENDING WHAT WILL COME OF THIS
BILL. WELL THEY CAN STILL
SENTENCE FOLKS TO AS LONG AS
THEY LIKE HE'S NOT STOPPING
THAT. BUT THE AUTHOR IS
ENSURING THAT IT IS A
CONSIDERATION. WILL IT THAT
HELP US TO SECOND GUESS HOW
MUCH WE'RE SPENDING PERHAPS.
WILL IT ENSURE THAT IT'S A
CONSIDERATION. I BELIEVE SO AND
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
BECAUSE- WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED
ON THIS ISSUE FOR ALL OF THE
REASONS. TO BE FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE TO HELP THOSE WHO
ARE INCARCERATED GET BETTER
OUTCOMES TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS JUSTICE IN WHO IS SENTENCED
AND FOR HOW LONG. YESTERDAY WE
PASSED AN EXTENSION MISTER
KALRA SPELL. AND DID JUST THAT
INSURED A LITTLE MORE JUSTICE
IN THIS IS ANOTHER STEP IN THAT
DIRECTION SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. DAVID BARKIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO OTHER MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK MR HERE REALLY
MAKE CLOTHES THANK YOU I'LL
JUST TAKE THE VERY THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
RATE DOES MY CLOSING
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. BUT YOU PUT A COUPLE
KALRA. MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. YEAH. IT.
FOR EXAMPLE. SEVERAL CLOSER
ROLE IN TELEVOTES HIGHS FORTY
THREE KNOWS THIRTEEN MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY ONE AB FIFTEEN FORTY
KERKORIAN SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY REVERTING AND
OTHERS AN AGGRAVATED CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE FIFTEEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN FORTY IS A
RECENT THING BILL. ARE THE
HONOR IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN OF
WORKING WITH. THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JEFF ROSEN FROM SANTA
CLARA ON DEVELOPING EVERY SENSE
THE BILL WOULD DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS COULD UPON FURTHER
CONSIDERATION LOOK AT CASES
THAT THEY ACTUALLY PROSECUTED.
AND BRING THEM BACK FORWARD OR
FOR RESENTENCING IT'S BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL WE'RE SEEING
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE HAVE INTEREST IN
TAKING A SECOND LOOK AT MANY OF
THOSE CASES. UNFORTUNATELY
CURRENT LAW DOESN'T GIVE JUDGES
VERY MUCH INFORMATION IN
ADDRESSING BUDGET INTERESTING
RESENTING CASES SO WHAT WE DO
IS AB FIFTEEN FORTY SPECIFIES
TIMELINES REQUIRES REASONS FOR
DENIALS TO BE IS TO SAY THAT ON
THE RECORD ALSO GIVES A
DEFENDANT'S RIGHT TO COUNSEL IN
SO MANY OF THESE ISSUES AND
WILL ALSO MAINTAINS JUDICIAL
DISCRETION. MOODY'S ISSUES
REALLY HELP STREAMLINE THIS
RESENTENCING PROCESS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD OF CONCERNS FROM THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION- WE DID AMEND THE
BILL PRIOR TO THE FLOOR TO
UPDATE THE BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT ELEMENT TO STATE
UNREASONABLE RISK OF DANGER TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. OF THE
PRESUMPTION CONTAINED IN AB
FIFTEEN FORTY RECOGNIZES THE
VETTING BY LAW ENFORCEMENT OF
THE C. FOR CANADA IT'S OF RE
SENSING IT DOES NOT GUARANTEE
THAT A PERSON WILL BE RE SENSE
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER. AYE VOTE ON AB FIFTEEN
FORTY. IF YOU CLEAR RECOGNIZED.
CALLER EXAMPLE TO RISE SINCE OF
THIS MAY I WILL THROUGH THE
WINDOW OF A SPECIFIC FACT
PATTERNS WHERE THERE WAS A
GENTLEMAN WHO IS UP IMPRISONED
IN THE COUNTY OF COLUSA ARISING
ROBUST ACCIDENT ARE UNDER
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH UNDER SOME
FROM COURT DECISIONS HE COULD
NOT HAVE BEEN PROSECUTED IN A
MANNER WHICH HE WAS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I ASK GOVERNOR BROWN
TO REVISIT THAT DECISION. THAT
FELL ON DEAF EARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY I DID SO AGAIN AND
GOVERNOR NEW SOME ENDED UP- OF
PROVIDING RACKS WITH THE
RELEASE WHICH IS WHAT I FELT
WAS THE RIGHT OUTCOME. SO THESE
SORTS OF FACT PATTERNS ARE OUT
THERE THEY'RE MATTERS OF
JUSTICE. AND ARM. FOR THOSE
INVOLVED IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. IT CAN FEEL
LIKE HOW DO YOU GET ANYONE TO
FOCUS ON YOUR CIRCUMSTANCE. ALL
ONCE YOU'RE IN THAT SYSTEM. AND
I THINK THISPROVIDES A-
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME HOPE. AND
SOME FLEXIBLE ON THE SYSTEM TO
RESPOND TO THE SPECIFIC FACTS.
INVOLVED HAVE GIVEN CASE- IT'S
NOT A- GRANT OF LARGESSE IT IS
JUST A REEXAMINED WHAT IS THE
MERIT. AND IRISH AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU MR COOLEY THINKING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER MISTER KING WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. KIRK WELL
OVER THERE ARE. VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
THEIR TO VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY ABOUT ICE
FORTY TWO NEWS THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES MOVING A FILE
ITEM. EIGHTY TWO AB FIFTEEN
FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME REAL FIFTEEN FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY WERE MCCARTY AND
OTHERS AN ECHOING IN DRUG
TREATMENT. THIS MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SORRY FOR
THE DELAY MADAM SPEAKER I'M
HERE TO PRESENT THIS BILL THIS
IS A DISTRICT BILL. IT WOULD
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM IN MY
DISTRICT FOR THE COUNTY OF YOLO
THE ADJACENT COUNTY NOT
SACRAMENTO ACROSS THE RIVER
HERE WHICH I. SHARE WITH ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES FROM DIXON WENT
DIXON WINTERS WRONG SAID EXCUSE
ME. THIS IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO GET AN
ALTERNATIVE SENTENCE TO GET
DRUG TREATMENT IMAGINE THAT WE
SEND IT'S TOO MANY PEOPLE. TO
PRISON WHO ARE DRUG ADDICTS AND
THEY COME OUT FRANKLY STILL
DRUG ADDICTS THIS WOULD
CORPORATION ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION. AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE HAVE BEEN CONVICTED
OF A FELONY. A NONVIOLENT NOR
SEX CRIME TO GET TREATMENT FOR
THEIR ADDICTION AND GET ON THE
ROAD TO RECOVERY. WE KNOW THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT WORKING
JUST LOOK ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE TOO MANY
PEOPLE GETTING ARRESTED FOR THE
CRIMES. FOR DRUG ADDICTION AND
NEVER GET TREATED AGAIN THIS IS
A PILOT. PROJECT PILOT PROGRAM
THE PROVIDE AN OPTION FOR
PROVIDERS. AND PROFESSIONALS TO
OFFER DRUG TREATMENT FOR IT FOR
INDIVIDUALS THIS WILL BE BASED
UPON SCIENCE. AND BASED UPON
EVIDENCE BASED RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT. AND WITH THAT I ASK
THE ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER CARTOON NETWORK'S W.
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO SUPPORT
AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO FOR VERY
PERSONAL REASONS. SOME OF YOU
MAY REMEMBER WHEN I SPOKE ABOUT
MY BROTHER BILLY. BILLY STORY
WHICH IS MANY OF OUR STORIES.
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES OF
SOMEONE WHO SUFFERED FROM AN
ADDICTION CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM.
AND MANY TIMES WOULD BE
RELEASED FROM IN AND OUT OF
GOING INTO JAIL THIS IS MY
BROTHER I WOULD GO STRAIGHT
BACK TO SOME OF THE SAME
PATTERNS ALWAYS VOWING TO DO
BETTER. HE ACTUALLY REALLY MANY
TIMES SAID HE WANTED TO WORK
JUST HAVE A SMALL PLACE TO LIVE
IT. WE INTERVENED AS MANY TIMES
AS WE COULD AND YET HE STILL
DIED. THIS PROGRAM A PILOT
PROGRAM WOULD GIVE THOSE WHO
CHOOSE TO. I WILL CHOOSE TO DO
IT VOLUNTARILY TO PARTICIPATE
IN A PILOT PROGRAM AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO JAIL OR PRISON.
WE HAVE FAR TOO MANY
INDIVIDUALS. FROM VERY YOUNG
AGES TO OLDER AGES THAT SFFER
FROM ADDICTION WHETHER IT'S
DRUGS OR ALCOHOLISM. AND WE DO
NOT TREAT THEM. THEY GO THROUGH
THE SYSTEM AND MANY OF THEM WE
SEE RIGHT NOW OUT ON OUR
STREETS I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
ASK YOU TO SUPPORT A PILOT
PROGRAM IN YOUR LOCALITY AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO. AN HONOR MY
BROTHER BILLY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS CLARK SILVA MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST REAL
QUICKLY I WANNA STAND IN
SUPPORT OF MY SEATMATE
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO I
KNOW THIS IS VERY CLOSE TO YOUR
HEART- AND VERY IMPORTANT I WAS
BEFORE I WENT INTO POLITICS I
WAS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
YOUTH COURT WHICH IS A JUVENILE
DIVERSION PROGRAM WE SAW THE
SUCCESS THAT IT HAD- AND WHAT
IT MEANT FOR. MY DISTRICT IN MY
REGION I KNOW WE WOULD- FEEL
PRETTY PAINFUL- FROM MY
COLLEAGUE IF THIS IF THIS
DIDN'T PASS AS WELL SO-
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY. THANK YOU MISTER IN
CHINA'S DAVIES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I ALSO WANT TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THIS IS
AFFECTED MY FAMILY AS WELL I
CAN TELL YOU THAT WHEN YOU ARE
IN JAIL OR PRISON. AT THE END
WHICH IT'S ALMOST TOO LATE THIS
WE CAN SEE A PROP FORTY SEVEN
VIEW YEARS AGO UNFORTUNATELY
WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU WERE
ARRESTED FOR DOING DRUGS- YOU
WOULD ACTUALLY RECEIVE THIRTY
DAYS A RE HAVE YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REDEEM YOURSELF
YOUR THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
HELP. BUT THAT NO LONGER WORKS
ANYMORE WE'VE GOT PEOPLE THAT
ARE BEING PICKED UP DOING
HEROIN FOUR TIMES A WEEK SO
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT WHAT'S SAD
IS THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY JUST A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS SO I
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THIS AND I
HOPE THAT- IT'S SUCCESSFUL AND
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD MAKING
THIS- SOMETHING THAT WILL BE A
LAW. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER IS MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED I JUST WANT TO PUT
IN A QUICK WORD TO IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL- SOME OF YOU MAY
KNOW THAT- JUST BEFORE COVERED.
TO HAD- I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TRAVEL TO. ITALY TO IT
PERSONALLY- REVIEW A LOCAL
COMMUNITY BASED MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM- THESE ARE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE WORKING. IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD WE ARE FACED
WITH A TSUNAMI. OF MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES GOING FORWARD.
COMING OUT OF CO GOOD- BUT THAT
EXISTED AND- BETWEEN SUBSTANCE
ABUSE WHICH IN MANY CASES LIKE
MATTHEWS LEADS TO PSYCHOSIS.
THESE ISSUES ALL ARE ALL
INTERTWINED IN THE BEST PLACE
FOR US TO ADDRESS THEM IS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. AND I THINK WE
NEED TO GIVE PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
A CHANCE AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER BLOOM SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MISS MCCARTY DIRECTLY. CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS WHO
DESERVE IT. BLOOMBERG WELL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT
ICE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY AB FIFTY SIXTY
A QUICK OVER SOME PEOPLE
FIFTEEN EIGHT BROTHER COMMITTEE
ON EMERGES MANAGEMENT AND THAT
THE IMAC TO THE STICKER
DECLARING THE USE OF THE MEDIA.
AFTER READING A FEW ARE A
ANOTHER THE YOU MADAM SPEAKER
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENT A B.
FIFTY SIX EIGHT THIS BILL BUILD
A EXISTING LAW REQUIRING CALL-
YES TEXT UP. A STATEWIDE
REGISTRY OF BUSINESSES NON OR-
INTERESTED IN DA SIR GO LABOR
EQUIP. RESOURCES FOR TO IN
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS. WITHOUT
SAID AB FIFTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WOULD REVISE EXISTING LAW TO
HEREBY REQUIRE COW- YES TO
DOVISH RIDGE OF BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
STRICTLY OUT STRUGGLE. THANK
YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEEING NO
FOR DEBATE ON MATTER FOR WILL
THE ROLE. PART OF A- ALL MEN OF
THE WHO DESERVE A. VOTED VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL FLOW THE ROLE IN
HOW THE ICE TWO ZERO THE
URGENCY ICE TWO HERE ON THE
THEM I PASSES. FOR SOME OF BILL
TEN TWENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MULLIN ACT LIVING
HOUSING TO DECLARE THE YEARS IS
HERE TAKE FOR IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER MIND YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THEY CAME OUT OF MEMBERS ALL
THE WAY OF THE BASS SHORT OF
AFFORDABLE. IN THE STATE ONE OF
THE LESSER KNOWN CONTRIBUTORS
TO THE ISSUE IS THE EXPIRATION
OF SO CALLED AFFORDABILITY
CONFIDENCE. WHEN CALIFORNIA HAD
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS THAT
RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE
AGENCY WERE REQUIRED TO RECORD
COVENANTS ON THE PROPERTY THAT
WE GUARANTEE THAT THOSE UNITS
WOULD REMAIN AFFORDABLE. AT
BELOW MARKET RATES FOR THIRTY
YEARS AND IN SOME INSTANCES
FIFTY FIVE YEARS. AS TIME
PASSES MANY OF THESE CONFIDENCE
REACHED THEIR TIME LIMIT TO
EXPIRE. AS OF TIME OF ITS
EXPIRE THE UNIT MAY THEN BE
RELEASED AT MARKET RATE. AS
EACH IT RESETS MARKET RATE IS
ONE LESS FOR UNITS THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO A LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLD AB TEN TWENTY NINE
SIMPLY ASK THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT TO. ADD
PRESERVATION OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS TO THEIR LIST OF
PRIORITIES FOR ALLOCATION OF
STATE FUNDING AND WITH. THAT I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER MULLIN THING HEARING
FURTHER DELAY ON THE MATTER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTED EITHER. ON
MEMBERS THIRD OF. ON MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. WHICH
MEANS AND NUMBER. SEVENTY THIS
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESERVE A.
MISTER MOM
IS A CALL. WE ARE MOVING TO
MISTER MULLIN CONTINUED TO DO
SPEAKER PRO TEM SPELLS WILL
MOVE TO FILE ITEM. FIFTY AB
EIGHT NINE SEVEN THE CLERK READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT NINE SEVEN S.
MEMBER AND THE CLIMATE CHANGE
FIFTY NINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER MEMBERS TO IS
A SO BUT VOTE. BOB IMPACT OF
CLIMB CHANGE WILL BASED ON A
COMMUNITIES PHYSICAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC CHARACTERISTICS WHICH
TEND TO EXTEND BEYOND CITY OR
COUNTY BOUNDARIES. THIS MAKES
REGIONAL COORDINATION BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS
AND PRIVATE SECTOR ENTITIES A
VITAL COMPONENT OF THOROUGH
RESILIENCY PLANNING. HOWEVER
DUE TO A LACK OF COORDINATED
PLANNING IN SOME AREAS. THE
STATE'S CURRENT MECHANISM FOR
FUNDING ADAPTATION PROJECTS
PROJECTS HAS BEEN PRIMARILY
PIECEMEAL. WITH NO
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
COORDINATING ITS INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
RESILIENCY RETURN AB EIGHT
NINETY SEVEN SIX TO FILL TIS
GAP BY ENCOURAGING AND
SUPPORTING IT REGIONAL CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PLANNING THAT BUILDS
UPON AND ENHANCES. LOCAL
ADAPTATION ACTIONS TO REDUCE
CLIMATE RISK AND TO FOSTERING
COLLABORATION AMONG LOCAL
REGIONAL STATE ENTITIES ON
ADAPTATION SOLUTIONS AND
FINALLY DEVELOPING GUIDANCE FOR
POTENTIAL STATE FEDERAL OR
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN FUNDING
REGIONAL PRIORITY ADAPTATION
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE.
FINALLY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT SINCE THE INTRODUCTION OR
ACTUALLY THE REINTRODUCTION OF
THIS BILL SEVERAL MEMBERS OF
THIS BODY HAVE PARTNERED WITH
ME AS JOINT AUTHORS PROVIDED
INTEGRAL INPUT. THAT IS EVOLVED
THIS BILL INTO EVEN BETTER
POLICY I DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BENNETT CORK IN
WORD FOR YOU AND YOUR STAFF
CONTRIBUTIONS AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MR MILLER MISTER WERE YOU
ARE ON MY THANK KNOW SPEAKER OF
THE BUT I AS THE ON SUPPORT AB
EIGHT NINETY. NOW IS THE TIME
FOR THE STATE HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ADDRESS KERR INFO
IF OF CLIMATE BY THESE REGIONAL
CHANGE NETWORKS. THESE NETWORKS
WOULD SUPPORT LOCAL EFFORTS TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE CHANGES
THE COMMUNITIES FOR PLANNING
AND COLLABORATING WITH OTHER
REGIONAL CLIMATE NETWORKS LOCAL
DECISION MAKING AND
FACILITATING FUNDING AND
PROJECT IMPLEMENTATION TO REACH
REGIONAL GOALS AB NINETY SEVEN
WOULD PROVIDE A MECHANISM. FOR
THE STATE TO PROVIDE
EFFICIENCIES IN THE KANEMI THIS.
FOR THE REVIEW REASONS TO
ADDRESS CHANGE I RESPECT ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
WARDEN BENNETT YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. SPEAKER I RISE IN
THE US. OF THIS ALSO WAS A JOY
AUTHORS. AND APPRECIATE THE
COLLAB. BY WITH- THAT RESOURCES
COULD THAT- PULLED US TOGETHER
AND- MISTER MULLINS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS YOU VERY MUCH. THEY YOU
MISTER BENNETT IN HERE NO FOR
DEBATE I THE MATTER WITH MIND.
YOU MAKE US. THANK MADAM
SPEAKER. AND THANK YOU AGAIN MY
COLLAR ASK FOR I'VE A- HER WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED A-
HOME MEMBERS VOTED A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE. CLEAR
WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND THAT I
SEE. TWO TO THAT MEASURE PASS
WE WILL TAKE A MESSAGE SPEAKER
PRO TEM. THIRD AND FINAL I AT
THIS WE WILL NOW TO FIRE ITEM
ONE NO AB A THIRTY SO THIRTY
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY ROLE THIRTY
BY US WHEN WE WERE MULLIN AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECT. MISTER MIND
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
AGAIN MATTER MA'AM FINAL AB A
THIRTY SIX TO EXPAND
OPPORTUNITY FOR AUTUMN VOTE
REGISTRATION CAL. IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN K. WAS THE STATE IN THE
S. WAS A MECHANISM FOR ALL.
VOTER THROUGH THE NEW MOTOR
VOTER ACT AUTHORED BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO MISS
CONSEILLERS. WHICH ENSURED THAT
ELIGIBLE INDIVIDUALS SEEKING
SERVICES THROUGH THE DMV. WILL
BE AUTOMATICALLY REGISTERED TO
VOTE UNLESS THEY OPTED OUT
PROGRAMS FOR AB ARE HERE
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE
NATION OF LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN VOTER REGISTRATION
RATES ACROSS THE BOARD. THIS
BILL SIMPLY ASSET THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE CONDUCT A
STUDY. ON EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION EFFORTS INCLUDING
AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION AS
WELL AS IDENTIFY OTHER STATE
AGENCIES THAT HAVE THE
CAPACITY. TO INCORPORATE
AUTOMATIC VOTER REGISTRATION
EFFORTS INTO THEIR EXISTING
OPERATIONS WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING NON CITIZENS FROM
MISTAKEN REGISTRATION AND DOING
THIS. AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
TAKES THE FIRST STEP IN
AUGMENTING AUTOMATIC VOTER
REGISTRATION CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MULLIN
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER DELAY
ON THE MATTER CLERK WILL THE
ROLE. ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO
THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THIRTY DESERVE. CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLE TELLING I'D FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS NOT THAT MEASURE.
MISTER MULLIN IS PREPARE TO
LIFT THE CALL ON- FILE ITEM
NINE AB TEN TWENTY THE THIRD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF IT. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY
THE VOTE I FIFTY FOUR KNOWS
ELEVEN THE URGENT I FIFTY
NATIONAL ON THE MEASURE THAT
MEASURE.
WE ARE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY TWO.
AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX THE
KERKORIAN. SOME WILL FOURTEEN
FOR SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
ACCORDING TO AIR POLLUTION MR
BERMAN YOU ARE UP AND MATTER.
THANK MADAM SPEAKER AND CO A.
B. THIRTEEN FOR SIX WILL
REQUIRES IMAGE. FROM NOOSA OFF
ROAD ENGINES SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
ON OR AFTER TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
SMALL OFF ROAD ENGINES ARE
ENGINES UNDER TWENTY FIVE
HORSEPOWER THEY ARE MAINLY
USED. IN LAWN AND GARDEN
EQUIPMENT SUCH AS THE FLOORS
AND LAWN MOWERS AND OTHER
OUTDOOR POWER EQUIPMENT.
OPERATING A COMMERCIAL LEAF
BLOWER FOR ONE HOUR IMAGE
POLLUTION COMPARABLE TO DRIVING
A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TOYOTA
CAMRY ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
MILES FROM SACRAMENTO. TO
DENVER. DAILY EMISSIONS OF AIR
POLLUTANTS FROM SMALL ENGINES
ARE PROJECTED TO SURPASS THOSE
FROM PASSENGER CARS THIS YEAR.
THESE EMISSIONS WORSEN AIR
QUALITY AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT
HUMAN HEALTH CAUSING ASTHMA AND
LUNG DISEASE AND OTHER AWFUL
HEALTH IMPACTS ON LANDSCAPING
PROFESSIONALS ARE BREATHING.
EXHAUST DAY IN AND DAY OUT. THE
GOOD NEWS IS THERE IS EMISSION.
OF A FOR ALL OF THE EQUIPMENT
IN THE SMALL ENGINE CATEGORY.
THAT WOULD FALL UNDER THIS
BILL. I WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
TWO IMPORTANT POINTS. FIRST
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO A
QUITMAN PURCHASE PRIOR TO
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. IT IS NOT A
RESTRICTION ON USE ONLY NEW
SALES. SECOND FARM AND
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT ARE
PREEMPTED. UNDER THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT AND ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO THIS BILL. ABOUT
HALF OF HOUSEHOLDS HAVE ALREADY
SWITCHED TO ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT. BUT IT WILL TAKE
MORE TO TRANSITION COMMERCIAL
USERS TO ZERO EMISSIONS. TO
THAT END AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
REQUIRES THAT FUNDING BE MADE
AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS TO OFFER COMMERCIAL
REBATES. TO HELP LANDSCAPERS
PURCHASE ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT. SEVERAL AIR
DISTRICTS LIKE SOUTH COAST AND
VALLEY AIR ALREADY OFFER
COMMERCIAL REBATE PROGRAMS. AND
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THE CITY OF
SOUTH PASADENA HAVE ALREADY
TRANSITIONED. TO FULLY ZERO
EMISSION LANDSCAPING. ZERO
MISSION AGREEMENT IS QUIET
WHICH ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
WILL APPRECIATE. AND IT DOESN'T
EMIT OZONE FORMING POLLUTANTS
ABOUT HARM THE PERSON USING THE
EQUIPMENT. AND CONTRIBUTE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX. THANK YOU
MR BROWN MISS GONZALEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I- RISE AS A PROUD JOIN
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR BECAUSE THIS
IS IMPORTANT THAT NOBODY
MISSED- WHAT THE WHAT THE
AUTHOR STATED IN THAT IS IT IS
DEPENDENT. ON THERE BEING
REBATES AVAILABLE. IN THOSE
REBATES HAVE TO BE AVAILABLE TO
IT ANY- SMALL. AS BUSINESS
OWNER REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS SO I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT FEATURE
THIS IS A WAY TO HELP BOTH
WORKERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT IN
A WAY TO CLEAN UP WHAT WE ALL
KNOW IS A NEW SENSE AND
ACTUALLY IS A- CAUSING GREASE
CUT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SO
I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ITS HARD WORK ON THIS. AND THAT
PROVISION THAT ENSURES. IT WILL
NOT HURT WORKERS. THANK YOU
MISCONDUCT. SEEING AND HEARING
NO DEBATE THE MATTER BERMAN
WOULD YOU EXPOSE. I DO WANNA
THANK MIKE FROM C. DIEGO FOR
HER LEADERS. IN THE CO LEADER
ON THIS ISSUE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK AN AYE VOTE THANKS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. HOME VOTED DESERVE A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE OUT OF. SQUARES
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTED ARE
TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWELVE THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE WILL NOW MOVE
BACK IN FILE ORDER TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY NINE AB TWO TWENTY FOUR
THE KERKORIAN. TWENTY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DALY AN ACT IN
THE PROFESSIONS OF LOCATION TO
KIND THERE'S THE REST. IT'S
DAILY RECORD. THANK YOU MAY
SPEAKER AND MEMBER THIS MODERN
OUR STATE DEATH OF HOUSE GOOD
MOTOR CARRIER. TO REFLECT THE
DIFFERENT SERVICES PROVIDED BY
MOVING COMPANIES THE BILL
SUPPORTED BY THE TEAMSTERS AND
BY THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER DALY SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THERE ARE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED. IT. OF THE WHO DESERVE
IT. WHERE WELL FLOWS THE ROLE
IN TELLING THAT I FIVE NEWS
HERE THE MEASURE. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO ITEM ONE TWENTY. A FIVE
SEVEN OKAY SEVENTY FIVE.
KERKORIAN. SOME REAL SEVEN FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALWAYS OTHER
AND TO EDUCATION FINANCE
PROVIDING FUNDS AND THERE
FOURTH ONE ELECTIONS THE
INSURED ISSUE ANSWER OF BONDS
OF THE SILICON AND HANDLING OF
THE OF THOSE PHONE IN THE PLAN
USE EITHER THICK FOR MERELY
MISTER DONNA YOU ARE OPEN ON
THE MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS A SEVEN
FIVE A KID THROUGH COMMUNITY
SCHOOL FOR BOND ON THE TWENTY
TWO TO ABOUT. THE SCHOOL FOR
PROGRAM IS A HIGH SIX PRO THAT
IS BY ON A- BETWEEN SO SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND ABOUT. STATE
BONBON HAVE BEEN MAD BY
BUILDING OF DOLLARS AND LOCAL
FUND AND OF FEES TO AND BUILD
YOUR SCHOOL ACROSS OF. TO
GATHER THESE FUNDS OF BUILT
SCHOOLS MODERN AGING FACILITY
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S- AND UP.
AND SUPPORT. VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM. THESE FUNDS
ALSO HELP YOUR- BY GENERATE
TENS OF JOBS AND KEEPING HER
PRICES LOWER. THE FUN FROM LAST
BONTA BY THE PROPOSITION FIFTY
ONE FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE ALL
TO. THIS BOND WILL PROVIDE FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION MODERNIZATION
C. AND CHARTER SCHOOLS. IT WILL
ALSO PROVIDE FUNDS TO ADDRESS
MORE RECENT NEEDS INCLUDING
DISASTER ASSISTANCE. TESTING
AND REMEDIATION OF LEAD IN
WATER TECHNOLOGY REQUIRED TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INTERNET AND- SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICT ASSISTANCE. AS YOU ALL
PROBABLY KNOW THE LAST ONE WE
PLACED ON THE BALLOT
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN DID NOT
WAS NOT APPROVED BY THE VOTERS.
THIS BOND BILL IS NOT AT ALL
IDENTICAL THE PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. I BELIEVE WE NEED TO
MODIFY THE PROPOSAL TO GET
VOTER SUPPORT AND HAVE DONE
SUCH IN THIS BILL I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
O'DONNELL'S SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERITIV THE- ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED VERY VOTE. WHERE WILL THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE ICE
FIFTY EIGHT NEWS HERE ON
URGENCY EYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASS. I WAS REMISS IN NOT
MENTIONING THAT AB TWO TWENTY
FOUR. THE VOTE WITH SIXTY FIVE
ZERO ANY URGING AND THE VOTE
WAS SIXTY FIVE ZERO. ON THE
MEASURE THAT MEASURE PASSED. WE
WILL MOVE BACK IN FILE ORDER TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR AB TWENTY
TWO THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLY WERE MCCARTY AND
OTHERS ARE NOT GOING IS
HEALTHCARE MCCARTY WERE OPEN ON
THE- THANK YOU MADAM. I HERE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO THIS IS
THAT WE SAY THIS A LOT BUT I
CAN TRULY SAY THIS IS A
TRANSFORMATIONAL BILL THAT WILL
CHANGE LIVES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
KIDS. AND FAMILIES BY PROVIDING
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN THIS
HAS BEEN A TWENTY FIVE YEAR-
QUEST FOR MANY PEOPLE IN THE
STATE I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY
RECOGNIZE. THE LAWMAKERS THAT
INTRODUCED THIS BILL BEFORE TO
HELP GET THIS THIS POINT. THEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS DILLANE EASTON
DEBRA R. TEASE FORMER SENATORS
JOSEPH MEDIAN DARRELL STEINBERG
AND RECENTLY OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE SENATE CENTERS DODD AND
GONZALEZ. PUSH THIS ISSUE
FORWARD THIS HAS BEEN AN
ELUSIVE GOAL BUT HERE WE ARE
TODAY. COUPLED WITH THE ACTIONS
IN THE BUDGET THIS AGAIN WILL
CHANGE LIVES FOR KIDS FAMILIES
AND OUR STATEOF CALIFORNIA. WE
KNOW FOR OUR KIDS EARLY
EDUCATION MATTERS ALL THE BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT SAYS OVER AND OVER
IF THERE'S ONE THING THAT YOU
COULD DO TO CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE KIDS SUCCESS
IN LIFE. PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
EARLY EDUCATION. KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA ALREADY CAN GO TO T.
K. IF YOU'RE BORN IN THE FALL
SO WE HAVE AN INEQUITY WHICH MY
COLLEAGUE IN SAN FRANCISCO ARE
BUDGET YOU'RE ALWAYS POINTED
OUT. 25% THE KIDS HAD
SUBSIDIZED PRE K. AND THE OTHER
KIDS DID NOT SO WORKING
FAMILIES AND SO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITES. CAN'T AFFORD THE
THOUSAND OR TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH FOR EARLY
EDUCATION IT. COSTS MORE TO GO
TO. TAKE PRE KAYPRO PRIVATE
PROGRAMS THE UNIVERSE OF. AT
BERKELEY. AND WE THAT TOO MANY
OF OUR FOR. WHO CALL. FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM ARE LIVING IN
POVERTY SO IF YOU'RE A MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILY. YOU ARE TOO POOR.
TO PAY FOR PRE K. YOURSELF BUT
YOU'RE TOO RICH TO GET THE
SUBSIDIZED PROGRAM SO THAT
HURTS FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THIS WILL BE A BOON
FOR WORKING CLASS FAMILIES BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW IF WE WANT
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES LIKE. ARE
STUBBORN ACHIEVEMENT GAP WHICH
IS REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY GAP
TOO MANY KIDS START
KINDERGARTEN BEHIND AND THEY
STAY BEHIND IF YOU WANT TO DO
THE DRESS THAT WHAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE REMEDY FUND EARLY
EDUCATION. YOU WANT TO ADDRESS
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY
MAKING SURE THAT OUR YOUNG KIDS
HAVE A CHANCE FOR ECONOMIC
SUCCESS HIGH QUALITY EARLY
EDUCATION IS THE REMEDY YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE ISSUES RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT. YOU WANT TO KEEP THE KID
OUT OF THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THE ONE THING THAT YOU
CAN DO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE A
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION. SO
RIGHT NOW WE SPEND. ALMOST A
BILLION DOLLARS TO FIND FOUR
YEAR OLDS TO GO TO STATE
PRESCHOOL AND NOW THOSE FOUR
YEAR OLDS WHO LIVE IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES CAN GO TO
FOR STATE PRESCHOOL AS A THREE
YEAR OLD. AND THEN GET A YEAR
OF TEEKAY AS A FOUR YEAR OLD SO
TWO YEARS OF HIGH QUALITY EARLY
YET. AGAIN WE'LL TELL TRAINS
LIVES. AND LASTLY I DID WANT TO
NOTE THERE ARE MANY PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHO ARE
NERVOUS ABOUT THIS. BECAUSE
LET'S FACE IT CHANGE IS HARD.
BUT REST ASSURED. THIS COUPLE
WHETHER BUDGET ACTIONS WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE. THAT NO ONE
IS LEFT BEHIND OUR PROVIDERS
AND OUR CENTER BASED PROGRAMS
THAT DOING BEEN DOING THE WORK.
FOR DECADES WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE WE LIFT YOU UP. AND YOU
CAN SERVE MORE INFANTS AND
TODDLERS AND THREE YEAR OLDS.
AND FRANKLY WE'RE GONNA NEED
MORE EDUCATORS ANYWAY IN EARLY
EDUCATION BASED UPON THIS
TICKET EXPANSION. AND THAT
SUBSEQUENT BUDGET ACTIONS SO
WITH THAT I WANT TO THANK THE
TWENTY FIVE PLUS JOINT AUTHORS
ON THIS FLOOR. WHO STOOD BEHIND
AB TWENTY TWO. AND ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY ON THIS MONUMENTAL
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY NETWORKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN MEMBERS I RISE AS A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BILL
TODAY- BUT ALSO AS A MOM A MOM
OF A FOUR YEAR OLD AND A MOM OF
A TEN MONTH OLD. THE CUTEST
CHILDREN YOU'VE EVER SEEN OUR
BUT I'M BIASED. AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO SAID
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT THIS IS ONE
OF THE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY TRULY ADDRESS THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP. GIVING ACCESS
TO ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS TO FULL
DAY TKA. IN THE STATE MY
DAUGHTER. I HAPPEN TO BE BORN
IN NOVEMBER SO SHE'S STARTING
TO QUE IN AUGUST AND OAKLAND
UNIFIED PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SO SHE'S ONE OF THE 25% THAT
ACTUALLY IS ABLE TO GO THERE
BUT EITHER 70% THE KIDS. DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO GO THERE.
AND THEY ARE PAYING. UPWARDS OF
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A FOR FREE.
IF THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR. CARE
CHILD CARE RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA IS AS MY COLLEAGUE
SAID- MORE EXPENSIVE AND
SENDING MY CHILD TO UNIVERSITY
AND I'M- I GOT IT I'M PAYING IT
FOR TWO KIDS AT THE MOMENT. FOR
THOSE PARENTS THAT ARE OUT HERE
I KNOW YOU ALL ARE DOING THE
SAME EXACT THING RIGHT NOW. SO
THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO SEND
THEIR CHILDREN TO A QUALITY.
FULL DAY T. K. PROGRAM IS
CRITICAL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I THINK TRULY.
WILL GIVE US THE ABILITY TO
REALLY FUNDAMENTALLY ADDRESS.
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE HOWEVER
SOME OF THE CONCERNS BY THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD CARE PROVIDERS
THAT I HAVE HEARD FROM I'VE
HEARD FROM THE E. C. COMMUNITY.
NOT ONLY FOR MY DISTURBANCE
FROM ACROSS THE STATE. IN TERMS
OF THEIR CONCERNS. ARE EASY
PROVIDERS. HAVE JUST GONE
THROUGH A PRETTY DRAMATIC
EXPERIENCE OVER THE PAST YEAR
MANY OF THESE. SCHOOLS HAVE
CLOSED BECAUSE OF COVERED. AND
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE THAT AND
WORK WITH THEM. AND ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE THE RESEARCH
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND PART OF THAT. IS
GOING TO BE. THE FULL EASY
BUDGET A BILL PACKAGE THAT WILL
MAKE HIS HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
INTO OUR EASY COMMUNITY.
SEPARATELY FROM THE T. K.
PROGRAM. WHICH INCLUDES
INCREASING OUR REIMBURSEMENT
RATES INCREASING AMOUNT OF
SLOTS THAT WE HAVE FOR OUR
CHILDREN. GIVING OUR PROVIDERS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO SERVE OUR
YOUNGER KIDS. AND MAKING SURE
WE HAVE WRAPAROUND SERVICES FOR
FULL DAY CARE FOR T. K. AND
ALSO INVESTING IN OUR- OUR
EARLY EDUCATION OUR OUR OUR
EARLY EDUCATOR PIPELINE TO
ENSURE WE HAVE THE WORK FORCE
TO BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE ALL OF
THIS. AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT-
ARE FULL BUDGET WILL DO I AM
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH ARE YOU SEE COMMUNITY- I'M
EXCITED ABOUT THE T. K. BILL
AND I WILL BE AN ALLY OF THE U.
C. COMMUNITY. WORKING WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO AND
MANY OTHERS HERE TO ENSURE
THAT. ALL OF OUR KIDS KIDS NO
MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE NO MATTER
WHAT COLOR SKIN YOU HAVE HAVE
THE ACCESS TO GOOD QUALITY.
FREE PUBLIC EDUCATION THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
S. WICKS MISSED YOU AND YOU ARE.
RECOGNIZED THANK. THANK YOU
SPEAKER I TO AS A PER COOPER IN
SUPPORT OF A TWENTY TWO I WANT
THE AUTHOR HIS WORK ON THE
SIMPLE BILL HIS PASSION DATA
YEAR AFTER YEAR I'VE BEEN PROUD
TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO JOIN HIM
THIS YEAR BUT NOT ONLY THAT BUT
ALSO WHEN I WAS IN MY SEAT IN
THE SENATE AS WELL. AS A FULL
TIME WORKING MOTHER OF TWO
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL BOYS I
UNDERSTAND IMPORTANCE PROVIDE
TKA EDUCATION TO WORKING
FAMILIES MY BOYS BENEFIT FROM.
PRE K. AFTER WATCHING MY BOYS
GO THROUGH PRE K. I HAVE
DEFINITELY BECOME A HUGE
SUPPORTER AND AN ADVOCATE FOR
ALL CHILDREN. TO BE ABLE TO
ATTEND PRE K. TKA HAS BEEN
PROVEN TO GIVE OUR CHILDREN A
SIGNIFICANT BOOST IN READING
AND MATH SKILLS PARTICULARLY
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND
ESPECIALLY DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS. IN 200-015-2000
SIXTEEN SCHOOL YEAR ONLY 33%
UNDER ONLY 33% OF CHILDREN
UNDER FIVE WHO QUALIFY FOR ONE
OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLICLY
FUNDED. EASY PROGRAMS WERE
SERVE. ONLY THIRTY THREE
PERCENT. HOW T. K. PROGRAMS OR
EXPERIENCE INSIGNIFICANT.
INSUFFICIENT FUNDING AND A LACK
OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ALL OF
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE MORE
PERSONALIZED ATTENTION IN THE
CLASSROOM AND THIS BILL IS THE
ANSWER TO MORE CHILDREN BEING
SERVED. AB TWENTY TWO PROVIDES
PARENTS WITH A FREE HIGH
QUALITY PRE K. OPTION WHY
MAINTAINING PARENT CHOICE AS
FAMILIES CAN CHOOSE THE CHILD
CARE PROGRAM THAT BEST MEETS
THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS. CAN PARENTS
COULD CHOOSE FROM C. S. P. P.
WHICH IS CALLED FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS HEAD START
PRIVATE PRESCHOOL GENERAL CHILD
CARE OR ANY OTHER PROGRAM THAT
WORKS BEST FOR THEIR FAMILY.
MEMBERS I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THE WORKING FAMILIES
AND SINGLE PARENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY HELP ALL CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATTHEW AND MY FELLOW THERE IF
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MOUNTAINS. AND I. ALSO TO AS
PROUD OFF OF AB TWENTY TWO- I
STARTED MY NONPROFIT CAREER
WELL OVER A DECADE AGO AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL I WELL THIS IS- TKA
THIS REALLY IS A REALLY PROUD
MOMENT FOR ME. AND ADVOCATING
FOR ALL FOUR YEAR OLDS TO HAVE
ACCESS. I'M ALSO AS A WORKING
MOTHER OF A FOUR YEAR OLD I SEE
EVERY DAY HOW MUCH SHE HAS
GROWN HOW MUCH SHE HAS LEARNED.
BECAUSE SHE HAS ACCESS TO
PRESCHOOL BECAUSE SHE'S HAD
ACCESS TO A QUALITY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. WHAT MANY
OF YOU MAY NOT KNOW IS BEFORE I
CAME TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY I
WAS A PRESCHOOL PROVIDER AND
CHILD CARE PROVIDER. MY MOM
OPENED A PRESCHOOL. AND BECAUSE
SHE WANTED TO GAVE THE
UNDERSERVED. KIDS IN OUR
COMMUNITY ACCESS TO A QUALITY
LEARNING EXPERIENCE A FAITH
BASED EXPERIENCE AS WELL.
REALLY BECAUSE IT PROVIDES A
SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL FOUNDATION
THAT KIDS NEED NOT JUST TO BE
SUCCESSFUL THROUGHOUT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL YEARS BUT REALLY
THE FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENTS THAT
ARE SO IMPORTANT THROUGHOUT
LIFE. MOM PASSED AWAY IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FROM
PANCREATIC CANCER. AND I THEN
TOOK OVER HER ROLE AS CEO OF
THAT NONPROFIT PRESCHOOL SO
FROM A MOTHER'S PERSPECTIVE
FROM A LONG TIME ADVOCATE FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. AND
THEN TO A PRESCHOOL PROVIDER
WHO SAW EVERY SINGLE DAY HOW
ACCESS TO THOSE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL SKILLS ARE SO VITAL
TO OUR AN UNDERPRIVILEGED. TO
THE STUDENTS WHO WE WOULD TAKE
ON THAT WERE IN FOSTER CARE
THAT WERE HOMELESS THAT HAD-
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND TRAUMA
HAPPENING IN THEIR LIFE AT
HOME. THESE EXPERIENCES GIVE
THEM THE SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
BALANCE THAT THEY NEED IN THEIR
LIFE IT HAS BEEN AN HONOR TO
SEE THAT AND TO SEE. THAT WE'RE
EXPANDING THAT. FOR ALL FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND LASTLY WE DON'T
DO ENOUGH WHAT I'M SO EXCITED
ABOUT IN THIS EXPANSION OF T.
K. IS THAT WE DON'T DO ENOUGH
FOR THE MIDDLE CLASS. WE TALK
ABOUT THE MIDDLE CLASS ALL THE
TIME BUT SO MANY FAMILIES SO
MANY MIDDLE CLASS WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES MAKE TOO MUCH MONEY TO
AFFORD SUBSIDIZED PRESCHOOL
CHILD CARE. BUT DON'T MAKE IT
MONEY TO TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND GIVE THOSE TO THEIR
CHILDREN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
EARLY LEARNING EXPERIENCE THIS
IS WHAT THAT BILL DOES I'M
EXCITED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITHOUT ESTAS WALDRON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO
RISE AS A PROUD JOIN AUTHOR OF
THIS MEASURE AND I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO. FOR LEADING THIS
EFFORT THROUGH MANY YEARS- OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT IT WE ALL KNOW
THAT TRADITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
GIVES CALIFORNIANS. OPPORTUNITY
TO ENSURE OUR STATE'S YOUNGEST
STUDENTS ARE BETTER PREPARED TO
SUCCEED BOTH IN THEIR FUTURE
SCHOOLING AS WELL AS IN LIFE.
AND A STUDY IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FOUND THAT TRADITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN GAVE OUR YOUNGEST
STUDENTS AT SIGNIFICANT
LEARNING ADVANTAGE. BUT WE KNOW
THAT ONLY 31% OF LOW INCOME
FOUR YEAR OLDS- ARE NOT 31% OF
LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLDS ARE
NOT SERVED IN ANY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION PROGRAM.
AND IT AS WAS STATED ONLY 33%
OF CHILDREN UNDER FIVE WHO
QUALIFY FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION ARE ACTUALLY SIR WE
CAN DO A BETTER JOB FOR EQUITY
AND ACCESS- FOR EDUCATION FOR
OUR CHILDREN I URGE AND I VOTE
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YO MISS WALDRON SEEING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MR MCCARTY MAKE CLOSE. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS THAT
MEASURE THAT'S CLOSE TO MY
HEART I'VE INTRODUCED THIS FIVE
TIMES. YOU KNOW I'VE ALWAYS
SAID THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
LOBBYIST AROUND THE HALLS
WORKING ON THESE ISSUES. YOU
KNOW DOESN'T HAVE A LOBBYIST
FOUR YEAR OLDS IN CALIFORNIA
LITTLE TODDLERS LITTLE KIDS SO
ON BEHALF OF FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND. YOUNG KIDS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A MONUMENTAL
VOTE WE'RE ABOUT TO TAKE AND
WITH THAT I ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU. CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. OF A- ALL MEMBERS LED
DESERVE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE BETTER. CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THERE I
SIXTY THREE NOTES HERE THE
MEASURE PASSES WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN AND FILE ITEMS EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN MILLION FILE
ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT AB THREE
FORTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
SOME PEOPLE FOR YOU SO BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND OTHER ARE
NOT GOING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE AFTER. YOU ARE. THANK
MADAM SPEAKER IN MY- TODAY I
RISE TO PER. AB THREE FOUR SO.
REGARDING YOU TO. MAN REFORM.
THIS BILL AIMS TO STRIKE A
BALANCE BETWEEN ALLOWING
PLAYERS TO CONTINUE TO UTILIZE
STEP THERAPY. AND PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION WHILE
ESTABLISHING GUARDRAILS TO
PROTECT PATIENTS. IT DOES NOT
PROHIBIT PRIOR AUTHORIZATION.
OR STEP THERAPY PROTOCOLS.
RATHER IT ESTABLISHES A
STANDARD TRANSPARENT PROCESS.
CURRENTLY MORE THAN TWENTY
STATES HAVE IMPLEMENTED
STANDARD EXCEPTIONS TO STEP
THERAPY. THANK YOU MEMBERS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DR EMBARRASSING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE WHERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IT. I
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW YOU
VOTE I FIFTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE WILL PASS AND RETAIN A
VIOLENT NINE ITEM NINETY AB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE READ SOME
BILL THREE SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEDINA AND OTHER NOT
TO IN COLLEGES. MISREADING YOU
ARE A- THANK YOU MATTER SPEAKER
IN MA'AM AB THREE FIVE WOULD
CHANGE THE PERCENTAGE OF HOURS
A PART TIME TEMPORARY EMPLOYEE
MAY TEACH IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES UP 285% OF THE HOURS
PER WEEK A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE
HAVING COMPARABLE DUTIES. UNDER
THE 67% THRESHOLD MANY FACULTY
MEMBERS TO TEACH AND MULTIPLE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AT THE SAME TIME TO
PIECE TOGETHER A FULL TIME
SCHEDULE THESE ARE OUR SO
CALLED FREEWAY FLYERS IT LIMITS
THEIR ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE CAMPUS COMMUNITY AND BE A
RESOURCE TO STUDENTS. THIS BILL
WILL HELP IMPROVE STUDENT
SUCCESS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL WELL ADDRESSING
ONE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
HARDSHIPS FACED BY PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBERS AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU MR MEDINA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
VERY. HOME SAID VERY. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLIED ICE
EIGHT NEW ZERO MEASURE PASS NOW
WILL NOTIFY ITEM MAY ONE A FOUR
SO CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
FOR SIX BY ASSEMBLY KALRA AND
OTHER IMMACULATE THE PUBLIC EYE.
HOW ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THE. THANK THANK YOU A MESS
BECAUSE MEMBERS. TROPICAL AND
FOR ARE AMONG THE MOST DE FOR A
ON EARTH. AND THE PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN STORING. PROVIDING HAVE
FOR AND PLANT SPECIES. THE
DESTRUCTION AND THE GOOD OF
THESE US TO. SCALE A- OR- FOR
US TO. PORTION OF GLOBAL GAS
EMISSIONS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
CALL CHANGE AS WELL AS WIDER
AND ABOUT. AND HUMAN RIGHTS
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARD TO
PROTECT INDIGENOUS WAS JEWISH.
AND GOVERNANCE OF THESE LANDS.
IT FOUR SIXTY IN THE DEFORESTED
FREE PROCUREMENT AT. REQUIRE
ANY ENTITY CLIENT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO CERTIFY
THAT THEY'RE NOT CONTRIBUTING
TO TROPICAL OR BOREEL FOREST
LOSS DIRECTLY OR THROUGH THEIR
SUPPLY CHAINS. AB FOUR SIXTEEN
IS MODELED AFTER AN EXISTING
SWEAT FREE POLITICAL FOR STATE
CONTRACTS A PROCUREMENT BAN
AGAINST CHILD LABOR. SO THIS
LEGISLATION IS NOT DISSIMILAR
TO PROCUREMENT POLICIES THE
STATE IS IMPLEMENTING IN PAST
YEARS TO HELP INSURE THE
CONTRACTORS WORKING OR NOT
GAUGING AND HARMFUL. ALSO IN
ORDER TO PROMOTE BEST PRACTICE
AB FOUR SIXTEEN REQUIRE. OR
DEPARTMENT GENERAL'S DEVELOP
DEFORESTATION FREEPORT OF
CONDUCT. TO PROVIDE GUARD TO
CONTRACTORS ORDER TO IDENTIFY
US RISK COMMODITIES. IN THEIR
SUPPLY CHAINS. AS A PRIVILEGE
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
CALIFORNIA'S PURCHASING POWER
HAS SIGNIFICANT MARKET FORCE
AND THIS BILL EXTENDS OUR
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP. TO THE PROTECT
PROTECTION OF TROPICAL AND
BOREAL FORESTS. BY ADOPTING
THIS PROCUREMENT POLICY WE'RE
INSURING THE STATE IS NOT
INTENDED. CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
SUCTION AND DRUG DEALERS TOP.
AND BOREAL FOR NUMBER SENDING A
CRUCIAL SIGNAL TO GLOBAL
MARKETS THE ELISE.
THUNDERSTRUCK QUEMADA DRIVEN
TO. AND PRIMARY FOREST. SHOULD
NOT BE TOLERATED. BY ADDRESSING
THESE ISSUES TO SUPPLY CHAIN
ACCOUNTABILITY WE CAN ACTUALLY
HELP THE DRIVER BETTER
PRACTICES LONG TERM. AS PART OF
THIS DAY BROUGHT. TO LEADERSHIP
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE. AB FOUR SIXTEEN ENJOYS
BROAD SUPPORT FROM INDIGENOUS
LEADERS ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
EXPERTS WILDLIFE ADVOCATES AND
COMMERCIAL BUSINESSES THAT
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES
WITHOUT RESPECTING US. RELIABLE
THANK YOU MAY KALRA SEEING AND
HEARING FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
MATTER CLERK WILL THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF THEIR A- HOME VOTE
DESIRED. AT THE TIME.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTED ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. BURKE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW IT ICE
FORTY THREE NO SIXTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM TWO
MOVING TO FILE A NINETY AB FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE A CIRCLE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTY BY
ASSUMING LUIS AND OTHERS
IMMACULATE IN THE CRIME WHICH.
THE SERVICE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THE MATTER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBER I READ
FOR AB FIVE EIGHTY. AND IMPORT
BILL THAT WILL COORDINATE STATE
F. TO HELP- URBAN AND RURAL
RURAL COMMUNITIES COMBAT
EXTREME HATE. AB FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE CREATES THE EXTREME HEAT
AND COMMUNITY REAL RESILIENCY
PROGRAM. UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH. THE PROGRAM
ESTABLISHES GUIDELINES FOR
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS AND
HELPS LOCAL ENTITIES
IMPLEMENTED MEASURES THAT
REDUCE EXTREME HEAT. AREAS THEY
EXPERIENCE EXTREME HEAT OFTEN
HAVE LARGE EXPANSES OF CONCRETE
LESS GREENERY HIGHER DENSITY
HOUSING LOWER AVERAGE INCOMES
AND POOR HEALTH STATUS. EXTREME
HEAT EVENTS ARE NOW YEAR ROUND
TEMPERATURES ARE RISING MORE
STEEPLY AND HEAT WAVES ARE
LASTING LONGER. THESE EVENTS
HAVE LED TO MORE POWER OUTAGES
COMPRISE COMPROMISED WATER
QUALITY. INCREASED POLLUTION
AND MORE INTENSE WILDFIRES.
JUST LAST SUMMER WE EXPERIENCED
ROLLING BLACKOUTS FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN TWENTY YEARS BECAUSE OF
AN EXTREME HEAT WAVE THESE
EVENTS WILL OCCUR MORE
FREQUENTLY AND WITH MORE FORCE.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS A GROWING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS- AB FIVE
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE WILL PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE TO OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND WILL
BRING EQUITY TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AND GIVE THEM A
FIGHTING CHANCE TO BEAT THE
HEAT. THANK YOU. THEY GIVE US
F. C. AND HEARING FURTHER TO ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK OPEN THEIR.
VERITABLE ALL MEMBERS SAID
DESERVED HOOK. THE CLERK WILL
THE IN TALLY THE VOTES I SEE
TWO NEW ONE THEM PASSED. I MEAN
IF I ITEM NINETY AB SIX TWENTY
FIVE WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
ACT THE CRIME DEFENSE FACT INTO
YOUR RIGHT AS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM ON MA'AM. TODAY IRA TO
PER AB SIX FIVE WOULD TO DIRECT
THE STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER TWO
HUNDRED TO STAY. TO UNDER WHAT
WE ARE NEEDED FOR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND INDIGENT DEFENSE
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE OF THE
CAR WILL OPEN ROLE. IN THIS
MODE IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL MY
OF THE DESERT IT. BURKE WILL
LOSE THE ROLE CALENDAR I FOUR
KNOWS THAT MIGHT PASSES.
PASSERIDAE ENVIRONMENT FIVE
UNIFIED ITEM NINETY EIGHTY SIX
THE COURT WILL READ ASSEMBLY
RULES EIGHTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I LIVING TO THE GREEN GAS
REDUCTION. BURKE YOU ARE THANK
YOU MANISTIQUE MEMBERS A JUNE
TWENTY REPORT BY THE CENTER FOR
COMMUNITIES FOR THE STRUCK OF
CLIMB INVESTING IS TO BUY THEM
APPLE COMMUNITY IN OUR- THIS
THIS HAS COME AT THE EXPENSE OF.
COMMUNITIES OF SICK LESS OP TO
ASK X. PROGRAMS AND INSIDE.
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING BY THE WAYSIDE AS OURS
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE AB SIX
EIGHTY HELP BRIDGE THE GAP BY
KEEP CALL RIGHT IN THE COW
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
RECENT REPORT PUTTING
CALIFORNIA ON THE HIGH ROAD A
JOB AND CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR
TWENTY THIRTY. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY REQUIRED GIGI R. F.
APPLICANTS TO USE FAIR AND
RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYEES TEN YEARS
PROMOTE HIGH QUALITY JOBS AND
SCREWS THEIR PROCUREMENT
POLICIES AND PREVAILING WAGE
FOR CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS THE
BILL IT FURTHER PRIORITIZE
APPLICANTS THAT PARTNER WITH
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS. THAT TARGET
RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TRIBAL AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES IN THE SAME
REGION AS THE PROJECT EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY WILL PUT PRINCIPLES
OF EQUITY ON THE FRONT END OF
THE APPLICATION PROCESS AND
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITIES ARE SUSTAINABLE
BECAUSE THEY ARE BUILT ON
CAREERS NOT JOBS. I
RESPECTFULLY. REQUESTED ABOUT.
THANK YOU BURKE SEEING AND
HEARING FURTHER ON THEM. CLERK
WILL THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. HOME
SAID TO THEIR. TO CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELLING THAT
ICE FORTY FIVE NEWS ELEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING THE FILE
ITEM. NINETY SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY SEVEN TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM IN
ACTIVATING THE REAL. THIS BLOOM
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK MADAM
SPEAKER MAY A SEVEN TWENTY WILL
IN. DENSITY RESTRICTIONS AND
PRIVATE COVENANTS THAT DO NOT
ALIGN WITH LOCAL ZONING. UNTIL
THE MID TWENTIETH CENTURY
RACIAL RESTRICTIONS IN HOUSING
COVENANTS WERE USED TO REDLINE
AND SEGREGATE NEIGHBORHOODS AS
WE ALL KNOW AND- THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS SINCE MADE
THESE RESTRICTIVE COVENANTS
UNENFORCEABLE HOWEVER. THESE
COVENANTS OFTEN CONTAIN OTHER
VESTIGES OF DISCRIMINATION SUCH
AS LIMITS ON THE NUMBER AND
SIZE OF UNITS THAT CAN BE
BUILT. IN SPITE OF WHATEVER THE
ZONING FOR AN AREA MIGHT BE.
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE WILL
INVALIDATE THESE RESTRICTIONS
AGAINST AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER IF THE COVENANTS
CONFLICTS WITH LOCAL ZONING.
UNDER THIS BILL PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS WHO NO LONGER REZONE
RESIDE ON THE PROPERTY CANNOT
USE COVENANTS TO CURTAIL MUCH
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING-DEVELOPMENT. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO REMOVE
UNNECESSARY VERY UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS IN OUR EFFORTS TO
TACKLE THE HOUSING CRISIS IT
COMES UP MORE OFTEN THAN YOU
MIGHT THINK WHEN A PORTABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS ARE LOOKING
TO PURCHASE A PIECE OF
PROPERTY. AND RATHER THAN GET
INTO LITIGATION THEY JUST PASS
ON THE OPPORTUNITY. SO THIS IS
AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO CREATE
MORE AFFORDABLE. HOUSING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THE YOU MISTER BLOOM IN HEARING
NO FOR DEBATE I THE MATTER OF
THE WILL- OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF THE- HOME MEMBERS TO
THEIR IT. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF
THE. YEAH.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND THAT ICE FORTY TWO NEWS
SIXTEEN THAT MEASURE K. THE
PAST THIRTEEN ON FIVE ITEM
<c.blue>IGHT WILL MOVE UP TO FILE ITEM</c>
NAY TWO AB FOR A THE CLERK READ.
SOME PEOPLE FOR EIGHTY S.
MEMBER AND OTHERS AND EVERYBODY
IN THE HOUSE OF THIS BUT.
MYSTERY ARE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO
DO A DIFFERENT BILL READY 2%
BUT HERE WE GO I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT A SYMBOL FOR EIGHTY A
MEASURE THAT WILL STRAIN LOCAL
AUTHORITIES AND TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION AGAINST LOCAL THREATS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
INCLUDING THE ABILITY FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT THE
FACILITY OR PORTION OF A
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS.
THAT COST AND EXPOSURE IN
CALIFORNIA MULTIPLE REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES HAVE JURISDICTION
OVER THE BUSINESSES THAT HANDLE
AND GENERATE HAZARDOUS WASTE
AND MATERIALS THAT POSE A RISK
TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND PUBLIC
SAFETY LOCALLY A CERTIFIED
UNIFIED PROGRAM AGENCY KNOWN AS
CUBA IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING AND ENFORCING
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND WASTE
LOSS IN THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER HAS GENERAL AUTHORITY
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH
AN EXPANDED THIRTY ONLY AFTER A
COUNTY WIDE EMERGENCY IS
DECLARED. CURRENTLY SOME
FACILITIES THAT EMIT HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCE CONTINUE TO OPERATE
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT MEET
REGULATORY REGULATORY MINIMUM
STANDARDS TO CEASE OPERATIONS.
IMMEDIATELY A PRIME EXAMPLE. OF
THIS IS THE ATROCITY IMPACTING
COMMUNITIES BEING THAT OF THE
EXIDE BATTERY RECYCLING
FACILITY IN VERNON CALIFORNIA
WHICH HAS IMPACTED. VARIOUS
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS UP THAT.
SERVE SERVICES COMMUNITY WHICH
CONTINUOUSLY HAS EXPOSED
FAMILIES AND RESIDENTS OF MY
DISTRICT AND SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOODS TO DANGEROUS
LEVELS OF TOXIC. TOXIC LEAD THE
DELAY TO SHUT THIS FACILITY
DOWN THE TO EMISSIONS FROM THE
PLANT CONTAMINATING MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND OF A RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES. ACROSS COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING BOYLE HEIGHTS EAST LA
IN SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES. AB
FOUR EIGHTY WILL ENABLE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT A
FACILITY OR A PORTION OF THE
FACILITY. TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS THAT
HAVE EXPOSED THEIR COMMUNITIES
TO HARMFUL TOXIC MATERIALS.
UNTIL THE ISSUE IS CORRECTED
FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS I
HAVE WORKED TO BRING GREATER
AUTHORITY TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. TO TAKE THE
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS AGAINST
THREATS TO OUR PUBLIC SOUTH. I
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT I HAVE
COMMITTED TO TAKING AMENDMENTS-
IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
REQUIRED PURPOSE TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF INVESTOR
RELATIONS WITH RESPECT TO THE
REPORTABLE AMOUNT AND STATING.
LEGISLATIVE INTENT WITH RESPECT
TO IMMINENT AND SUBSTANTIAL TO
ADDRESS REMAINING INDUSTRY
OPPOSITION WE HAVE WORKED VERY
HARD FOR THE LAST FEW YEARS. TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO THAT. NO
CITY OR NEIGHBORHOOD ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA EVER HAS TO
FACE ANOTHER SITUATION LIKE
EXCITED. AB FOUR EIGHTY IF THE
COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION
IMPACTING ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. AND ONE NEIGHBOR A
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO ACT IN THE
INTERESTS OF OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND BETTER PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES HEALTH AND SAFETY
WHILE COORDINATING WITH PROPER
PROPER AGENCIES AND I
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CARILLO.
DR QUIRKY ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- I SUPPORT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AB FOR EIGHTY
SUPPORT MEASURE TO STRENGTHEN
LOCAL AUTHORITY PROTECTING
PUBLIC HEALTH FROM HAVE
HAZARDOUS WASTE RELEASES. WHEN
WE HEARD THIS BILL IN ASTM
COMMITTEE WHICH I CHAIR. I URGE
THE OFFER TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS RAISED BY MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SINCE THEN
THE AUTHORS WORKED EARNESTLY
WITH THEIR SPONSORS LEGISLATIVE
COUNCIL AND OTHERS. TO FIND
WAYS TO AMEND THE BILL THIS
WAGE THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS.
THE AUTHOR IS PLANNING TO AMEND
THE BILL WITH LANGUAGE IN THE
SENATE TO EXPRESSLY CLARIFY THE
TERM EMITTED SUBSTANTIAL
ENDANGERMENT- WHICH IS
ESTABLISHED BY CASE LAW AND
REQUIRES THE LOCAL AUTHORITIES
TO HEAR TO ALL FEDERAL STATE
AND CASE LAWS. HI THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE VOTE AYE ON A.
B. FOUR EIGHT THANK YOU DR CORK
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MYSTERY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF THE VERY OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE THAT
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A BURKE
WILL CLOSE. CUOCO'S THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE IS FORTY THREE
KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YOUR MOTION. AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ITEM ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY
SEVEN CLARK TO THE INACTIVE
FILE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MOVING
THE FILE ITEM NINETY NINE AB
SEVEN NINETY FOUR THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE SEVEN
NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AND OTHERS IMMACULATELY
THEIR POLLUTION. IF CAREER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM SO
PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN NINE FOR THE CLIMATE JOBS
IN EQUITY ACT. A MEASURE THAT
WILL TRANSFORM CLEAN VEHICLE
INCENTIVES INTO A TRUE ENGINES
FOR ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
GROWTH OF HIGH QUALITY JOBS FOR
DISADVANTAGED WORKERS BY
ENSURING THAT PUBLIC FUNDING TO
PURCHASE CLEANER VEHICLES. IS
TIED TO LABOR STANDARDS CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE STRATEGIES IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE COVER NINETEEN.
DOWNTURN IN THE GOVERNOR'S. A
CLIMATE EXECUTIVE ORDER HAS
MADE THESE INVESTMENTS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT ECONOMIC EQUITY
AND CLIMATE TOOLS THE ABILITY
OF THE STATE TO MEET AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS DEPENDS IN THE
LARGE. DEPENDS IN LARGE IN THE
FLEET PURCHASERS TRANSITIONING
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES A
MAJOR OBSTACLE TO MEETING
CLIMATE GOALS IS A MIS
CLASSIFICATION OF PORT TRUCK
DRIVERS MISCLASSIFIED DRIVERS
CANNOT AFFORD NEW CLEAN OR
ELECTRIC TRUCKS WHEN THE BURDEN
OF THE COST FALLS ON THEM. AND
NOT THE TRUCKING COMPANY'S
WORKFORCE STANDARDS CAN BEGIN
TO SHIFT THIS BUSINESS MODEL IN
TRUCKING FOR EXTREME WORKER
EXPLOITATION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
NON COMPLIANCE TO HIGH ROAD
JOBS IN CLEAN VEHICLES THAT
DON'T POLLUTE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AS SUCH
AB SEVEN NINE FOUR CREATES A
PATHWAY TO ENSURE PUBLIC
INVESTMENT IN FLEETS BY TRYING
TO. BUY TIENE WORK FOR
STANDARDS TWO INCENTIVE DOLLARS
THIS IS A MODEL THAT CAN BE
USED TO CREATE HIGH QUALITY
JOBS IN CLEAN VEHICLE
MANUFACTURING AND SUPPORT. MADE
IN AMERICA POLICIES PREVIOUS
VERSIONS OF THIS BILL ATTACHED
WORKFORCE STANDARDS TO
INCENTIVIZE FOR VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS AND REQUIRE
DOMESTIC ASSEMBLY AND CONTENT.
OF ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES TO
SUPPORT BY BACK AMERICAN
POLICIES I WANT TO HELP BRING
BACK AND SUPPORT GOOD JOBS AND
DOMESTIC. CLEAN CAR
MANUFACTURING. BUT REQUIRES
WERE WITH PARTNERS IN THE- TO A
WAY FOR. AS A SHOW OF FAITH I
HAVE AMENDED OUT ALL LANGUAGE
RELATED TO LABOR AND MADE IN
AMERICA STANDARDS FOR
MANUFACTURERS OF CLEAN VEHICLE
SO THAT WE MAY CONTINUE. THE
CONVERSATION IN THE DISCUSSION
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE AUTO
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY TO SEE
IF WE CAN FIND A PATH THAT IS
WORKABLE AND MEETS BOTH
CLIMATE. AND JOB QUALITY GOALS
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS POSSIBLE
WE CAN'T DO BOTH. AT THIS
CRITICAL MOMENT OF TRANSITION
TO CLEAN A TO A CLEAN ECONOMY
CALIFORNIA CANNOT AFFORD TO
FAIL AND COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGIES TO ENSURE THAT
CLIMATE JOBS. ARE GOOD JOBS THE
GROW OUR ECONOMY AND BENEFIT
WORKERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS. ON THIS
MATTER MY DOOR IS ALWAYS OPEN
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THE YOU MISS CAREER
SINGING HEARING NO FURTHER. ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK OPEN THE
ROLE. OKAY THE ART OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW IT ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE
KNOWS FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS THROUGH A
PILOT. ONE FOR. AT FILE IN ONE
HAND NINETY ACTIVE FIVE LUNA I
LET ONE A ONE ABA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. WHICH
ALLOWS HEALTH CARE WORKERS
PROVIDING DIRECT PATIENT CARE
TO OVERRIDE A HOSPITAL
ALGORITHM. WHEN IT'S WITHIN
THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE. WHICH
INCLUDES PHYSICIAN APPROVAL.
AND ULTIMATELY IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT. WELL
I'LL THE RHYTHMS ARE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL USED TO HELP
DECIDE THE BEST COURSE OF
TREATMENT FOR MILLIONS OF
PATIENTS A YEAR. ALGORITHMIC
BIAS AND SPECIFICALLY RACIAL
BIAS IN THE HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY
A WELL DOCUMENTED. I HAVE HAD
MY OWN EXPERIENCE WITH THE
INTERVENTION OF A NURSE. SAVE
MY LIFE. WHEN I WAS DIAGNOSED
WITH DIABETES. I'M NO LONGER ON
INSULIN BECAUSE OF HER ADVICE
ON WHAT I NEEDED TO DO WITH MY
HEALTHCARE. UNDER THE
SUPERVISION OF A PHYSICIAN.
MAJOR HOSPITAL SYSTEM THE
SYSTEMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ALREADY RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. AND
CURRENTLY IMPLEMENT THE SAME
WORKER PROTECTIONS THROUGH
THEIR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS TECHNOLOGY IS MEANT
TO COMPLEMENT THE SKILLS I
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. NOT
REPLACE THEM. AND WE WHEN WE
ALLOW ALGORITHMS DOCTORS AND
NURSES TO WORK TOGETHER. WE
WILL SAVE LIVES. MEMBERS. ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY TWO
NEWS THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
A FILE ITEM ONE OH TWO WE HAVE
DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE OF
THREE MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE OH
FOUR EIGHTY NINE NINETY THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOMETHING ON
NINE NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AND OTHERS IMMACULATE
IN THE PRISONERS SANTIAGO YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER EIGHTY NINE NINETY
WOULD STRENGTHEN VISITATION
RIGHTS FOR FAMILY MEMBERS OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE BY
RESTORING VISITING AS A RIGHT
VISITATION RIGHTS. ARE OFTEN
TAKEN AWAY AS A FORM OF
PUNISHMENT THIS IS THE ONLY WAY
TO END UP THE END THE HARMING
OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE FAMILIES
AND ESPECIALLY YOUNG CHILDREN
HAVING A FAMILY CLOSE TO SEVEN
HELPS. TO IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH
BEHAVIOR REHABILITATION OF AN
INCARCERATED PERSON AND OUT OF
THEIR FAMILIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR KNIVES. THANK YOU
MISTER SANTIAGO'S. HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE A. FIRES. FORTY
ONE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE
TO VOTE. YEAH. WELL CLOSER
ROLAND HOWEVER EYES FORTY ONE
KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS AND RETAIN AND
VIOLATE ONE OF FIVE FILE ITEM
ONE IS SIXTY B. ELEVEN OH FIVE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
RULE LIVING- FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
RODRIGUEZ IMMACULATE IN THE
WORKFORCE WORKPLACE SAFETY. MR
RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TODAY PRESENT A. B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE THE PROTECTION
OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND THE
FAMILIES FROM COVER NINETEEN
THE HOSPITAL'S CRITICAL TO
BEATING THE PANDEMIC WHEN
YOU'RE INTO THIS PANDEMIC ARE
NURSES TO REPORT INADEQUATE
SCREENINGS OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND PATIENTS ADMITTED
TO HOSPITALS AND OTHER
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES INCLUDING
THAT NOT ALL PATIENTS ARE
TESTED BEFORE ARRIVAL AND THAT
IN SOME CASES PROCEDURES ARE
FORMED. OR PERFORMED WELL
PATIENT TEST RESULTS ARE STILL
PENDING A. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE
BUILT ON THE GUIDANCE PROVIDED
BY CDPH BY REQUIRING EMPLOYERS
TO PROVIDE PP TO HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEES DEVELOPER PROGRAM TO
OFFER WEEKLY TESTING PER PERSON
NOW REQUIRE EMPLOYERS TO TEST
PATIENTS FOR COVERT NINETEEN
PRIOR TO ADMISSION ARE STRICTLY
OUT FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THIRD OF THE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A. REQUIRES FORTY ONE.
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT ICE FORTY FOUR KNOWS EIGHT
THAT MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN
WE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM ONE
AWAIT MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
OH NINE AB ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME OF
BILL LEVIN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE IN THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS SANTIAGO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU
MAN'S SPEAKER AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ON ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN
BUT TO CREATE THAT A BANK CAL
PROGRAM WHICH WOULD ALLOW EVERY
CALIFORNIA HAVE A NO FEE NO
PENALTY ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
FINANCIAL SERVICES DEBIT CARDS-
AND DIRECT DEPOSITS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS BANK THOSE WHO
ARE UNBANKED OR UNDER BANKED BY
PROVIDING A SERVICE THAT IS
THAT IS OF NO FEE NO COST. EMI
VERY CLEAR ABOUT IT IN MANY
CASES FOLKS DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CASH A CHECK FOR
PRE OR HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY AT
THE SAME AT DOLLARS WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS CREATE THAT
PUBLIC PLATFORM THAT ALLOWS FOR
A LOCAL INDIVIDUALS
PARTICULARLY COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR TO BE ABLE TO DEPOSIT
DOLLARS INTO THIS NOW THERE ARE
SOME SAFEGUARDS THAT TE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
AND APPROPRIATIONS HAD HELPED
US TO TAKE NUMBER ONE THERE IS
A MARKET ANALYSIS- IF THE
MARKET ANALYSIS I DETERMINES.
HI THIS IS FEASIBLE WE COME
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE TO
REQUEST A THE ABILITY TO MOVE
FORWARD IF AND ONLY WHEN THAT
THAT HAPPENS AND I WANT TO
THANK THE BANKING AND FINANCE
CHAIR. OF THE ASSEMBLY FOR
THEIR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR HARD WORK IN HELPING US
TO ESTABLISH. A BANK AND A BANK
CAL PROGRAM IS THAT THIS WILL
THIS WILL BE A GAME CHANGER FOR
COMMUNITIES I LIKE THE ONE THAT
I REPRESENT WE HAVE NO ABILITY
IN MANY CASES ODD TO BANK AT NO
COST NO FEE SERVICES- I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK WHEN I'VE
AMEND YOUR- THANK YOU MISTER.
IS TO YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU
MANAGED I RISE AS A ON THIS
BILL ASKING FOR YEARS. THIS
BUILDS ON THIS LEDGE. WORK FROM
TWO YEARS AGO. TO ALLOW CITIES
TO PILOT ALTERNATIVES TO
TRADITIONAL BANKING- WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS BILL. ONE FOR
CALIFORNIANS ARE UNBANKED OR
UNDERBANKED WHICH MEANS THAT
THEY EITHER DON'T HAVE A BANK
ACCOUNT. OR USE COSTLY
FINANCIAL SERVICES LIKE CHECK
CASHIERS OR PAYDAY LENDERS. AND
AS THE AUTHOR STATED THIS BILL
WILL NOT CREATE A PUBLIC BANK
IT WILL CREATE A BOARD THAT
PARTNERS WITH EXISTING
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TO
PROVIDE FREE DEBIT CARD
ACCOUNTS. IT CALLS FOR MARKET
ANALYSIS AND ALSOREQUIRES THE
LEGISLATURE TO FOR THE RATIFY
THE RESULTS OF THAT ANALYSIS
AND WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOOK. THANK YOU MISTER
TO MISTER KALRA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
THANK OUR OUR COLLEAGUE. OFFER
LEADING ON THIS ISSUE FOR SO
MANY YEARS- I STAND AS A
PROBABLY JOIN AUTHOR OF AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN. THE
ISSUE. OF OUR WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF- BY DIFFERENT
VARIOUS SCHEMES AND SECTORS OF
THE FINANCIAL- IN IN THE
FINANCING INDUSTRY HAS ALWAYS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT I'VE FOUGHT
AGAINST. DURING MY ENTIRE
ELECTED CAREER- HOWEVER AS WE
DO THAT WE ALSO HAVE TO CREATE
PATHWAYS. TO FISCAL
OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL AND
FINANCIAL OPPORTUNITIES I THINK
THIS BILL- OF. DOES A LONG
WAITING CONTINUES OUR JOURNEY.
ALONG OF IT WOULD TO CREATE A
STATE. BANK AND ALL
OPPORTUNITIES REPUBLIC BANKS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE. TO CREATE
REAL ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
WITHOUT AYE RIDGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA CLEAR
WRECKED. CALLER I AM PLEASED TO
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE OF
MY CAREER FOLLOWING BANKING
ISSUES GOES BACK TO THE
SEVENTIES WHEN WE SAW HIGH
INFLATION BANKS WERE BY LAW
REQUIRED TO PAY A VERY LOW
INTEREST RATE. THIS LED TO
SOMETHING CALLED DISORDER
MEDIATION AS MONEY MARKET
INSTRUMENTS GOT CREATED AND
PEOPLE TOOK THE MONEY OUT OF
BANKS TO GO FOR HIGHER
INTEREST. THE BANKING SECTOR
HAS ALWAYS SEEN EVOLUTION. AND
WITH THE EVOLUTION THE ROLE OF
TECHNOLOGY ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY. AND ABILITY TO
SLICE AND DICE CUSTOMER LIST TO
IDENTIFY PRIME. CUSTOMERS TO
MAKE MONEY FOR PRIVATE SECTOR
FINANCE INSTITUTIONS. HAS
ACTUALLY INTENSIFIED THE NEEDS
OF LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
SO I THINK THIS IS REPRESENTS A
VERY IMPORTANT ALTERNATIVE IN A
MARKET PLACE. I FEEL IT MEETS
THE NEEDS OF. HELP SUPPORT ALL
OF OUR CALIFORNIANS MEET THEIR
FINANCIAL NEEDS AND I REGION I
WILL. THANK YOU MR COOLEY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MR
SANTIAGO YOU MAKE THIS. YEAH
AND I APPRECIATE ALL THOSE WHO
STOOD UP TO SPEAK AND I WANT TO
ONCE AGAIN SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR FOR THE BANK BANKING AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY FOR
HELPING US. MAKE IT A BETTER
BILL BUT BUT IT ALSO WANT TO
MENTION THAT WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE ON. AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE I TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
BROUGHT UP. BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND
APARTMENTS OF SEASON AS IT
RELATES TO BEING ABLE TO PAY
OUR RENT FROM. BANK CAL BUT
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR WHAT THIS
IS WOULD BE IS A GAME CHANGER
AND I SAID THIS A NUMBER OF
TALK PUBLICLY ABOUT IT REALLY
IS TRUE THAT WHEN A RICH PERSON
MAKES AND MAKES MONEY THAT
MONEY WORKS FOR THEM IT MAKES
MORE MONEY. WHEN SOMEBODY WAS
OF LOW INCOME MAKES MONEY THAT
DOLLARS GALLON FROM EVERY
CORNER FROM THE MINUTE YOU CASH
AT THE MINUTE THERE'S A PENALTY
FEE OVERDRAFT. FEES THAT WE'VE
NOW SEEN HISTORIC. A PROFITS.
ON ALL. FEES BY SOME OF THE
LARGEST BANKS. SO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AS ALLOW LOW
INCOME PEOPLE MOSTLY MINIMUM
WAGE. UNDERBANKED I'M DOCUMENT
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A PUBLIC
PLATFORM WHERE THERE'S NO FEES
AND THAT DOLLAR. IS NOT GALA
JUST AT EVERY CORNER THEY TURN.
AT SIMPLY IF I RESPECTFULLY. I
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. VERY WELL. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. OF A RESERVE AT THIS
REQUIRES. FORTY ONE. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY DESERVE.
ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD OF A.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
LIVING A FILE ITEM ONE TEN AB
TWELVE- FOR THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO MOBILE FOR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AND
OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE
HOSPITALS THIS WORKS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS. THE COURT
BEFORE COVER NINETEEN
COMMUNITIES F COLOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
AN EQUAL ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTHCARE. THE CDC IS FOUND
THAT RACISM IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
FUNDAMENTAL HEALTH INEQUITIES
AND DISPARITIES IN LIFE
EXPECTANCY. THIS PANDEMIC IS
FURTHER EXPOSING EXACERBATED
HIS INEQUITIES IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM DURING THIS
PANDEMIC WE HAVE SEEN BLACK
LATIN ACCENT INDIGENOUS PEOPLE
ARE AT INCREASED RISK OF
EXPOSURE ILLNESS
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH
RELATIVE TO THE SHARE OF THE
POPULATION. THEREFORE IT IS
IMPORTANT NOW MORE THAN EVER TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE COMPLETE
ACCURATE AND TRANSPARENT DATA
REPORTING IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY
AND RESPOND TO THE HEALTH
DISPARITIES WITHIN OUR STATE.
AB TROUBLE FOR REQUIRE THE
COLLECTION OF DATAON PATIENT
HEALTH OUTCOMES BY RACE
ETHNICITY AND OTHER
DEMOGRAPHICS THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRE COLLECTION OF WORK FOR
STATIC WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS DIVERSITY. AND STAFF
MANAGEMENT HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY WE'VE
ADDED- PRIVACY PROTECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT- BOTH THOSE THAT
RECEIVE CARE IN THAT WORK IN
HOSPITALS AND THEIR PRIVACY
GARDEN. I WITHOUT A. ROOM
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK MESS WITH. HERE
THERE FOR DEBATE ON THE COLOR
WILL OKAY THE ROLE. BOTH OF
THOSE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THAT ICE
FORTY TWO NO SEVENTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY IN FILE ITEM ONE
ELEVEN MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
TWELVE ONE TWELVE AB TWELVE
TWENTY EIGHT THE COURT AGREED
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
AND ACT WITHIN THE CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. IF YOU'RE WHAT YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE TWENTY EIGHT SIMPLY
ESTABLISHES A PROCEDURE TO
RELEASE INDIVIDUALS RETENTION
THAT ONLY FACE A VIOLATION OF
PROBATION AS NOTED IN THE
POLICY ANALYSIS EXISTING WAS
NOT CLEAR ON WHETHER OR NOT A
PERSON DETAINED ACCUSED OF
FILING A PROBATION HAS RIGHT TO
BAIL. PROBATION CURRENTLY
OPERATES UNDER A SEPARATE LEGAL
SYSTEM ONE WHERE THE BASIC
CIVIL RIGHT LIKE THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE THREE
DETENTION HEARINGS AND BURDEN
OF PROOF BEYOND A REASONABLE
DOUBT OR DISREGARDED THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE BY
DIRECTING THE COURTS TO RELEASE
PEOPLE DETAINED ON A VIOLATION
OF THEIR PROBATION UNLESS THEY
FIND AT. THE INDIVIDUAL WOULD
POSE A THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY
OR DETERMINE THAT THEIR FLIGHT
RISK AS YOU JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING THIS REASON REFORM
TO UPHOLD THE CORNERSTONE OF
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
WHICH IS THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE THERE IS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. AND I
CERTAINLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES. SEEING AND HEARING
FURTHER. ON THE COLOR WILL-
OPEN THE ROLE. VERY VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE
THIS REQUIRES FORTY ONE.
YEAH
CLERK WILL THE ROLLING TELEVOTE
EYES FORTY TWO KNOWS NINETEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MISTER
MATHIS IS PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL. ON ITEM TWENTY FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED INSTEAD
OF A. CERTIFIERS.
FORTY ONE-
ALL MEMBERS VOTED ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. MISTER
MATTHEWS THE CALL. MOVING THE
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN AB
TWELVE SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOME PEOPLE TWELVE SIXTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE
AND OTHERS IN THAT ROOM IN THE
GREENHOUSE GASES BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWELVE SIXTY
ONE CODIFIES RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE BY THE STATE AUDITOR IN A
RECENT REPORT. THE MEASURE
REQUIRES CARB THREE YEARS UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE DEVELOP A PROCESS
TO DEFINE AND COLLECT AND
EVALUATE DATA DEMONSTRATING THE
SOCIO ECONOMICAL BENEFITS THAT
RESULT FROM VARIOUS PROGRAMS
AND TO USE THIS DATA TO MAKE
FUNDING AND DESIGN
RECOMMENDATION IN ITS ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE THESE
ARE ALL RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
CARPET GREED WITH IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND THE BILL
SIMPLY ASKED THE BOARD TO KEEP
ITS COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. WE HAVE BEEN
COMMUNICATING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WILL CONTINUE
TO DO SO THIS BILL HAS HAD
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN ITEM.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. OF A- ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. WHERE
WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES WILL PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE
FOURTEEN WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN WILL PASS THE RETAIN
AND FILE ITEMS ONE SIXTEEN
THROUGH ONE EIGHTEEN MOVING THE
FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN AB
TWELVE NINETY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM AN ACCOLADE IN THE
PESTICIDES IF YOU'RE GOING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
CORRECTS A DRAFTING ERROR FROM
LAST YEAR'S AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. A BILL THAT I CARRIED
LAST YEAR THAT REGULATES THE
USE OF SECOND GENERATION ANTI
COAGULANT RODENTICIDES THAT'S A
MOUTHFUL AN IMPORTANT CHANGE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE- THANK YOU MISTER. C.
HEARING FURTHER TO ON THE
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
MEMBERS BOTH. OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL WHO LOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THAT ICE FIFTY
NINE TWO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WE'VE BEEN A FILE ITEM
WE DISPENSE WITH FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY SIX NINETY
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX NINETY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA AND ACTIVE IN
HEALING ARTS SECTOR REGULATOR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB SIX NINETY
WHICH WILL HELP US TO ADDRESS
THE SHORTAGE AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS BY CLARIFYING PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND OTHER
PSYCHOTHERAPY SETTING
DEFINITIONS THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE I. THINK YOU MISSED
ARAMBULA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THE-
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE A- CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW IT IS SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER MATHIS IS PREPARED TO
LET THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY
FOR THE CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
BURKE CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY THREE
KNOWS EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE WILL NOT
TAKE UP A FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB THREE EIGHTY NINE. THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
EIGHTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AND ACCLIMATING TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES.
MISTER GRIFFIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB THREE EIGHTY NINE
WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO ALLOW
AYE COUNTY TO CONTRACT FOR
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE SERVICES.
WITH THE FIRE PROTECTION
DISTRICT AND PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES THROUGH A WRITTEN SUB
CONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE
AMBULANCE SERVICE IN MY
DISTRICT CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
THE FIRE PROTECTION DISTRICT
PROVIDES NINE ONE ONE SERVE ME.
EMERGENCIES AMBULANCE SERVICES
TO NEARLY ONE MILLION COUNTY
RESIDENTS UNDER A LONG TERM
EXCLUSIVE OPERATING CONTRACT
WITH THE COUNTY UNDER A
SUBCONTRACT WITH AMERICAN
MEDICAL RESPONSE WEST. SINCE
THE INCEPTION OF THE FIRE EMS
ALLIANCE THE OVERALL LEVEL OF
INEFFICIENCY AND OPERATIONS
CLINICAL QUALITY IN RESPONSE
TIMES HAVE IMPROVED
TREMENDOUSLY AND SERVES AS AN
EFFECTIVE MODEL FOR OTHER
COUNTIES TO BASE THEIR
PARTNERSHIPS OFF OF. AB THREE
EIGHTY NINE WILL GUARANTEE TAT
COUNTIES RETAIN THIS ABILITY TO
CONTRACT FOR EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE SERVICES WITH A FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT AND TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES THROUGH
A SUBCONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE
AMBULANCE SERVICE THIS WILL
ALSO ENSURE THAT THIS PROVEN
EFFECTIVE SUBCONTRACTING MODEL.
FOR EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
DEPLOYMENT SYSTEMS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN OPTION FOR
OTHER COUNTIES TO DEVELOP
SIMILAR SUBCONTRACTING SYSTEMS
IN THE FUTURE I AM AWARE OF
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS AND HAVE
MADE COMMITMENTS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IMPACTED BY AB
THREE EIGHT NINE. THAT I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE BILL TO
INSURE THAT WE INCLUDE
AMENDMENTS THAT ALL PARTIES CAN
AGREE UPON I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER GRIFFIN AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS BOTH. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW
THAT ICE FORTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR AB SIX OH FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ. SOME BILLS SIX
OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
INOCULATING TRANSPORTATION A
MAKING OF OPERATION ARE FOR MR
DAILY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THE
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS IN THE
ROAD MAINTENANCE AND
REHABILITATION ACCOUNT. REMAIN
DEDICATED FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE SAFE AND RELIABLE ROADS
THIS BILL A CLARIFIES HOW THE
INTEREST MONEY ON THE ACCOUNT
WILL BE SPENT. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER DALY MISTER FRAZIER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MATTER SPEAKER ONE
REALLY APPLAUD THE- MY
COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING THIS
FORTH THIS IS ONE OF THE SMALL
ITEMS IN SB ONE THAT WE DID
NOT. DEFINE AND THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO MAKE SURE
THE SHOP IS CONTINUALLY FUNDED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
NONMEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL LOSE THEIR ROLE
IN HOWEVER I FIFTY SIX NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
X. AB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN BURKE
WILL READ. SOME REAL SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN BY SOME MCCARTY
INOCULATING STATE PROPERTY.
YEAH YOU'RE RIGHT MR MCCARTY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
IN A SPEAKER THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL WHICH WOULD TRANSFER SOON
TO BE SURPLUS PROPERTY IS
CURRENTLY OCCUPIED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA DAVIS TO
HELP WITH STUDENT HOUSING AS WE
LOOK TO EXPAND THE UC DAVIS
CAMPUS HERE INSACRAMENTO TELL
BUT TWO KEY ISSUES IN OUR
DISTRICT. HOUSING AND
GENTRIFICATION WITH HIGHER
EDUCATION GROWTH HERE AS WELL
AS MAKING SURE WE EXPAND ACCESS
TO THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU ASK THE RIVA. THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY SEEING HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS BOTH USER TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
PAUL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THAT I. SIXTY NOTES
HERE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO NEED TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACT WITHIN THE SOLID
WASTE THE THREE MEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. WE ALL
KNOW THAT IN THE LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF CODED THAT THE USE
OF ONLINE RETAILERS HAS REALLY
SKYROCKETED. AND ALONG WITH
THAT HAS COME THE ASSOCIATED
PROBLEM OF PLASTIC PACKAGING
MATERIAL AND POLY STYRENE.
WHICH IS NOT RECYCLED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALMOST
ANYWHERE. FILLING UP OUR
LANDFILLS. CAUSING OUR
MUNICIPAL IN OUR WEIGHT PAYER
RATE PAYERS. TO HAVE TO DEAL
BECAUSE- OF THOSE- THOSE
LANDFILLS. GOING BEYOND. AND
HAVING TO A HAVING TO THAT MUCH.
FURTHER IN FOR AWAY. FROM WHERE
PEOPLE ARE USING IT. UP BUYING
NOT REALIZE THAT THAT. THAT TEN
THAT WIDGET THAT TOY COULD ALSO
COME WITH A SEA OF PLASTIC. AND
ALL OF THIS IS A NECESSARY OR
MOST OF IT IS UNNECESSARY
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WE ALSO
HAVE. MEANT MATERIALS THAT ARE
ALTERNATIVE MATERIALS THAT ARE
SUSTAINABLE AND THAT ARE
RECYCLABLE AND IN FACT MANY OF
OUR ONLINE SHOPPERS ARE ALREADY
TRANSFER ARE TRANSFORMING TO
USING THOSE MATERIALS. I BY
CLOTHING ONLINE SOMETIMES IT'S
VERY RARE NOW THAT THAT
CLOTHING COMES WRAPPED IN
PLASTIC. NOW THEY COME IN A
RECYCLE GARMENT BAGS BUT SOME
OF OUR LARGEST ONLINE RETAILERS
ARE USING ALL KINDS OF
ALTERNATIVES THAT ARE MORE
SUSTAINABLE. THIS BILL SIMPLY
SAYS THAT BY A DATE CERTAIN
WITHIN A FEW YEARS ON LARGE
ONLINE RETAILERS WILL HAVE TO
USE RECYCLABLE PACKING MATERIAL
AND CAN NO LONGER USE THE NON
RECYCLABLE MATERIALS. THAT
RIGHT NOW WE'RE FILLING UP OUR
LANDFILLS. NOW MEMBERS I WILL
ADMIT TO YOU THAT THIS BILL IS
A WORK IN PROGRESS. OUR GOAL IS
NOT TO BE PUNITIVE NOT TO MAKE
LIFE IMPOSSIBLE FOR THESE
RETAILERS BUT INSTEAD. TO PUSH
THEM TO MAKE THE TRANSITION. IN
WHICH THEY ARE ALREADY
EMBARKING ON. TO PUSH THEM TO
DO THE INVESTMENT IN OUR ANTI
TRUMP SWEPT THERE IS. A MOVE
THEIR MACHINERY OVER. AT A
FASTER RATE THAN THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING BUT BELIEVE ME
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ALREADY HAPPENING IN THE MARKET
PLACE AND THAT IS DOABLE. NOW
FOR SHIPPERS THAT HAVE MORE
SPECIALTY ITEMS ARE ITEMS WHERE
THERE'S NOT AS MANY
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE. WE HAVE
BEEN TAKING AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO TAKE THOSE
MEASUREMENTS. I AM MYSELF IS
APARTMENT ON LINE RETAILER. FOR
YEARS I SOLD VERY DELICATE
BREAKABLE- CLASS THROUGH THE
INTERNET AND SHIFTED ALL AROUND
THE WORLD I UNDERSTAND HOW HARD
IT IS TO SHIP SOME ITEMS. WE
ARE TRYING TO WRITE THIS BILL
INTAKE AMENDMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR ONLINE
RETAILERS. FEEL THAT THEY CAN
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS OF THE
BILL AND THOSE THAT HAVE COME
TO US AND SAID THEY NEED A
LONGER LEAD TIME OR THEY NEED
AN EXEMPTION. WE HAVE BEEN
GETTING A LOT OF THOSE IN THE
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
DOABLE FOR ALL OF THOSE
RETAILERS. WE ALREADY TOOK A
MOMENT TO GIVE A LONGER
TIMELINE FOR ELECTRONIC
EQUIPMENT. WHEN I WROTE THE
BILL I MADE SURE TO EXEMPT OUT
CERTAIN SPECIALTY RETAILERS
WHERE I KNEW THIS WOULD BE A
HARDSHIP. WE ARE LOOKING AT
LANGUAGE NOW TO EXEMPT OUT
PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS THAT
NEED TO BE KEPT AT A AT A
CONTROLLED TEMPERATURE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS ACHIEVABLE
FOR EVERYBODY THAT'S THE GOAL
IS NOT TO BE PUNITIVE. IT'S NOT
TO STOP ONLINE RETAIL. WHAT THE
COUNTRY IT'S TO ALLOW THE
GROWTH OF ONLINE RETAIL BUT THE
WAY THAT PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
EXPECT WHICH IS IN A WAY THAT
IS SUSTAINABLE. AND THAT LEAVES
THE COUNTRY. IN IN TERMS OF
BEING RECYCLABLE. WITHOUT
MEMBERS WE WILL CONTINUE TO
TAKE A MEMBERS I'D I'D GIVE YOU
ALL MY WORD THAT IS WE GOING TO
THE SENATE WE WILL PROACTIVELY
REACH OUT EVEN TO THE INDUSTRY
GROUPS THAT HAVEN'T REACHED OUT
TO US TO SAY. IS THIS DOABLE
FOR YOU DO YOU NEED ANY HELP
WITH ANY OF THIS DO YOU NEED A
LONGER TIMELINE DO YOU NEED AN
EXEMPTION FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
PRODUCTS THAT ARE. PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE. AND WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS WE DON'T
WANT TO STOP ONLINE RETAIL WE
JUST WANT TO HAVE. THOSE
SITUATIONS STOP WE'RE ALL OF US
ARE WONDERING WHY THAT HAD WE
GOTTEN THE MAIL IS COVERED IN
YARDS AND YARDS OF BUBBLE WRAP.
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MYSTERY
MINISTRY BEST YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED- THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE AS
CHAIR OF NATURAL RESOURCES- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY ONE AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
THAT WILL PHASE OUT CERTAIN
SINGLE USE PLASTIC PACKAGING
FOR THE E. COMMERCE INDUSTRY.
SINGLE USE PACKAGING IS ONLY
USED ONCE YET ACT ITS
CONSUMPTION DAMAGES OUR STATE
AND CONSTITUENTS FOR CENTURIES
AFTERWARDS THE IMPACT TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT CANNOT BE IGNORED
AS WE CONTINUE TO SHIFT HOW WE
PURCHASE OUR PRODUCTS WE MUST
ENSURE. WE DO IT IN THE MOST
SUSTAINABLE WAY POSSIBLE I WANT
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
FROM GLENDALE FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MESS RIVAS. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON. THE
MATTER THREE THIRTY WICKS POST
NO NO I THINK THAT IS MY
CLOSELY OKAY THANK YOU CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR ALL. MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE THE. SMALL
MEMBERS SAID HE WAS THERE TO
VOTE. ON NUMBERS VERY ABOUT
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. ON
OVER THIRTY DESERVE BOTH CARS.
FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS THIRTY
DESERVE A. THREE NUMBER OF THE
CALL. WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM. TWENTY EIGHT. OUR.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME OF THE ONE
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AND OTHERS
MACKLIN IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS MR GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MASTER
YOUR COLLEAGUES THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO FUND THE EXPANSION
OF EXISTING NETWORKS FOR FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS THAT
SUPPORTS CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
THANK YOU MR GARCIA SEEING
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS BOTH.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TAYLOR I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. FORTY SEVEN WE WILL NOW
TAKE A FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME OF ELEVEN
NINETY ONE BY SOME MCCARTY AND
ACTIVATING THE FIREARMS MR
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
MEASURE TO ADDRESS GUN VIOLENCE
IN OUR STATE WE KNOW WE HAVE AN
EPIDEMIC WHICH WITH TOO MANY.
GUNS GETTING IN THE WRONG HANDS
WE ALSO KNOW THAT ABOUT 75% OF
ALL. CRIME GUNS ORIGINATE FROM
A GUN DEALERS FROM WITHIN THIS
STATE AND ABOUT 5% OF THE GUN
DEALERS ARE RESPONSIBE FOR
ABOUT 90% OF ALL- GUN. GUNS
RECOVERED AT CRIME SCENES THIS
WOULD TASK OUR DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO FURTHER ANALYZE GUN
DATA. TO HELP US UNDERSTAND HOW
GUNS HOW CRIME GUNS ARE SOLD IN
TRAFFIC AND HOPEFULLY REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR STATE ASK
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR MCCARTY. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK THEM. ALL
MEMBERS BOTH. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. WHERE WILL.
WHO KNOWS THE ROLE AND TALLIED
ABOUT ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS
WILL BE ENTERTAINING VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME HE LIKE A
VOTE CHANGES PLEASE RAISE YOUR
MIKE AND I WILL CALL ON YOU.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOUR VOTE CHANGE.
FOLLOW NINETY TO A BEFORE
EIGHTY FROM EITHER NOT VOTING.
BURKE CHANGE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOPER ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
EIGHTY- IT'S ABOUT BUILDING
FIFTIES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER IS THERE MIKE DOES NOT
APPEAR TO BE WORKING. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES EIGHTY SIX TWO
FIVE CHANGES FROM OPPOSITION
TONIGHT. VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVIES ASSEMBLE SIX ONE
FIVE NO TÁI. MISTER
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ZERO CHANGE. CUNNINGHAM AB
SEVEN TWENTY ONE NO TÁI. VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM SOME LEGAL SEVEN
TWENTY ONE NO TÁI. MISTER
CHANG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ZERO
CHANGE THANK YOU AB ONE TWO
FOUR FROM KNOWN TO NOT VOTING.
MR CHAN DEMANDER MR CHAN. CAN
YOU PLEASE REPEAT THAT WE HAD
OUR TIME HERE YOU. EXCUSE ME
CAN YOU REPEAT THE VOTE
CHANGING- AB ONE TWO FOUR FROM
NOTE TO NOTE VOTING. PRO CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE TWENTY FOUR NO TO NOT
VOTING MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR VOTING. MEDINA
FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB SEVEN
TWENTY ONE NOTE TO AYE- CHANGE
THE SUMMER MEDINA ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN TWENTY ONE NO TO I'D.
MEMBERS. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM. TWELVE AB EIGHT
ELEVEN KERKORIAN. SOME REAL
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THREE OF US ANAK LEVINE AS
TRANSPORTATION THE THREE OF US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT ELEVEN
SIX TO STREAMLINE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY'S
PROJECT DELIVERY AS LOS ANGELES
PREPARES FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
GAMES THIS MEASURE WILL BRING
LA METRO'S ENABLING STATUTES IN
ACCORD WITH ALL OTHER TRANSIT
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA BY
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENT THAT
THE L. A. METRO BOARD. APPROVED
BY A TWO THIRDS VOTE LA METRO'S
ABILITY TO UTILIZE DESIGN BUILD
AS A METHOD OF PROJECT DELIVERY
AB EIGHT ELEVEN HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS. OUR SUPPORT AND
POLICY COMMITTEES AND HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
RIVERA SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AMERICA. ALL
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD VOTE.
WHERE WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THEY THAT I SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS WHEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY NINE. AB EIGHT FIFTEEN
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE EIGHT FIFTEEN BY
ASSUMING A RELEASE RIVAS AND
ACTIVATING THE SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
THE SERVICE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER UNDER
CURRENT LAW AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
WANTS TO BECOME A SCHOOL NURSE
MUST HOLD A BACHELOR'S DEGREE A
NURSING LICENSE AND A SCHOOL
NURSING CREDENTIAL ONLY FOR
UNIVERSITIES IN THE ENTIRE
STATE OFFER PROGRAMS THAT CAN
GRANT THE SCHOOL NURSE
CREDENTIALS. AB EIGHT FIFTEEN
WILL HELP ALLEVIATE THE SCHOOL
NURSE SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA BY
EXPLICITLY STATING THAT ELEAZAR
ARE AUTHORIZED TO OFFER IN
HOUSE SCHOOL NURSE
CREDENTIALING PROGRAMS TO
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES THESE L.
E. A. SPONSORED PROGRAMS WOULD
HAVE TO BE APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION ON TEACHER
CREDENTIALING ADDITIONALLY AB
EIGHT FIFTEEN WOULD REQUIRE
ELLIE A SPONSORED CREDENTIALING
PROGRAMS. TO MEET THE SAME
QUALITY STANDARDS AND RIGOR AS
THOSE EXPECTED OF POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS THAT CURRENTLY
OFFER THE PROGRAMS AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN HAS HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN FISCAL AND POLICY
COMMITTEES. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS REAVIS SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF A-
RIGHT. ON MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. MURATSUCHI. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES WE WILL NOW
TAKE UP FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN.
AB SEVEN FIFTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE SEVEN
FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY WERE
MCCARTY AND ACCLIMATE TO
ELECTIONS MCCARTY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THIS BILL IS A MEASURE
TO INCREASE DEMOCRACY IN OUR
COUNTY ELECTIONS. THIS WILL
PROMOTE EQUALITY ENHANCE
CITIZEN PARTICIPATION BY
ALIGNING OUR COUNTY WIDE
ELECTIONS- WITH OUR
PRESIDENTIAL ACTIONS WE KNOW
THAT TURNOUT IS MUCH LOWER
DURING THE OFF YEAR ELECTIONS
IN SACRAMENTO WE HAVE A ROUGHLY
16% HIGHER TURNOUT. IN
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS AND
GUBERNATORIAL YEARS IN LOS
ANGELES IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. THE ISSUES RELATED TO
OUR COUNTY GOVERNMENTS ARE
GROUNDED IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WE SHOULD BE ENSURING THAT THE
MOST AMOUNT OF PEOPLE IN THESE
COMMUNITIES VOTE FOR THESE
IMPORTANT ELECTIONS ASK YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CARTY MR MOWING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS JUST- ADDED MY
THANKS TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE. HOW THESE COUNTY WIDE
ELECTED OFFICIALS- SHOULD HAVE
THESE ELECTIONS OCCUR DURING
PRESIDENTIAL CYCLES WHEN THE-
ELECTORATE MORE CLOSELY
RESEMBLES THE POPULATION AS A
WHOLE WHEN YOU HAVE HIGHER
TURNOUT ELECTIONS. IT'S MORE
DEMOCRATIC MORE REPRESENTATIVE
YOU CAN DIVERSIFY YOUR A LECTIN
OFFICIALS POOL IT'S A GOOD
THING FOR DEMOCRACY I APPLAUD
MY COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING IT
AND I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR MINISTER BENNETT
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR HI. AMANDA SPEAKER.
I RISE ALSO WOULD SUPPORT. AND
I'VE THINK I'VE RECOGNIZE VERY
MUCH THAT THERE BEEN MANY TIMES
WHEN THE COUNTY ELECTED
OFFICIALS DO NOT REFLECT. OF
THE POPULATION THAT THEY SERVE
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
IN THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER BENNETT SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTE. TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE
IT. CLOSE THE ROLE AND HOW THAT
ICE FORTY FIVE KNOWS NINETEEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
NOT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO FIVE
ITEM. AB TWO FIVE A THIRD WILL
READ. SOME PEOPLE TO FOR FIVE
ASSEMBLY RUMOR CG INACCURATELY
WHEN I REALLY THIS AMERICAN SHE
WORKED. THANK YOU MUCH I
PRESENTE TWO FIVE WHICH IS THE
CLOVER NINETEEN SMALL BIZ A
VIXEN RELIEF PACK. AS WE ALL
KNOW DEPEND WAS DEVASTATING TO
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES OVER 40%
OF SMALL BUSINESSES MANY MOM
AND POP STORES AND RESTAURANTS
ARE CURRENTLY AT RISK OF
SHUTTING DOWN IF THEY HAVE NOT
IF THEY HAVE NOT ALREADY SHUT
DOWN. WITH PARTICULARLY HARD
IMPACTS AND MANY IMMIGRANT AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. WALERY
TRYING HAS BEEN RE OPENING
SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE
RESIDENTIAL TENANTS CONTINUE TO
BE SADDLED. WITH MASSIVE DEBT
OF UNPAID RENT. LAST FALL I
WENT ON A TOUR OF LOCAL SMALL
BUSINESSES AND I WAS STRUCK BY
HOW THEY WERE SAYING MANY OF
THE SAME THINGS THAT WE'RE
HEARING FROM RESIDENTIAL
TENANTS. GIVE US SOME
FLEXIBILITY AND PAYING BACK THE
RENT WE NEED OUR LANDLORDS TO
WORK WITH US WELL I HEAR THE SO
CALLED GOOD LANDLORDS ARE
NEGOTIATING FLEXIBILITY TO
AVOID VACANT PROPERTIES WITH NO
RENTAL INCOME. I WAS SURPRISED
AND DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR SO
MANY REFUSING TO NEGOTIATE.
THIS BILL IS A SIMPLE MEASURE
WOULD SIX IT ENCOURAGE
COMMERCIAL LANDLORDS TO DO THE
RIGHT THING TO SIMPLY ENGAGE IN
A GOOD FAITH NEGOTIATION BEFORE
THEY EVICTED THEIR SMALL
BUSINESS TENANTS. THIS BILL
TAKES A BALANCED APPROACH TO
ENCOURAGE COMMERCIAL LANDLORDS
TO DO THE RIGHT THING. WELL AT
THE SAME TIME RECOGNIZE THAT
LANDLORDS HAVE TO PAY THEIR
BILLS AND THAT THEY SHOULD NOT
BE REQUIRED TO GO INTO
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP THEMSELVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MERRETT SU
CHI'S C. HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE OF A CAR WILL OF
THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF THE- ALL
MEMBERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESERVE IT THIS
REQUIRES FORTY ONE.
IT'S
DIRECTED TO MISS THE CALL.
MISTER CHOW YOUR FOR MOTIONS AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR'S
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO THE AN ACTIVE FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB FOURTEEN NINETY
ONE MCCARTY ITEM FORTY ONE
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN MCCARTY
ITEM SIXTY NINE AB TWELVE FIFTY
TWO CHILD AND ITEM SEVENTY
THREE EIGHTY THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT MCCARTY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. MEMBERS WE ARE
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM. SIXTY AB ELEVEN
THIRTY NINE THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS SAID HE'S VERY
VOCAL. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLIED ABOUT EYES
TWENTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY SIX
THAT MEASURE FAILS. WITH
CARRILLO FOR PURPOSE THE REST
AFTER RECONSIDERING. WITHOUT
AND. NOW I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTEEN AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE
OF HER COMPOSED. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. IS THAT
CORRECT. THIS FRIEDMAN IS A.
MEMBERS WE WILL TAKE UP FILE
ITEM SIXTY SIX AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
IMMACULATE IN THE PUBLIC FOR
SECONDARY EDUCATION. THIS
BERNARD BACK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWELVE
FIFTEEN TAKES NECESSARY
COMMONSENSE STEPS TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE U
ADMISSIONS PROCESS.
PARTICULARLY IN ATHLETICS THE
MISSIONS WHICH ARE ESPECIALLY
VULNERABLE TO ABUSE THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT DONATIONS AND
PERSONAL CONNECTIONS ARE NOT
CONSIDERED IN EMISSIONS
DECISION. REQUIRES UC CAMPUSES
TO REPORT ON THEIR POLITICAL
AMBITIONS PROTOCOLS AND
OUTCOMES TO PREVENT FRAUD.
REQUIRES THE UC TO CONDUCT
REGULAR INTERNAL AUDITS OF THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS THESE AT UC
CAMPUSES THE TWENTY NINETEEN
VARSITY BLUES COLLEGE EMISSIONS
SCANDAL AND SUBSEQUENT STATE
AUDIT OF THE UC EMISSION
SYSTEM. SHOWS THAT EMISSIONS
FRAUD REMAINS A PREVALENT AND
URGENT ISSUE RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA EVEN IN THE MIDST OF
A GLOBAL NINETY COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC THE UC RECEIVED AN ALL
TIME RECORD HIGH NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS. FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE EMISSION ESTIMATED
AT NEARLY TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND APPLICANTS I
INTRODUCED THIS BILL WITH MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM
SACRAMENTO BECAUSE WE EACH
BELIEVE THAT EACH ONE OF THOSE
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
APPLICANTS. DESERVES A FAIR
SHOT. FOR EVERY STUDENT OMITTED
IN EXCHANGE FOR DONATIONS OR AS
A FAVOR TO A FRIEND OR A FAMILY
A QUALIFIED STUDENT LOSES THEIR
SPOT. THIS BILL TOGETHER WITH
MY BILL AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
THREE ONE CREASE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY TO PREVENT FRAUD
IN THE UC EMISSION SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB TWELVE FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER HALF. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THAT THE COURT WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON A VOTE. HONG VOTED TO
THEIR. TO BURKE WILL LOSE THE
ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE I SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF ITEMS STILL ON CALL
BUT WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE WILL MOVE
TO THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR I BELIEVE THERE
RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S CONSENT
CALENDAR. BEFORE WE VOTE WE
WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTION THAT IS ON CONSENT
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ADDING CO
AUTHORS. CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DAHLE
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA'S
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS
AND PROGRAMS ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
BY SIMPLY RIVER CHOI RELATIVE
TO SECURE LOW DAY ANISSA MAKING
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON RELATIVES
CALIFORNIA FISHING AND BOATING
WEEK. CLICK ON THE OVER THE
ROLE. THAT ON AS A CO AUTHOR TO
THE RESOLUTIONS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHOR.
ON THE RESOLUTION ON CONSENT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE- SIXTY
EIGHT CO AUTHORS ADDED.
EVERYONE THEM- TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT ALENDAR DOES HAVE MADE
ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND EXAM
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA'S
REGIONAL OCCUPATIONAL CENTERS
AND PROGRAMS. CALDERON THIS IS
A VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTED
WHICH TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS TO VOTE. WELL. CLOTHES
ARE ALL TIED UP ISAACSON TWO.
NO ZERO. CLARCOR READER ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY. I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX I SEVENTY
TWO. NO. ZERO AND WE'RE.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARE TO LIFT
THE CALL. ON THE ITEMS THAT ARE.
ON CALL. LET'S LET THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY ONE MS
FRIEDMAN CARPOOL POST. ALL
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. WHO WISH TO VOTE.
CLOTHES ARE ALL TIED UP I THREE
FIVE KNOWS TWENTY ONE THAT
MEASURE FAILS AND MISS FRIEDMAN
NOTICES RECONSIDERATION.
ONE
OKAY. AND. POSTED ON. SINCE SO
IF YOU. MEMBERS ARE PREPARED
AND OUT OF THE CALL ON FILE AT
FOURTEEN AB TWO FIFTY FIVE
MURATSUCHI THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. TWENTY SEVEN OF
TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE FAILS
IN MID MISTER MURATSUCHI
NOTICES RECONSIDERATION. OKAY
MEMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
THURSDAY JUNE THE THIRD FLOOR
SESSIONS AT TEN AM. THERE IS I
BELIEVE THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS. BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS. THIRTY MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT SO THAT'S THIRTY
MINUTES FROM RIGHT NOW. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED TO RETAIN. ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING OVER THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. BIZRATE'S MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
TOMORROW THURSDAY JUNE THE
THIRD AT TEN AM IN THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.